Hallo Stefan. Was hast du den Tag gemacht?
Ich habe auf einem Podium gesessen.
Kein Klimathema?
Kein Klimathema und auch kein Klimareferendum für mich.
Okay, gut, was auf einem Podium.
Dazu kommen wir ja nachher noch. Also ich werde nicht anfangen, mich selbst zu zitieren, aber ich werde etwas spielen, was davor stattfand, nämlich beim ersten Panel war Adam Tooze da und der hat eine sensationelle Rede gehalten, eine Rede gehalten, die erschütternd ist, die mich wirklich erschüttert hat, als ich dort saß. Und deswegen müssen wir darauf eingehen, das war eine Veranstaltung der IG Metall, eben Friedrich Eberthaus und die IG Metall hatten mir auf freundlicher Weise schon, ehe es veröffentlicht ist, den Mitschnitt zur Verfügung gestellt, sodass wir jetzt dann nachher Clips hören können. Aber in Berlin war ja auch dieser Klimaentscheid und das Quorum wurde nicht erreicht, das heißt, es sind nicht genügend Leute überhaupt zur Wahl gegangen. Und dann war es auch noch so, dass diese Wahl knapp für diesen Entscheid ausgegangen ist, aber nun jetzt ja nicht gereicht hat, aber auch nur knapp. Und das ist ja doch erstaunlich, denn als ich hörte, es gibt da diesen Entscheid und dann gab es ja von den üblichen Prominenten dazu Werbung, dachte ich, naja, das wird wohl so auf 90 Prozent Zustimmung hinauslaufen. Immerhin ist es ja Berlin. Wir haben ja alle unser Berlin-Klischee kultiviert, ich besonders vielleicht. Und dann dachte ich, dort will man die autofreie Innenstadt, dort will man weiß ich nicht was, aber nichts da. Also noch nicht mal das Quorum erfüllt. Und dann auch nur knapp hat man überhaupt jetzt mal da eine Mehrheit in der Minderheit gehabt.
Seit 2021 möchte die EU handelspolitisch auf offene strategische Autonomie setzen. Mit diesem Begriff möchte ich mich zunächst in den ersten fünf Minuten auseinandersetzen. Denn das klingt zunächst wie einen Widerspruch. Wie kann man gleichzeitig offen sein und seine Selbständigkeit? Das heißt, Autonomie bewahren sind Heteronomie und Autonomie nicht Widersprüche.
Und man denkt, was macht er jetzt? Jetzt kommt so eine Begriffsbestimmung. Dann versucht er, das so ein bisschen zu historisieren. Er nimmt Bezug auf Macron, der die NATO als Hirntod bezeichnet hat. Und der auch sagte, Europa muss da unabhängiger werden. Das war alles so in der Reaktion auf die Trump-Wahl. Folgende Worte findet Tooze dafür.
Das Ganze hatte einen französischen Flair, muss man sagen. Ein bisschen gaulistisch ist Europa geworden in diesem Moment.
Nun, was hatte Europa eigentlich vor?
Noch Ende 2020 schien es so, als würden Berlin, Paris und Brüssel einen eigenen Weg für sich bahnen wollen mit dem Comprehensive Agreement on Investment. Das wurde aber durch die Sanktionspolitik des Europäischen Parlaments und die Reaktion der Chinesen darauf blockiert. Dann kam Putin und dann kam, und das ist der nächste Punkt, auf den ich wirklich betonen möchte, dann kam der hochstrategische und umfassende Versuch der Biden-Administration, Europa in seine Blockbildung gegen China einzuspannen.
Und Tooze, sag noch mal, es geht nicht nur um Begriffe jetzt hier.
Es sind nicht nur Begriffe, über die wir reden, in anderen Worten es sind auch Emotionen und Geschichtsbilder und politische Visionen im Spiel. Das aber war 2021. Nun ist es mit dem Krieg ernst, und zwar in zweifacher Hinsicht.
Inwiefern ist es denn ernst mit dem Krieg?
Europa denkt natürlich vor allem an Ukraine. Putins Invasion erteilt die harte Lektion, dass in einer multipolaren Welt auch andere die Umgangsformen bestimmen können, dass nicht nur der Westen sich seine Kriege aussuchen kann und dass die Gewalt von anderen den eigenen Freiraum massiv einschränken kann, was wiederum die eigene Handlungsfähigkeit prämiert. Der Kernpunkt für unsere allgemeine Diskussion heute nachmittags scheint mir, dass die russische Aggression schockierend, wie sie sein mag, keine fundamentalen Zielkonflikte aufwirft, zumindest auf mittelfristiger Sicht. Im Gegenteil, sicherheitspolitische, wirtschaftspolitische, energiepolitische und klimapolitische Überlegungen, demokratiepolitische Überlegungen darüber hinaus drängen alle in eine Richtung zur größtmöglichen Beschneunigung der Energiewende.
So, da könnte man ja erst mal sagen, also der Krieg in der Ukraine verändert nicht so viel beziehungsweise, naja, es hat sich dann herausgestellt, dass das doch keine gute Idee war, so abhängig zu sein von Russland und so Sachen. Aber grundsätzlich geopolitisch ist da nicht was ganz Neues mit entstanden, sondern da sind ja eigentlich noch die die Lager alt Vertraute. Der eigentliche Konflikt ist nun ein anderer.
Nämlich die Auseinandersetzung zwischen China und den USA, in Ostasien und vor allem über Taiwan. Ich wähle meine Worte hier bewusst dramatisch. Unterschätzen sie bitte das Risiko nicht. In Washington redet man unentwegt darüber, nicht nur über Wettbewerb und Rivalität, sondern über einen Krieg mit China. Einer schießenden Auseinandersetzung. Unentwegt und offen.
Aber wer? Die Regierungsweise Haus oder was?
Er wurde noch mehrmals dann dazu gefragt, ob er jetzt die Republikaner speziell meint. Nein, er meint nicht die Republikaner speziell, er meint die Demokraten. Er wird es gleich nochmal deutlich machen. Er ist ja jemand, der sehr viel bereit, der in internen Talks ist. Wir werden da auch gleich noch so eine kleine Anekdote von hören. Und er ist also gleich mit beiden Administrationen und den Thinktanks und Beratern und was es da gibt. Also er ist da mitten drin quasi als Externer und kriegt also diese Debatten mit.
Also die Hillary Clinton ist ja damals, bevor sie nicht gewählt wurde, hat sie ihre Außenpolitik einmal dargelegt, ihr pazifisches Zeitalter und so weiter. Das war ja schon sehr auf Konfrontation gebürstet, aber eben noch also auch wenn ich jetzt so beiden höre, klingt das ja immer noch sehr nach. Das ist ein Systemkonflikt, den wir sozusagen nach den Spielregeln der Ökonomie und so weiter entscheiden. Eine schießende Auseinandersetzung, in der man jetzt wirklich sich gegenseitig die Flugzeugträger davon, aber das meint er so.
Das meint er so und eine Woche später im Handelsblatt Mittwoch 29. März ist dann hier USA spielen China-Attacke gegen Taiwan durch und da gibt es jetzt ein 156-seitiges Paper eines Thinktanks, das eine Denkfabrik in Washington, die mal durchgespielt hat, wie das dann zu verlaufen hat und da geht es dann um das Manöver. Was würde dann eigentlich dabei passieren? Wer würde wie angreifen? Welche U-Boote benötigt man? Das wird also alles komplett hier durchgespielt, das wird dann ein bisschen erläutert, Handelsblatt. Und dann heißt es hier auch Dutzende von Schiffen, Hunderte von Flugzeugen und Zehntausende von Soldaten würde die USA einbüßen dabei. Taiwan sieht seine Wirtschaft am Boden zerstört, heißt es in dem Szenarienpaper. Und die globale Position der USA ist über viele Jahre hinweg geschädigt, aber es wäre dann eben damit verhindert, also man glaubt, dass man siegen könnte dann gegen China, dass Taiwan nicht eingenommen wird. Also das ist etwas, was direkt durchgespielt wird. Und das ist sehr beängstigend und man liest es vielfach jetzt im Handelsblatt zum Beispiel oder auch in anderen Wirtschaftszeitungen liest man, dass diese Handelskrieg, der geführt wird oder der Protektionismus, doch sehr viel weitreichender ist. Und Tooze führt das jetzt weiter aus und das war wirklich das Erstaunliche. Adam Tooze ist ein linker, Keynesianisch angehauchter Wirtschaftshistoriker, der nicht für Alarmismus bekannt ist.
Der nennt schon gerne große Zahlen, aber...
Genau, er nennt gerne große Zahlen, aber er ist jetzt nicht derjenige, der als Cassandra durch die Gegend turrt und er ist da bei der IG Metall. Er spricht dort zu einem kleinen Publikum, aber mit einer großen Offenherzigkeit, mit einer ungeheuren Leidenschaft und das klingt dann weiter so.
Das eigentlich Ungeheuerliche, das undenkbare Szenario wird zunehmend banalisiert. Es gibt viele auch an entscheidenden Stellen im amerikanischen Militär, für die es nicht mehr eine Frage des Ob, sondern des Wann ist. Und hoffen sie bitte nicht auf einen Sinneswandel. Die Dynamik läuft schon über ein Jahrzehnt. Es ging schon zu Obamas Zeiten los. Wie der Ballon Zwischenfall Anfang des Jahres zeigt, hat es nun fast den Charakter eines Selbstläufers. Die Leute in Washington wissen selbst nicht so recht, wie es zu diesem Skandal kam, was eigentlich noch beunruhigender ist, sein sollte. Und eine Entspannung, selbst wenn es dazu kommt, wäre wie im Kalten Krieg eine Sache von Jahren, wenn nicht von Jahrzehnten. Und wie viel Zeit haben wir eigentlich noch, wenn wir zum Beispiel an die Klimakrise denken?
Mit anderen Worten, wir sind mitten in diesem Konflikt schon drin.
Ich bin ein bisschen skeptisch.
Wir hatten doch vom Wirtschaftsministerium, von Habeck schon, ist doch ein Paper geleakt worden, das da auch vom Handelsblatt veröffentlicht wurde vor ein paar Monaten, wo es darum ging, wie sich Deutschland abnabeln könnte, wenn China sich Taiwan nimmt. Das heißt, diese Szenarien sind sehr, sehr deutlich auf dem Tisch. Wir hatten auch mal, ich glaube, es war 2020, haben wir schon mal über diesen Konflikt gesprochen, mit dem, mit diesem Begriff Turkididis-Falle. Also wie kann es sein, dass eine Welt macht, die andere ablöst, ohne dass es zu einem Krieg kommt. Das ist ja das von Turkididis formulierte Problem und das ist etwas, was ThinkTanks auseinander beschäftigt. Und dann hatte ich damals von der Rosa-Luxemburg-Stiftung einen Text in Auszügen hier vorgelesen, in Clips, von Inga Solty. Und was Solty da geschrieben hat vor etwa zwei Jahren, ist ziemlich nah an dem, was Adam Tooze jetzt hier erzählt, aus dem Inner Circle in Washington.
Also die Eskalationsdominanz, wie man ja heute so schön sagt, weil man diesen Begriff jetzt plötzlich kennt, liegt ja ganz klar bei China. Denn mittlerweile wird ja alles, was Amerika oder auch jetzt Deutschland macht, als Eskalation beobachtet und so gleich vor verurteilt. Also Nancy Pelosi Reise oder jetzt die von Stark-Watzinger, was ja auch wieder so ein bisschen heimlichen Humor hat, dass Deutschland ja sich diplomatisch geeinigt hat, nur untere Ränge der Regierung zu schicken. Also schickt man die Bildungsministerin, was ja auch wieder das Signal nach intern ist. Also das ist der untere Rang. Bildung ist ja nicht so entscheidend. So und die fahren dann dahin und es wird sofort verurteilt und jeder denkt...
Aber das hätten die ja früher nicht gemacht.
Ja, aber es ist so eine ganz große Diskussion. China kann da auch noch mal klar machen, selbst das ist uns schon zu viel. Und China geht ja, wenn man jetzt so einen Bogen schlägt...
Ich will das nicht verteidigen, was die mit Taiwan machen, was China macht, aber dass das der Westen das tut, um China Grenzen aufzuzeigen, ist ja auch klar. Nancy Pelosi fährt ja nicht dahin, weil die die Leute mal treffen wollte.
Aber damit zementiert man ja die Grenze, die beide Seiten wollen.
Genau, aber das ist doch einfach eine Bestätigung von der Tousthese.
Also China möchte auf gar keinen Fall, dass Taiwan irgendwie benutzt wird, irgendwie gefährlich zu werden für China. Also irgendwelche Stationierung von irgendwas und so weiter. Das ist überhaupt nur Anlauf, also nicht mal Tourismus möchten wir im Grunde, politischen Tourismus. Alles soll unterbunden werden. Und jetzt sehe ich aber nirgendwo bei den Amerikanern oder bei den Europäern, dass sie wirklich mehr machen als auch Nancy Pelosi macht da mal eine unabgesprochene Reise, also nicht mit dem Präsidenten abgeholt und dann so als Abschiedsgeschenk an die Welt irgendwie, dass man da nochmal ein Zeichen setzt.
Naja, also die Deals, die geschlossen werden zwischen Washington und Taiwan sind ja schon, haben ja schon zugenommen, haben eine andere Intensität und die offiziell nicht diplomatischen Überbindungen sind da.
Genau, aber da ist ja dann die Frage, was würde China gewinnen, wenn sie eine militärischen, also eine militärische Eroberung Thais waren, ist so teuer für China selbst.
Ja.
Mit allen Opportunitätskosten, die da, also nicht nur, dass der Krieg selber wahnsinnig teuer wäre, das sind 160 Kilometer See, die muss man erst mal überbrücken und um dann erfolgsversprechend in Taiwan irgendwas zu machen, das ist ja nur noch ein wehrhaftes Volk wahrscheinlich, muss man ja doch einiges investieren. Das geht auch nicht ohne sichtbare, also das sieht man, so wie diesen russischen Aufmarsch und so weiter. Und das ginge ja sofort mit erheblichen politischen Kosten in der Vorbereitung einher. Also die ganze Welt würde darauf reagieren, wenn es nur eine militärische Zuckung sozusagen gäbe. Und selbst wenn der Konflikt dann läuft, man hat doch jetzt an Russland gesehen, wie unvorhersehbar so ein Krieg verläuft. Wir müssen ja langsam wirklich mal auch ein ehrliches Gespräch darüber führen, wie sich Putin da verschätzt und verkalkuliert hat. Das war ja absolut nicht der Plan. Ein Jahr später immer noch. Das war ja mehr so diese Grimmeerwartung. Und sagt so, wir sind das gar nicht. Und dann, wenn wir es eingenommen haben, sagen wir, ja wir sind es doch so. Also wir fahren nach Kiew mit so einem 60 Kilometer Konvoi und dann, okay, ist jetzt unser und die ganze Welt ist damit einverstanden. Nee, ist ja alles nicht genau so nicht gekommen. Und ich denke mir irgendwie, ja die Chinesen sehen auch und denken, es ist unkalkulierbar. Also man weiß einfach nicht, was man gewinnt. Und deswegen versuchen sie, diesen mega Stress zu machen jedes Mal. Bei der kleinsten Bewegung, bei Taiwan irgendwie. Also ein Besucher aus Deutschland wird gleich das ganze, alles, was man auffahren kann, diplomatisch wird er aufgefahren, um allen der ganzen Welt zu zeigen, das ist nicht okay und so. Und das ist zwar ein ganz enormer Alarmismus, bei dem ich immer wieder denke, ja die investieren einfach da, wo sie es überschauen können, alles, was sie haben, um nicht in diesen unüberschaubaren, unkalkulierbaren, hinein zu rutschen. Und das machen sie aber gerade sehr erfolgreich, wie man ja auch an Tooze wieder sieht. Also Tooze liest den hier die Leviten, weil er sagt, die Chinesen lassen sich nicht unendlich reizen. Passt auf, es ist auch eurer Verantwortung hier nicht. Macht nicht den Fehler wie bei Putin und verteufelt ihn einfach und sagt, ist ja egal, ist ja irrational und so weiter. Sondern nein, die Chinesen sind rational. Seid vorsichtig und so.
Genau, und wenn wir mal diesen Zank-Apfel-Taiwan ausklammern, ist es ja trotzdem so, dass man zwei Weltmächte, oder die eine ist noch im Aufstieg begriffen, aber bald haben sie dann die Augenhöhe vielleicht erreicht. Dann haben wir es ja da mit zwei Weltmächten zu tun, die mal abgesehen von Taiwan sehr viele widerstreitende Interessen haben. Zum Beispiel im digitalen Raum, wie eben gesehen bei TikTok oder im Nahen Osten dann, wie gesehen bei Saudi-Arabien und Iran. Und dann ist die Frage, ob das überhaupt diesen Konflikt geben muss aufgrund von Taiwan oder ob Taiwan nur quasi dann der Anlass ist, weil natürlich auch eine Regierung in Washington eine Legitimation braucht, um in einen Krieg zu treten. Und dann hat man da natürlich wieder das Menschenrechte und so weiter. Ja, genau. Weil man muss jetzt auch von europäischer Perspektive sagen, das ist schlimm, wenn das so kommen würde. Aber ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob gleich die Leidenschaft so groß wäre, dass jetzt deutsche Bundeswehrsoldaten sagen, nichts lieber als in Taiwan für die westliche Freiheit zu sterben oder so. Also ich will mal eine andere, auch für die Amerikaner sollten, weil wir führen ja heute, wir reden ja noch gleich darüber. Ich habe hier eine unglaublich interessante Statistik, lasse ich dir auch direkt da, aus dem Wall Street Journal mit der Universität Chicago zusammen. Und zwar wurde da gefragt, was den Menschen eigentlich wichtig ist. Und diese Frage stellt man immer wieder. Und zwar von 98 an hat man damit begonnen und ist jetzt im Jahr 2023 angekommen. Und da geht es also um Patriotismus, Religion, Kinder haben, in der Community involviert sein und Geld. Und so sieht die Statistik aus. Das heißt, alle Sachen außer Geld, also Geld geht nach oben, ist von 98 an in den letzten 25 Jahren von etwa 30 Prozent auf etwa 50 Prozent hochgegangen. Und sonst Patriotismus von 70 Prozent auf unter 40 Prozent. Religion von über 60 Prozent unter 40 Prozent. Kinder haben im Übrigen auch und in der Community involviert sein. Das heißt aber, wenn also bei Amerikanern der Patriotismus bei irgendwo 35 Prozent angekommen ist und Geld wesentlich wichtiger ist, ist also auch sehr fraglich, ob die Amerikaner in diese schießende Auseinandersetzung gehen wollen.
Ja und es ist wieder so dieses allgemeine Problem mit Amerika auch der letzten hundert Jahre. Wenn der Krieg noch weit genug weg ist, fühlt man ihn umso leichter und Taiwan ist sehr weit weg von Amerika. Das ist natürlich auch ein Problem. Wenn das jetzt vor Amerikas Haustür wäre, würden die da auch ein bisschen anders mit umgehen. Ich sehe jedenfalls hier und das kann man jetzt schon mal sagen, Amerika auch in einer sehr provozierenden Position.
Genau.
So wie, das kann man ja vielleicht 2023 im März auch mal sagen, so wie wir auch Russland bei diesen Sicherheitsinteressen eben nicht ernst genommen haben. Und damit auch mit provoziert haben. Entschuldigt zwar nichts, was jetzt konkret entschieden wurde, aber es ist halt trotzdem eine Geschichte, die wir mitgeschrieben haben.
Ja, ja eben. Also man kann, man wird dann auch irgendwann, wenn es dann mal zu so etwas kommen würde, dass wir da einen Krieg haben oder das China sich da Taiwan unter den Nagel reißt, dann wird man natürlich auch immer sagen, ja, da ging nichts von westlicher Seite aus. Aber natürlich gibt es da gegenseitige Provokationen. Und wir haben das jetzt auch gerade mit diesen sehr launigen Clips von TikTok gehört. Das ist ein absolut harter Konfrontationskurs, der da gerade gefahren wird. Das ist eigentlich eine Verschärfung dessen, was wir bei Trump erlebt haben.
Also TikTok ist wie die Ballons. Das sind diese neun Stellvertreterkriege.
Das sind die, welchen Ballon schießen.
Die neuen Arena des Krieges.
Ja, da würde man auch nicht am Ende sagen, er das rechtfertigt, einen Krieg mit 100.000 Toten. Aber wir müssen natürlich das schon im Blick behalten. Und da bin ich wirklich dankbar, dass Adam Tooze das tut. Also ich würde mal sagen, hätte diese Rede die, wir hören das jetzt noch weiter, es wird noch krasser, hätte diese Rede jetzt irgendjemand, sagen wir mal aus der Linkspartei oder so gehalten, wer bei TikTok war es, unglaublich, wie kann man so was sagen und dergleichen, da ist man doch froh, dass Adam Tooze da über diesen kleinlichen Diskursen surft. Und er sagt hier zur Multipolarität folgendes.
Wenn Brüssel mit Offenheit und Multipolarität liebäugelt, wird das in Washington anders gesehen. Man sollte sich hier keinen Illusionen hingeben. Amerika sperrt sich gegen eine multipolare Welt. Offen und unverfroren behaupten sie die Supremacy, die Dominanz in zentralen Machtbereichen.
Also im Zuge des Ukraine-Kriegs sind ja schon sehr viele Handelsgeschäfte dann nicht mehr in Dollar abgewickelt worden. So und da untergräbt man ja genau das, also wenn Tooze hier so sagt, die Amerikaner sperren sich gegen eine multipolare Welt, es soll nur ein Pol geben, dann geht es ja nur um die Dollar-Dominanz, also nur um die Hoheit mit dem Dollar und das wird ja eh schon untergraben. Also hier wird auch Amerika gerade so ein bisschen in die Ecke getrieben. Irgendwann obliegt es dann auch nicht mehr dem Handlungsvermögen, also der amerikanischen politischen Führung weltweit da einfach über Geschäftsgebaren zu gebieten, sondern dann sind sie einfach aus dem Spiel.
Und es könnte sein, dass jetzt diese harte Sanktionspolitik gegen Russland das letzte Mal war, dass der Westen überhaupt eine so starke Macht hatte, das durchsetzen zu können, denn hätten wir nicht mehr die Dollarstärke, hätten wir nicht einen IWF, hätten wir nicht all diese Institutionen, die angekoppelt sind an dieses Ganze, dann wäre das in dieser Weise gar nicht mehr möglich.
Also China so zu sanktionieren, wird nicht funktionieren. Wir haben ja auch den Wang des letzten Monats bei der Sicherheitskonferenz auf der Bühne gesehen, wie er dann so diese Papiere betonte. Wir machen hier das und das und das. Also wir haben nicht nur unsere Währung, sondern auch unsere politische Programmatik, mit der wir die Welt einbinden. Und da haben wir schon die Hälfte der Welt unterschrieben, die machen damit und so weiter, an diese ganze Parallelstrukturierung von Weltbank und dem ganzen Kram, den wir bisher hatten.
Und ich meine, das spreche ich für uns beide. Wir sind keine Freunde dieses chinesischen Systems, wollen da nicht leben, werden aber auch nichts von außen daran insofern ändern können, dass wir sagen, ja dann steigen wir jetzt in den Konflikt, knallhart eine und zur Not, kämpfen wir zwei auch noch irgendwo da.
Es sind 1, 4 Milliarden Chinesen.
Ich meine, du bist ja wenigstens im Fitnessstudio dann gewesen, kannst ja dann da ordentlich zuschlagen.
Ich kann noch einen Meter weiter laufen, bevor ich das mache.
Das nicht und naja, wir hören weiter Tooze.
Wenn es mit der Unipolarität vorbei ist, setzt Washington nun auf eine Blockbildung unter seiner eigenen Führung. Strategie also ja, mit allem Drum und Dran, aber mit der Offenheit und der Autonomie wird es schwierig.
So das neue alte Wort heißt Blockbildung, wo man nicht mehr einfach unipolar das Ganze managen kann. Und Amerika umarmt Europa in gewisser Weise.
Unterschätzen Sie auch hier bitte nicht die Intentionalität. Es gibt gesamte Teams im Weißen Haus, die daran arbeiten. Man möchte das anhand des Inflation Reduction Acts nicht glauben, aber das ist die Politik des Kongresses, nicht der Administration. Die amerikanische Umarmung hat sicherheitspolitische Dimensionen, NATOs Hinwendung nach Asien, Okos. Das hat technisch politische Dimensionen, die Mobilisierung von Südkorea und den Niederlanden im Chipkrieg gegen China. Und es hat seit neuestem auch energie- und klimapolitische Dimensionen, mit dem Deal, und ich sage das bewusst, dem Deal zwischen von der Leyen und dem Weißen Haus.
Von der Leyen war im März im Weißen Haus, haben wir relativ wenig von gesehen. Es gab auch gar nicht viel. Sie saßen da zusammen. Weiden hat von einem Kerzchen abgelesen, dass er sich sehr freut, dass sie da ist. Und anschließend kam sie dann nochmal im Mantel rausspaziert und hat ein paar Dinge mitgeteilt. Und das hören wir uns jetzt erstmal an, was sie dort erzählt. Und man denkt, naja, das ist so blablabla.
I'm just coming from a bilateral meeting with President Biden. It was a very good meeting, very constructive. We discussed a lot of topics. The first topic we discussed is the Inflation Reduction Act. And indeed we welcome the Inflation Reduction Act because it is a massive investment in the green transition moving towards a net zero economy. It is mirrored by the Green Deal Industrial Plan in the European Union. A few weeks ago we had already an agreement concerning electric vehicles accessing the American market. Today we agreed that we will work on critical raw materials that have been sourced or processed in the European Union and to give them the access to the American market as if they were sourced in the American market. We will work on an agreement what that is concerned.
Gelobt wird jetzt dieser Act und dann werden einige Dinge aufgezählt, mit denen man aber gar nicht so richtig anfangen kann, worauf will sie hinaus. Sie geht aber auch nicht näher darauf ein. Sie beantwortet noch drei, vier Fragen der Presse, aber auch nichts Relevantes. Und dann gibt es noch diesen einen Punkt, den sie loswerden will.
And the third point is that we agreed on a transparency dialogue concerning the incentives that are given to the clean tech industry. For us it's important on both sides of the Atlantic to know what kind of incentives are being given to the clean tech industry, to make sure that we join forces to boost the clean tech industry that is crucial and paramount for reaching a circular economy, a net zero economy.
Also dass das Ding Inflation Reduction und so weiter heißt, ist natürlich witzig, denn man hat ja nur auf eine Krise gewartet, um das ja schon zweimal im Anlauf befindliche Gesetzes-Dings-Investitions, eigentlich die neue Wachstumsstrategie zu organisieren. Zum machen, das hat ja dann immer der Joe Manchin da aufgehalten, quasi die amerikanische FDP.
Und dann konnte man eben sagen, wir machen jetzt was gegen die Inflation, Joe.
Genau, und man braucht ihn jetzt auch nicht mehr, weil man hat ja diesen eigenen Kongress Senatsitz, den kommt es ja nicht mehr an. Und es war ja wirklich, sie will ja genau dasselbe, und zwar seit drei Jahren. Sie kam ja ins Amt 2020 mit dem European Green Deal. Wir haben es ja im Januar 2020 besprochen. Und sie hat es ja auch unter dieser, das ist die neue europäische Wachstumsstrategie. Wir sind ja, uns ging ja die Straße aus. Wir wussten ja nicht mehr, in welche Richtung wollen wir denn wachsen. Und dann gab es zuerst diese große, große Hinwendung zum Digitalen durch Corona. Plötzlich musste das alles aufgepowered werden und jetzt eben erneuerbare Energien. Und es wird alles aufgehalten durch die FDP.
Nur, wenn wir es jetzt auf der geopolitischen Ebene betrachten, dann können wir das nochmal ganz anders interpretieren. Also es stimmt, Europa hat eigentlich diese Wachstumsstrategie. Die FDP hat es noch nicht begriffen. Die USA hat die Wachstumsstrategie, hat ein besseres Framing dafür geschaffen und hat es so durchgedrückt. Aber dass es jetzt diese Annäherung zwischen EU und USA gibt, das ist etwas sehr Erstaunliches. Und man hört aber hier gar nicht mal eigentlich, worum es dann ging. Aber das Weiße Haus hat ein Statement veröffentlicht nach diesem Treffen. Und jetzt wird es doch konkret. Und dann merkt man plötzlich, hier geht es jetzt nicht so sehr um, naja, wie kriegen wir da dieses Material dorthin und was machen wir nochmal mit dem Klima? Sondern es geht hier ganz klar um geopolitische Interessen. Und zwar heißt es hier, die EU-US-Taskforce zum Inflationsbekämpfungsgesetz hat unsere Partnerschaft in Bezug auf diese gemeinsamen Ziele produktiv vertieft und in Bezug auf die identifizierten Herausforderungen praktische Schritte unternommen, um unsere Ansätze zur Stärkung und Sicherung von Lieferketten, Produktion und Innovation auf beiden Seiten des Atlantiks anzugleichen. Es klingt jetzt erstmal so, also man hat ja durch diesen Act in den USA erstmal in Europa Panik ausgelöst, was wollen die da eigentlich von uns, beziehungsweise dürfen wir da nicht mehr exportieren, was auch immer. Und dann heißt es hier aber, nachdem man es ein bisschen beschrieben hat, um welche kritischen Produkte und so weiter es geht, der Dialog über Anreize für saubere Energie wird Teil des EU-US-Handels und Technologie-Rates werden, wo er auch den Informationsaustausch über nicht marktwirtschaftliche Politik und Praktiken Dritter, wie die der Volksrepublik China, erleichtern wird, um als Grundlage für gemeinsame oder parallele Maßnahmen und koordinierte Lobbyarbeit zu diesen Themen in multilateralen und anderen Foren zu dienen. Das heißt, worauf das hier hinausläuft ist, man versucht eine Industriepolitik zu machen, die die westliche Blockbildung tatsächlich herstellt. Und das ist sehr stark gegen China ausgerichtet. Und so ist das auch dann zu verstehen, wenn von Transparenzdialog und so was die Rede ist. Das heißt, man informiert sich gegenseitig darüber, was andere machen, was man herausgefunden hat, was China und so weiter vorhat, um dann entsprechend dagegen handeln zu können. Und weiter heißt es dann zum Thema Stärkung wirtschaftlicher Sicherheit und nationale Sicherheit, das ist nämlich hier zusammengefasst. Die Vereinigten Staaten und die Europäische Union arbeiten daran, durch transatlantische Zusammenarbeit unsere wesentlichen Sicherheitsinteressen und die Widerstandsfähigkeit unserer Volkswirtschaften zu stärken. Wir bekräftigen das unsere Zusammenarbeit zur Stärkung unserer wirtschaftlichen Sicherheit und unserer nationalen Sicherheit auf der Aufrechterhaltung des regelbasierten Systems beruhen sollte. Also auf dem westlichen System. Da will man jetzt also in den nächsten Monaten Schritte einleiten. Wir werden unsere Arbeit zur Stärkung unserer wirtschaftlichen Sicherheit fortsetzen und dabei auf konkrete Bedrohungen reagieren, die wir identifiziert haben. Die Vereinigten Staaten und die Europäische Union teilen die Besorgnis über die Herausforderungen, die unter anderem durch wirtschaftlichen Zwang, die Bewaffnung wirtschaftlicher Abhängigkeiten und nicht marktwirtschaftliche Politiken und Praktiken entstehen. Und dann heißt es zum Schluss noch, wir werden unsere Arbeit im Rahmen des Handels- und Technologierates und der G7 fortsetzen, um die Koordinierung untereinander und mit anderen gleichgesinnten Partnern zu verstärken, um unsere Lieferketten zu diversifizieren und unsere gemeinsame Bereitschaft, Widerstandsfähigkeit und Abschreckung gegen nicht marktwirtschaftliche Politiken und Praktiken zu erhöhen.
Es ist ja eigentlich witzig, dass man die Marktwirtschaft fördert, indem man hunderte von Milliarden von Subventionsgeldern zur Verfügung stellt, aber immer geknüpft an so Programme, wie du es jetzt vorgelesen hast. Also das ist nicht aus dem Markt heraus, sondern die Politik einfach sagt, verdienen könnt ihr bei uns, wenn ihr das und wie wir es dann steuern. Weil damit gibt man sich ja eigentlich schon geschlagen und sieht, die Chinesen schaffen das ganz schön krass, die machen es einfach über den Befehl, sagen einfach von heute auf morgen politisch entschieden, es gibt kein Corona mehr.
Das sind natürlich die nicht marktwirtschaftlichen Maßnahmen. Also TikTok ist auch nicht marktwirtschaftlich. Das ist alles nicht marktwirtschaftlich.
Also bei TikTok weiß ich es nicht so genau, weil die müssen ja da nicht so wirklich, keine Ahnung, das ist so virtuell.
Ich sag das jetzt zum Spaß, weil so ist das interpretierbar. Also das heißt, es gibt jetzt so eine neue, man sagt jetzt hier nicht, wo unsere Moral nicht eingehalten wird, sondern wo nicht marktwirtschaftliche Politiken stattfinden. Und das kann man natürlich dann immer auf jede Autokratie, wenn man so möchte, beziehen.
Also TikTok ist so ein schwieriger Fall. Aber nehmen wir mal die Autoindustrie. Die Chinesen haben ja schon relativ früh damals gesagt, 8% der Neuzulassungen pro Hersteller müssen e-mobiles sein. Dann ist der Sigmar Gabriel hingeflogen als Bundeswirtschaftsminister. Er sagte, er wollte nicht noch mal drüberlegen. Wir wollen doch den Verbrennern noch so ein bisschen hofieren und so weiter. Und die so, nee, wir bleiben hier hart. Und das ist halt dieses, der Staat sagt einfach, regelt über Verbote und so weiter und so fort. Jetzt kommen die Amerikaner und schlagen dieses vor mit riesigen Subventionstöpfen, die einfach so als Anreizsystem, so Honeypots, einfach so ganze Märkte zu lenken. Und die Europäer wollen das eigentlich mitmachen, können aber nicht, weil sie blockiert werden, beispielsweise durch die FDP, die nämlich sagt, naja, wenn wir so und so viel Geld staatlich zur Verfügung stellen, wir hätten ja gerne, dass nur private Gelder investiert werden, damit dann auch die Renditen, damit das juristisch klar ist, die Return on Investments gehen auch in private Hand. So, und jetzt blockiert die FDP quasi im Systemstreit mit China diesen, in Anführungszeichen, marktwirtschaftlichen Zugang über riesige Subventionstöpfe, die politisch gesteuert sind und so weiter, das Geld zur Verfügung stellen, um die Märkte zu lenken, womit Biden jetzt schon sieht, oh, das ist aber blöd, weil dann klappt unsere Blockbildung nicht, wenn nur wir Amerikaner machen, ist zu wenig, wir sind da nicht mehr so mächtig wie früher und so. Und damit fördert ja die FDP eigentlich dieses chinesische Modell, dass nämlich die Chinesen mit ihrer politischen Steuerung dann doch viel erfolgreicher, viel schneller zu Potter kommen und die Amerikaner eben nichts dagegen oder weniger dagegen halten können, als sie, wenn die Europäer mitmachen würden, erreichen könnten. Also macht eigentlich die FDP, jetzt mal so ganz vulgär, kurzgeschlossen Politik, also Blockadepolitik, die den Chinesen da hilft. Als die marktwirtschaftliche Partei.
Auf ganz lange Sicht gesehen schon. Es ist einiges ein bisschen verrückter, denn ich werde gleich noch Hans-Werner Sinn zustimmen. Zustimmen, ja. Ich werde Hans-Werner Sinn loben.
Ich bin gespannt, was er sagt.
Erst noch, Tooze hat auch das Treffen von Biden und Leyen sich angesehen, sagt Folgendes dazu.
So wird auf amerikanischer Seite das Treffen am 10. März zwischen den beiden Präsidenten vom Biden-Team gedeutet. Als Einverständnis Europas zu einem Pakt in Sachen strategischen Rohstoffen, Anreizkompatibilität in Sachen Industrieförderung. So haben sie das umgeschrieben. Die Inflation Reduction Act, worum es geht, ist Anreizkompatibilität herzustellen. Technologische Zusammenarbeit, den Abschluss des Aluminium- und Stahldeals bis Ende Oktober dieses Jahres, Zusammenarbeit in der globalen Infrastrukturförderung und in der Reform der Weltbank. Punkt für Punkt ein strategisches Bild einer Blockbildung, die Amerika und Europa zusammen, wenn nicht schweißen, dann zumindest einen Gleichschritt herstellen, einen Rhythmus herstellen soll. Eine Politik, die aber gleichzeitig gegen China gerichtet ist.
Ich bin da übrigens mal sehr dafür. Also hier möten wir mal eine amerikanische Strategie dargelegt, bei der ich sage, finde ich gut.
Ich glaube, dass die industriepolitische Idee sinnvoll ist und ohne Industriepolitik, also ohne Eingreifung der Politik, wird es nicht gehen. Die Frage ist nur, wenn wir an dieser Blockbildung teilnehmen, wo uns das hinführt. Und das führt ja Tuz hier ziemlich deutlich auf.
Aber im Zuge dessen heißt das ja, wenn wir eine Unabhängigkeit beim Thema Energie wollen, dann machen wir das natürlich über erneuerbare Energien, also über Solar und Wind und Wasserkraften, wie auch immer. Und wir haben dafür aber zu wenig Geld und so weiter. Also stellt der Staat einfach hunderte Milliarden zur Verfügung.
Nein, das steht ja außer Frage. Die Frage ist nur, ob wir das mit den Amerikanern nach ihren Vorstellungen als Blockbildung verhalten sollen.
Das ist ja eben auch meine Vorstellung, das meine ich ja damit. Die Amerikaner legen es vor, aber ich denke mir irgendwie...
Die haben ja ein anderes Interesse daran. Die sagen ja nicht, damit du hier Sond- und Windenergie hast und damit dein Haus betankst.
Aber sie sagen erst mal, das ist ein Anreizsystem. Wie hat sie jetzt genannt? Anreiz, Dingserbums, Kompatibilität.
Aber gegen China, das ist ja auch was, was ich vorgelesen habe, ist natürlich ein Anreizsystem, das in erster Linie darauf aus ist, zu sagen, wir bilden einen wirtschaftlichen Block gegen China. Und das bedeutet dann auch, dass man sehr bald härtere Sanktionen gegen China durchsetzen will. Also die Niederländer haben es ja schon am eigenen Leib jetzt erfahren. Und wenn man da eine solche Eskalation herstellt auf wirtschaftlicher Ebene hin zu China, dann mag das für die USA jetzt gerade wichtig sein. Aber ob das im europäischen Interesse ist, da hat jetzt Adam Tooze, und da habe ich, und da hat auch Hans-Johannes Sinn, seine Zweifel. Und das, glaube ich, ist das große Problem, dass wir jetzt zwei Diskurse miteinander vermischt haben. Der eine Diskurs ist, in dem wir uns ja völlig einig sind, zu sagen, ohne eine eingreifende Industriepolitik werden wir keine grüne Wende hinbekommen, werden hier nicht die Solarpanels sein und all das. Das wird der Markt nicht regeln, weil er gar kein Interesse daran haben kann. Beziehungsweise auf lange Sicht könnte er eins dran haben, aber ein Markt kann nicht auf lange Sicht agieren. Das kann eigentlich nur die Politik. Nur wird dieser Diskurs, der wir müssen was fürs Klima tun, gerade verknüpft mit einer geostrategischen Blockbildung, und das kann man ja dann selbst bis zu Fridays for Future nachvollziehen, wo dann plötzlich Fridays for Future so klingt, als würden sie NATO-Interessen in erster Linie vertreten wollen, dass man dadurch eine Konstellation geschaffen hat, die auf eine Eskalation hinausläuft, die dann so aussieht, dass wir vielleicht auch dann wirtschaftlich ein großes Problem bekommen, im Gegensatz zu den USA, denn Tooze zeigt uns erst einmal auch das klimapolitische Dilemma bei der Sache auf.
Und hier aber entsteht das handfeste Dilemma. Und ich werde es kurz machen, um zum Schluss zu kommen. Von Russland kann man sich mit Gewinn abkoppeln, von China nicht.
Und damit meint er natürlich, die deutsche Wirtschaft kann sich nicht und die europäische Wirtschaft kann sich nicht von China abkoppeln. Und auch mit Blick auf den Klimawandel ist das vielleicht gar nicht ratsam. Er hat da Zahlen, die ich nicht kannte, die mich echt umgehauen haben.
Gehen wir nur in den einen Bereich der Energietechnik und der Energiewende. Von den 1, 1 Billionen Dollar, das sind also 1.100 Milliarden Dollar, die Bloomberg New Energy Foundation im letzten Jahr an Ausgaben für die Energiewende weltweit dokumentiert, also von 1, 1 Billionen, wurden 140 Milliarden in den USA verausgabt, 180 Milliarden in Europa und 550 Milliarden in China. Das heißt die Hälfte aller Ausgaben weltweit für die Energiewende in China. Das Dreifacher der großen westlichen Blocks. Und das IRA, das Inflation Reduction Act, wird an diesen Größen und Ordnungen nichts grundsätzlich verändern.
Das ist ja auch ein echtes Problem. Also China verdient sich jetzt dumm und dämlich an der Energiewende, so wie wir uns ja auch dumm und dämlich an allen anderen in den letzten 100 Jahren verdient haben. Und diese Einsicht finde ich auch total relevant, nämlich zu sagen, wir sind bei den fossilen Energien von Russland abhängig gewesen und bei den erneuerbaren Energien sind wir es von China. Wir haben im Zuge dieser, wir brauchen doch den Verbrenner und so weiter, ja, das Eingeständnis an China gegeben. Ja, wir, also ihr schützt für uns unsere Autoindustrie, dafür überlassen wir euch unsere Solar. Und wir waren ja Weltmarktführer in beiden Wind und Solar und jetzt ist es China. So, aber ich habe gar nichts dagegen, dass das als Problem erkannt wird. Und so wie man sich von Russland abhängig macht im Zuge eines Krieges, dass man sich jetzt mit dieser Autonomie, bei dieser Technologie, was ja im Grunde nur bedeutet, die Windräder werden in Europa hergestellt und dann nicht immer um die Welt gefahren, sondern halt auch in Europa verbaut. Und wir haben ja nun mal Siemens, die diese 15 Megawatt Turbinen mittlerweile da in der Nordsee installieren und so weiter.
Die sind aber auch gut in China investiert.
Genau, und jetzt haben wir halt so ein Skalierungsproblem, wie ist ja Robert Habecks neues Lieblingswort Hochfahren, eine Industrie, wo hochgefahren werden. Und ich finde aber auch, das sollte jetzt alles mal hochgefahren werden.
Das ist definitiv so, nur sehen wir ja gerade hier, China tritt als Vorreiter auf. Das heißt, wenn wir jetzt sagen, China macht die ganze Zeit böse Dinge und ja, die bauen auch noch neue Kohlekraftwerke, weil die natürlich eine Energie brauchen, dass sie das auch mit diesen riesen erneuerbaren Investitionen nicht hinbekommen, dann muss man doch festhalten, dass wir, also wenn wir jetzt wirklich sagen, Klima geht uns ja alle an und wir müssen alle was tun, dann können wir nicht sagen, wir versuchen mal das Klima ohne China zu retten, was zugleich aber nicht bedeuten muss, dass wir uns einfach eine neue totale Abhängigkeit begeben. Aber diese Abhängigkeit müsste ja nicht sein, aber zugleich geht es ja bei den USA darum, eigentlich die Schotten dicht zu machen. Und Tooze bringt noch eine Zahl.
Noch bezeichnender sind die Zahlen für die vorgelagerte Stufe, wo es um die Investition in den Fabriken geht, die die Energiewende maßgeblich bestimmen werden, also PWEV-Fabriken. Davon waren letztes Jahr von diesen Investitionen, sie belaufen sich auf rund 110-120 Milliarden Dollar weltweit, 90% in China. Und in den letzten fünf Jahren fällt Chinas Anteil in diesem strategischen Bereich nie unter 85%.
Ja, und da bin ich sehr dafür, dass wir in Europa jetzt mal den gordischen Knoten zerschlagen und sagen, es kommt jetzt auf jedes Dach eine Solaranlage und auf jeden Quadratkilometer an der Nordsee 10 Windkraftanlagen. Bis wir hier so viel Energie haben, dass wir mal wieder alles einfach machen können, was wir wollen. Und es nicht plötzlich heißt, oh, jetzt müssen wir mal sparen, weil wir haben das Netz nicht ausgebaut. Die Baden-Württemberger müssen jetzt mal alles ausschalten, damit genug Strom im Netz bleibt, damit man die Netzrequenz stabil hält, weil gerade so viel Wind in der Nordsee produziert wird, dass das Netz sonst kaputt ginge. Wenn die in Baden-Württemberg jetzt mal Fernsehen gucken. Das sind ja alles absurde, mittelalterliche Zustände. Und da bin ich doch sehr dafür, dass wir jetzt einfach die FDP da mal raushauen und sagen, all in Investition. Deutschland hat noch eine Billion offen, bevor irgendein Finanzmarkt-Teilnehmer sagt, oh, ist das aber mega verschuldet.
Aber ich glaube, dass das schon immer unter der Bedingung des offenen Marktes laufen soll. Und deswegen komme ich jetzt zu meinem Part, ich lobe Hans-Werner Sinn.
Ich bin sehr gespannt jetzt.
Ich habe eben schon mit dem Anarchismus geliebeäugelt, das ist nicht meine Art, aber jetzt liebeäugle ich mit dem Liberalismus. Und man könnte ja erstmal eine Prioritätensetzung vornehmen. Was ist eigentlich das Allerwichtigste?
Gesundheit.
Dann würde man sagen Gesundheit, ja, aber das ist eine sehr individuelle Sache, plus dann auch mal die gesellschaftliche Sache, wie ist die Vorsorge und all das. Und dann würde man aber sicherlich als nächstes auf den Frieden kommen.
Auch, ja.
Und dann kommen alle anderen Fragen. Und ich würde nochmal hier deutlich machen, in fast allen anderen Fragen bin ich mit Hans-Werner Sinn nicht einer Meinung. Der sagt natürlich ja auch Dinge zu Inflation oder zu löden und so was im Handelsblatt. Da wollen wir gar nicht drauf eingehen. Aber es geht jetzt im Handelsblatt darum, brauchen wir ein neues Geschäftsmodell? Deglobalisierung, wird er gefragt, ist das was? Und dann sagt Hans-Werner Sinn, nein, wir müssen das Alte wiederbeleben und gegen die Ideologien verteidigen, also das alte Geschäftsmodell. Der links-grüne Moralismus, der anderen als willkommenes Argument für schieren Protektionismus dient, führt uns auf teure Abwege. Dann wird er gefragt, und Friendsharing? Friendsharing ist auch Protektionismus. Der Handel bringt aber besonders große Spezialisierungsvorteil für alle Beteiligten, wenn sie sich unterscheiden. Viv la différence. Und dann geht es darum, na ja, aber Menschenrechte. Dann sagt er ja, diese Menschenrechte gibt es. Und die muss man auch immer wieder herausstellen. Aber er sagt, die Verbindungen zu China dürfen nicht abreißen. China ist Deutschlands größter Handelspartner. China ist ein mächtiges Land und China ist Deutschland gewogen. Ich würde diese Karte nicht aufgeben, auch wenn es sicher richtig ist, sich stärker zu diversifizieren. Und er sagt auch, unsere Sicherheitsinteressen sind natürlich engstens mit denen der USA verbunden. Doch liegen die wirtschaftlichen Interessen nicht beisammen. Wir müssen uns hier emanzipieren. Und dann wird er nochmal daraufhin gefragt, was soll das bedeuten, emanzipieren? Wir, die Europäer und die Deutschen, müssen jedenfalls unsere besondere Beziehung zu China pflegen. Wir können nicht den konfrontativen Weg der USA übernehmen. Das sollten wir schon aus ökologischen Gründen nicht tun. Man kann China nicht klein halten wollen und gleichzeitig hoffen, dass es die fossilen Brennstoffe, die wir ihm wegen unserer Kaufverbote verbilligt überlassen, auf klimapolitischen Gründen nicht verwendet.
Also die Blockbildung, die Tooze hier sieht, Europa, Amerika. Und jetzt die Warnung, die Hans-Werner Sillen ausspricht. Europa wird immer angedichtet, dann so klein beizugeben und so. Aber wir haben es ja auch mit dem selbstbewussten Europa zu tun. Es sind hier mehr Menschen, insgesamt volkswirtschaftlich schon augenhöher, auch wenn der Dollar da stärker ist. Und wir sehen ja auch bei verschiedenen Gesetzgebungen, jetzt ist es gerade der AI Act, aber auch bei diesem Silikon-Welle. Ja, mal sehen, das ist ja alles noch, läuft auch schon seit drei, zwei Jahren, was bei Rom kommt, aber also Datenschutzrecht, der ganze Kram, da hat Europa schon eigene Töne gesetzt. Wir werden da auch Amerika ein bisschen zähmen können. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass, wir sehen ja auch, wie Macron sich da verhält, dass Europa da einfach mitmacht, wenn Amerika so auf Konfrontationskurs geht.
Tja, also ich will hier nochmal sagen, bei allen Differenzen zu Hans-Werner Sinn, er hat völlig recht, wenn er nochmal sagt, dass die Formel Wandel durch Handel ein richtiger Ansatz ist. Auch wenn sie dann bei Putin nicht gefruchtet hat, ist das nicht per se falsch. Und wenn wir uns einfach vorstellen wollen, eine Welt, in der wir jetzt auf Dauerkonfrontation leben, wir zwischen zwei Weltmächten und wir könnten jederzeit auch mit dabei sein, dann ist das doch eine grauenhafte Perspektive. Also die beängstigt mich jetzt ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen mehr, als zu wissen, dass mit dem Klima wird arg werden. Weil da kann ich immer noch in gewisser Handlungsmacht auch agieren und kann Dinge tun und unterlassen oder sehe auf jeden Fall nicht gleich dem Tode ins Auge. Er sagt hier nochmal ganz deutlich, und das ist wirklich wunderbar, also ich hätte fast Lust, mich mal mit ihm zu unterhalten, Willi Brandt hatte recht, schon der Philosophie Manuel Kant wusste, dass Nationen, die Handel miteinander treiben, weniger Kriege gegeneinander führen. Der Welthandel ist ein Stück Friedenspolitik. Nur der Handel kettet die Länder so weit aneinander, dass sie friedlich gesinnt bleiben.
Wird er aber auch weiterhin.
Ich hoffe, dass sehr.
Bist du so abhängig von China, gäbe gar kein Aussehen.
Wir hören noch ein paar schlimme Clips jetzt, aber ich will es nur nochmal deutlich machen. Man muss jetzt vorsichtig sein. Wir haben natürlich von linker Perspektive aus, aus dieser Neoliberalismus- und Globalisierungskritik heraus, sehr stark immer den Freihandel kritisiert. All das, was in der Welt an Ungerechtigkeit dadurch entsteht, haben Outsourcing von Arbeitsplätzen, all das kritisiert. Und das ist auch alles richtig, was da kritisiert wurde. Ich glaube nur, dass die Alternative zu dieser liberalen Wirtschaftsordnung, die jetzt gerade sich auftut, keine gute Alternative ist, sondern es eher noch schlimmer macht. Deswegen bin ich an dieser Stelle auf der Seite der Liberalen. Und Hans-Werner Sinn, man kann über ihn sagen, was man will. Und ich finde das wirklich auch degutant, was er Leuten sagt, die wenig verdienen und all das. Aber er ist natürlich ein wirklicher Liberaler in dem Sinne, dass er hofft und glaubt, dass man durch so ein System des liberalen Freihandels es dazu bringen kann, dass eine Welt nur wirtschaftlich miteinander vernetzt ist und nicht mehr Kriege führen muss. Und das ist schon etwas Wertvolles.
Wir müssen Ihnen mal sagen, die Globalisierung ist in Verruf gekommen, weil in Bangladesch diese Fabrik zerstört wurde und dann 1000 Tote näheren und so weiter. Und wir haben ja von Gerd Müller, die Argumentation gehört beim Lieferkettengesetz, das ja als unterbelichtetes Gesetz vielleicht eines der wichtigsten der letzten Jahre war. Für drei Euro mehr, die am Ende der Wirtschaftskette da ankommen, wo wirklich gearbeitet wird, für drei Euro mehr kann man schon europäische Arbeitsschutzstandards einhalten. So, und obwohl wir die da für 2, 50 Euro nähen lassen und das hier für 70 Euro verkaufen, trauen wir es nicht zu, das dem Kunden für 72, 50 Euro zu verkaufen, für diese zwei Euro mehr. Wir könnten alles so lassen, wie es ist, und müssten einfach nur ein bisschen mehr Geld, nur ein bisschen mehr Geld, die Wertschöpfungskette entlangrutschen lassen. Und schon hätten wir ganz schön viele Probleme gelöst.
Das kannst du bei Schokolade genauso durchrechnen.
Und wir brauchen nicht immer dieses fundamentale, ja, der ganze Kapitalismus, und überhaupt alles muss abgeschafft werden. Nee, wir müssen nur diese Verteilungsfragen anders klären. So wie wir ja noch in Deutschland. Wir haben genug Geld, wir haben genug Produktivität, wir haben genug Menschen, wir haben nur Verteilungsprobleme. Es sind nur Verteilungsprobleme.
Was wir aber momentan ja sehen, ist eine Industriepolitik oder eine Politik, die ohne die Industrie stattfindet. Wir werden das jetzt gleich noch weiterhören. Denn erstmal ist das verrückt. Wir haben jetzt noch dieses E-Fuel zu denken, Lobbyarbeit und so und dann stellt sich ja fast heraus, ach so, die Konzerne sind auch schon gar nicht mehr interessiert. Aber was wir eigentlich erleben, ist durch die FDP noch so eine starke, wir gucken mal, welche Konzerne welche Interessen haben und versuchen, die durchzusetzen. Und das erleben wir aber zum Beispiel in der beiden Administration nicht mehr. Aber wir hören erstmal noch weiter Tooze.
Das ist also das Dilemma. Die Dynamik der Energiewende, die Zukunft der metallverarbeitenden Branche, sei es im Maschinenbau, Fahrzeugbau oder eben auch im Elektrobereich. Die Zukunft, die dort gestaltet wird, wird de facto von China bestimmt. Die aufsteigende Macht, die aber jetzt von der die USA verlangt, dass Europa sich entkoppeln muss. Und geben Sie sich da wirklich keinen Illusionen hin. Die Forderungen werden von Washington der Reihe nach gestellt werden. Sie haben in gewisser Weise eine Programmatik dafür. Diese schrittweise Einbindung Europas und Ostasiens in die Blockbildung gegen China wird sehr bewusst von sehr smarten Leuten. Ungeheuer umgänglich Menschen, liberale Menschen, mit denen man sehr gerne essen gehen würde, betreiben diese Politik mit großer Absicht.
Es sind nicht die republikanischen Hardliner. Und erstaunlich ist, wer jetzt eigentlich regiert.
Diese Politik wird gestaltet von Menschen mit einer historischen Fantasie. Und zum Teil würde man sich wünschen, dass sie das nicht hätten. Denn sie verstehen sich als Akteure in einem sehr großen Drama. Und das Entscheidende darin ist, dass in der gegenwärtigen demokratischen Partei die Wirtschaft keine entscheidendes Wort mitspricht. Es ist eine sehr interessante Umkonfiguration der amerikanischen Politik. Wenn Sie an die Koalition um beiden herum denken, ist das nicht mehr die Koalition der Clinton-Jahre. Das ist nicht mehr die Globalisierungskoalition, auch bei den Demokraten nicht. Man könnte fast in eine gewisse Nostalgie für die alten Zeiten verfallen, wo Robert Rubin und Goldman Sachs doch das Huder vertreten. Wenn Sie zurückdenken an die Bush-Jahre, da hat Wall Street das chinesisch-amerikanische Verhältnis maßgeblich mitbestimmt.
Das ist doch interessant.
Er geht doch auch auf Apple ein. Apple hat ja nun mit China eine wichtige Werkbank. Dass man da einfach sagt, ihr seid zwar unsere wichtige Aktie, aber wir haben eine andere Idee von China. Das wäre undenkbar gewesen. Das interessiert mich jetzt, wenn ich hier den Systemtheoretiker sitze. Was tut sich da eigentlich? Wir haben natürlich die verschiedenen Systeme, Politik, Wirtschaft, Medien. Und dann ist doch wahrzunehmen, dass bis auf die Podcasts, die du eben genannt hast, Medien und Politik in großer Eintracht gegen TikTok schießen, auch sehr auf einem Antik China-Kurs sind. Es gibt sicherlich einzelne Teile der Wirtschaft, die das gut finden, weil die durch einen Protektionismus wahrlich geschützt werden. Aber man hat ja sehr viele Industriezweige oder Börsenleute, die einfach nicht mehr direkt in der Politik involviert sind. Was bedeutet das eigentlich, wenn die Systeme wieder stärker, unabhängig voneinander agieren? Oder wir sagen, wir haben jetzt so ein medialpolitisches System, oder zwei Systeme, die da große Schnittmengen haben, während das Wirtschaftssystem das einfach fragt, bringt es was, bringt es nichts? Das würde man ja so auf die Wirtschaft reduzieren können. Dass das erstmal nicht die relevante Frage ist, sondern erstmal fragen wir, wie geht es den Uiguren?
Ja, also man muss ja erstmal den Mensch dann rausnehmen aus der Rechnung. Wir haben es also nicht mit Politikern oder Unternehmern zu tun, sondern nur mit Kommunikationen, die entweder darauf abstellt, mehr Geld zu verdienen oder politische Macht zu erringen. Und das sind ja zwei sehr verschiedene Sachen. Also Geld verdient man einfach, indem man in einem kleinen Handel mit einem Plus rausgeht und es wird dann einfach aufsummiert, umso mehr man solche Handel zusammen organisieren kann in irgendwelchen Organisationen, umso besser. Und bei Macht funktioniert es ja anders. Gerade wenn man so ein Systemstreit hat, wie das sich in China einfach macht, also das Macht gar nicht auf Unterstützung aus ist, sondern da ist halt einfach das Zentrum klar, Zentrum und Peripherie sozusagen. Peking entscheidet einfach, während ja Macht auf westlicher Seite immer wieder neu organisiert werden muss. Und zwar nicht nur alle vier Jahre für Wahlen, sondern bei jeder einzigen öffentlichen Kommunikation. Wird ja immer darauf abgestellt, dass man auch die Machtkommunikation mitlaufen lässt. Also wie vorhin schon angemerkt.
Was dann Lamprecht nicht kann, deswegen muss sie zurücktreten.
Oder haben wir mit dieser politischen Entscheidung Habeck ausreichend geschwächt, fragt dann Scholz per Zuruf im Willy-Brandt-Haus nach. Und dann heißt es, ja, können wir so machen, da kommt Habeck nicht gut durch. Dann hat man die Machtfragen auch wieder dran gebunden. Was Tooze hier kritisiert, ist ja, was wir ansonsten als Korruption bemängeln, dass nämlich die eine Logik in die andere Logik so rein korrumpiert. Also dass man sagt, wir sind zwar hier das politische Zentrum, aber eigentlich geht es doch nur um Kosten nutzen. Genau, aber eigentlich sind wir ja eine Washington AG, die Geld verdienen möchte. Also nutzen wir mal diese ganzen Machtfragen nur als Vehikel und lügen dem Volk hat irgendwas vor oder sowas. Wir klären das so auf Programme-Ebene, was wir jetzt hier tun. Und das finde ich...
Warst du da auch nostalgisch?
Naja, ich werde so ein bisschen nostalgisch, also nostalgisch nicht im Sinne von, aber was er sich ja hier wünscht, ist ja, oder sagen wir mal so, Nostalgie ist ja immer so ein Zurückerinnern an schönere Zeiten, weil man klären kann, warum sie schön waren. Und jetzt ist ja die Frage, warum sagt Adam Tooze, dass es zu Clintons Zeit schön war? Weil man da nämlich mit politischer Macht ökonomisch Profit erzeugen, provozieren konnte. Also man wusste, wie sich die Systeme miteinander irritieren. Und es drohte zum Beispiel kein Krieg. Und jetzt ist ja alles außer Rand und Band. Also wir hören ja nachher gleich die ganze GPT-Sache, wie die auf der Bühne stehen. Da fragt man sich ja wirklich, gibt es Systemlogiken noch? Gibt es so reine Rationalitäten von Systemen noch? Kann man noch Systeme miteinander irgendwie in kommunikativen, operativen Zusammenhangen bringen? Oder sind wir jetzt eh allem irgendwie ausgeliefert? Maurice Höfken hat jetzt mal darauf hingewiesen. Zinsen. Also wir haben eine Inflation und regieren darauf mit Zinsen. Zinsen bringen alles durcheinander, das ganze Gefüge. Also wenn wir einfach eine Verdreifachung von Zinsen haben und dann 20 Jahre laufende Kredite bei 5% und dann aber 15%, dann ist das, was wir für diesen Kredit kaufen, plötzlich dreimal so teuer. Aber es sind doch nur 2% mehr. Ja, aber es ist trotzdem in der Rechnung, am Ende ist es dreimal so teuer. Und das bringt alles durcheinander. Und dann pensieren solche Sachen wie, dass die Silicon-Welle-Bank-Pleite geht, nur durch Misskommunikation. Und plötzlich ist aber die Kredite Zwiss auch Pleite. Und Leute solche Sachen. Also alles hängt miteinander zusammen.
Und alle sagen, es ist nicht wie 2008.
Ja, und da werden alle nostalgisch und sagen, ich hätte gern wieder die Zeit zurück, in der man mit politischer Macht auch so in die Ökonomie eingreifen kann, dass man irgendwie, ja, wir wissen ja, ihr wollt Profit. Und das ist dann nicht ganz unsere Rationalität. Aber wir entscheiden jetzt einfach mal, oder wir bereiten entsprechend vor, damit sowas nicht passiert, kommt doch mal ins Weiße Haus und klären wir das mal. Also dieses Deutschland AG-Bild, das dahintersteckt, da kann man schon sehr nostalgisch werden, aber in dieser Zeit führt es halt sowieso nicht zurück.
Aber gibt es nicht einen ganz großen Widerspruch gerade zwischen der Bevölkerung und dem politischen System? Und ich würde jetzt mal noch die Akteure mit reinnehmen. Ich bin ja auch kein Systemtheoretiker. Wir haben jetzt anfangs über dieses Referendum in Berlin gesprochen. Da geht kaum jemand hin und dann auch nur die Hälfte eigentlich sagt, ja, können wir machen. Und die meisten Berliner haben offenbar andere Sorgen. Wenn ich jetzt hier diese Statistik nehme aus dem Wall Street Journal, dass alles runtergeht, also dass Interesse bzw. die Leidenschaft für Patriotismus, Religion, Kinder haben und Community-Involvement und nur das Interesse für Geld steigt, dann bedeutet das erst einmal, offenbar geht es vielen Leuten nicht besonders gut, deswegen ist Geld das Wichtigste. Also Leute, die Geld haben, sagen oft, Geld ist mir nicht so wichtig. Leute, die kein Geld haben, wissen, wie wichtig Geld ist.
Ja, aber bei einer 10% Inflation ist halt Geld das Knapp ist.
Genau, dann ist Geld das, was knapp ist und das, worauf die Priorität liegt. Geld ist aber auch etwas völlig Individualistisches und was sehr Funktionales.
Nicht zwingend. Also ich bin immer wieder beeindruckt, wie sehr die Tagsthemen oder so mit dem Börsenbericht doch für gute Laune sorgen können, indem sie einfach sagen, der Euro kletterte, dem DAX geht's gut. Das ist dann nicht mein Geld, sondern das ist einfach so das Thermometer für uns alle.
Aber wenn man einzelne Leute befragt, also wenn sie nicht sagen, eher ist für mich der Patriotismus wichtig als Geld oder die Religion wichtig als Geld, sondern sie sagen, Geld ist wichtiger. Wenn sie das sagen, dann bedeutet das doch erst einmal, dass sie, diese Bevölkerung, eigentlich auf der Hans-Werner-Sinnlinie liegen und sagen, gut, wir machen Handel, wir sind mit allen Ländern, die uns Profit bringen, egal welche Ideologien, welche Autokratien das sind, sind wir d'accord, uns geht es ums Geld. Wir wollen versuchen, möglichst viel Profit zu machen, wie die Unternehmer. Die Unternehmer, sagt Adam Tooze, sind rausgedrängt. Die Wall Street regiert nicht mehr mit der beiden Administrationen. Zugleich haben wir aber da eine Administration und haben generell eine Politik und haben auch einen medialen Widerhall. Wir haben es bei Ukraine gemerkt, wir werden das bei Taiwan wahrscheinlich dann noch einmal ganz genau so erleben, die aber die ganze Zeit sagt, Patriotismus, also die quasi ideologisch argumentiert. Also wir haben doch hier eine interessante Spaltung, dass wir zum einen eigentlich jetzt ist die liberale Idee durchgetrickelt, kann man sagen. Also jetzt wollen alle im Prinzip, dass es ihnen ein bisschen besser geht finanziell, während wir aber jetzt eine Politik haben, die sagt, naja, auch wenn die Apple-Aktie abstürzt, wir lösen uns von China, auch wenn das ein großes Desaster für Europa sein sollte und für die europäische Autoindustrie. Wir lösen uns von China. Und medial wird das dann auch entsprechend konstatiert. Das heißt, wir haben doch da eine unglaubliche Kluft gerade. Was bedeutet aber auch, wir erleben, wo wenig Rückhalt dafür eigentlich da ist, eine völlig andere, sagen wir ideologisch ausgerichtete Politik, auch Außenpolitik. Und mit ideologisch meine ich jetzt was Wertfreises. Also einfach nicht konsumistisch geleitet, wirtschaftlich geleitet, sondern sehr stark ideologisch geleitet.
Man könnte diese Liste hier auch ummodeln in so ein Intelligenz. Also es klingt ja fast wie bei so einem Intelligenz-Test, wenn man so fragt, was passt nicht in die Reihe? Aber Geld weiß ich, worum es geht. Kinderwunsch, ja keine Ahnung, später mal oder ist schon erledigt, aber wie auch immer, passt grad nicht in meinen... Also das kann man ja auch mal noch mal historisieren, ein bisschen ausklammern. Bei Geld weiß man einfach, worum es geht. Geld kann man, das ist wie dieses berühmte, das Gold, es glitzert und man kann es in die Hosentasche stecken und dann kommen so diese Weisheiten, ja für eine Goldmünze kannst du immer einen Mantel kaufen, egal ob 1923 oder 2023, usw. Das ist halt bei den anderen Kategorien, was soll man denn jetzt mit Patriotismus, Religion und Kinderwunsch?
Da frage ich mich auch fast mal, was man mit Patriotismus soll. Aber offenbar gibt es in der Politik und auch im Medial, wir haben das ja nun jetzt über ein Jahr hier durchgespielt, doch ganz andere Töne und das finde ich erstmal sehr interessant, also dass wir da eine Spaltung erleben, also da wieder bei den Repräsentanten und jenen, die sie repräsentieren sollen. Was soll denn jetzt Europa tun? Adam Tooze sagt Folgendes.
Denke ich, dass wir zurückgezwungen werden in Fragen, die wir möglicherweise viele von uns seit dem Konflikt 2003, den man aber abtun könnte als gewisserweise amerikanischer Amoklauf in Folge von 2001. Vielleicht werden wir zurückgedrängt durch diese Problematik und durch diese Formulierung des Problems in die Jahre der 80er Jahre, wo die europäische Linke eine viel schwerwiegende und komplexe Standortsbestimmung vollziehen sollte. Eine Standortbeziehung in Sachen NATO-Doppelbeschluss, die letztendlich auch zu einer Spaltung der deutschen Linken geführt hat.
Als hättest du den Clip schon gekannt, hast du eben gesagt, komisch, bei den Linken ist irgendwie alles durcheinandergegangen. Man fand, die Regierung macht auch immer nur dummes Zeug, wir sind gegen alles und jetzt aber, wenn Krieg ist, Regierung ist toll, vertritt den Willen des Volkes und so. Und diese Verwirrung, die du jetzt gerade so wunderbar aufgetan hast, die schildert eigentlich jetzt hier Tooze nochmal und sagt, ja, das könnte jetzt so ganz problematisch werden. Wo wird man sich dann eigentlich da in dem linken Lager, muss man wohl eher sagen, orientieren? Er sagt nämlich, Europa ist da schon ziemlich tief drin.
Das sind also meiner Meinung nach ganz fundamentale Fragen, die auf uns zukommen und zwar im rasenden Tempo. Was man nicht unterschätzen darf, ist, inwieweit diese Frage der strategischen Autonomie Europas bereits jetzt und nicht nur aufgrund von Putins Krieg mit einer riesen Hypothek belastet ist, im Moment hier gewisserweise eine Linie, einen Strich zu ziehen und im Moment Amerika zu erklären, dass man bereit ist, einen bestimmten Weg mit ihnen zu gehen, aber nicht weiter als das, würde jetzt bereits einen Bruch implizieren?
Das ist natürlich die Chinesen, ich hab es ja vorhin schon mal gesagt, fahren gerade semantisch alles auf, weil sie wissen, umso besser schützen wir uns davor, strukturell tätig werden zu müssen, also wirklich nicht schießen, lassen wir uns mal bei den Worten. Und dieses Problem hat ja Amerika auch. Man muss jetzt überall semantisch immer gleich rein, alles ist immer gleich der größte und so weiter Vorfall, überhaupt ein Ballon, der irgendwie oben rumfliegt, einer von Hunderten, ist dann immer gleich das Untergangsszenario und so. Und hier ist natürlich paradox, was er fordert. Er möchte nicht, dass es eine schießende Auseinandersetzung gibt, also dass es strukturell wird, dass wir dann wirklich ins, wo es teuer wird. Gleichzeitig will er das aber verhindern, indem wir semantisch schon mal runter regeln und Amerika Grenzen aufzeigen. Was ja nur bedeutet, wir schwächen diese semantische Auseinandersetzung auf westlicher Seite, was uns ja wieder gefährlich in so ein strukturell, also die Grenzüberschreitung zum strukturellen, weil wir müssen semantisch sozusagen, ja wieso? Es gibt dieses interessante Video, da ist so ein Zaun, so ein Tor, so ein Gartentor, und auf jeder Seite ist ein Hund und sie bellen sich an und man sieht so richtig, sie würden am liebsten übereinander herfallen. Plötzlich geht dieses Tor auf und dann stehen sie sich von jetzt auf gleich ohne dieses Gitter zwischen sich gegenüber, hören sofort auf zu bellen, tun so, als wäre nichts gewesen und gehen so ihre Wege, fallen nicht übereinander her. So und noch ist dieser Zaun da und solange dieser Zaun da ist, muss jeder dem anderen zeigen, sobald hier, ja, also niemand will sehen, wir können alle noch blöffen, soweit wie es geht, aber wir müssen eben auch. So und umso mehr wir uns anbellen, umso mehr sagen alle draußen Stehenden, lasst mal das Tor zu. Weil wenn die einfach nur so, dann kannste auch aufmachen, passiert nichts und so, und dann passiert aber doch was. Und das ist auch dieses Paradox hier.
Das ist die ganze Zeit eine Situation, also gerade weil wir schon so tief da drin sind.
Ich betone, ich stelle diese Situation bewusst, etwas dramatisch da. Und ich tue das nicht, um einfach nur um den Nachmittag zu beleben, sondern weil nicht wie viele anderen Besucher in Amerika die Stimmung in Washington in den letzten sechs Monaten zutiefst beunruhigt hat.
Also ich habe Adam Tooze so noch nicht sprechen hören. Das muss ich wirklich sagen. Und es war, als man dann dort live saß, ein ganz eigenartiges Gefühl, weil er es nochmal auch deutlich Europa abverlangt, was jetzt zu tun ist.
Ich würde mir wünschen, dass die Regierung Europas klipp und klar sagen, es gibt kein vorstellbares Szenario, in dem wir in einen militärischen Konflikt mit der Volksrepublik China uns hineinbegeben werden. Auch nicht als eure Alliierten. Es gibt einfach kein solches Szenario.
Also es gibt kein Szenario. Das würde wirklich bedeuten, dass man sagt, auch wenn irgendwas mit Taiwan sein wird, wir werden uns nicht daran beteiligen.
Aber willst du diese Botschaft an China senden? Wir machen nichts, selbst wenn ja Taiwan überfällt.
Intern kann man die senden.
Ist natürlich...
Ja, also ich würde die jetzt vielleicht nicht...
Aber was heißt intern? Du weißt ja nicht, wo China zuhört und wo nicht. Woraus sie Schlüsse ziehen und woraus nicht.
Nur die Sache ist, Amerika erwartet ja bereits, dass wir alle mitmachen. Er sagt das hier nochmal deutlich.
Das wäre ein Riesenschock im Moment für die amerikanische Politik. Das würde das Kongress nicht verarbeiten können. Das heißt, wenn man die zugrunde liegenden unausgesprochenen Prämissen der amerikanischen Politik im Moment offen ausspricht, kommt man sofort in einen Konflikt. Wenn man das nicht tut, lässt man sich gewisser Weise drauf ein. Das ist wirklich das Dilemma der europäischen Diplomatie im Moment.
Ja, das ist nicht nur ein Dilemma, das ist ein sehr großes Paradox.
Ja, und das ist nicht auflösbar. Vor allem, wenn man dann Habecks Mann hört, ist das mit Philipp Steinberg, das ist der Abteilungsleiter für Wirtschaftsstabilisierung und Energiesicherheit. Der war dann gleich im Anschluss mit Tooze zusammen auf dem Panel. Und wir hören uns nur vier Clips an. Ich muss es fast nicht kommentieren, glaube ich.
Herr Tooze, das war ja hochgradig spannend. Und ich habe gerade wieder über LNG-Terminals und so Wahnsinn verhandeln müssen, mal schön mal wieder so eine wirklich pointierte, akademische und intellektuelle Diskussion zu führen. Aber sehen Sie es mir nach, ein bisschen dann doch holzschnittartig und zuspitzenpolemisieren. Deswegen möchte ich ganz kurz vielleicht auch ein bisschen darauf antworten.
Ist aber, greift aber in eine andere Logik. Das ist halt Politik.
Ja, aber dann kann man vielleicht auch einfach den Mund halten. Das geht ja auch. Also ist das jetzt, wenn man das jetzt hört, so, aber vielleicht ein bisschen holzschnittartig. Und jetzt sagt er hier einfach...
China, die Bundesregierung, wir ringen ja auch, wie wir mit China umgehen sollen. Wir haben aber auch eine neue China-Strategie, die natürlich auch viel kritischer ist. Ja, warum denn? Weil in China alles Mögliche passiert. Angefangen mit Menschenrechte über die Art und Weise einer, ich sage es, imperialistischen Wirtschaftspolitik, die China macht, no-level playing field.
Also folgendes Beobachtungsangebot. Das ist eine Veranstaltung, die findet in Berlin statt. Vor ein paar Leuten und dann bei YouTube und wir pucken es hier auch und so. Jetzt ist aber für jemanden wie Philipp Steinberg in politischer Verantwortung, also eben nicht akademischer, sondern politischer Verantwortung ganz wichtig, dass er weiß, in China, in diesem riesigen Apparat, gibt es für jeden wie ihn einen Counterpart, der nur die Aufgabe hat, für die chinesische Partei zu beobachten, was Philipp Steinberg wo und wie vor allem sagt, mit welchem Ton. Also der hat jetzt zwei Publikums, zwei Publika. Einerseits uns, wir, die Öffentlichkeit und dann diesen einen Zuhörer, der einmal die Woche Report gibt an die Partei nach oben, was Philipp Steinberg auf der Bühne gesagt hat. Und den nimmt er ganz wichtig. Und das finde ich auch ganz wichtig, dass er den ganz wichtig nimmt. Dass er da so frau und schärfen uns gegenüber in Kauf nimmt, dafür aber ein Signal nach China sendet.
Aber welches Signal sendet er denn?
Ich finde es ganz schwierig mit diesem nur Subjekt-Sein, alles von den USA aus. Es mag alles zutreffen, was sie sagen und ich teile das und freue mich auch, wenn ich beim nächsten Mal in Washington bin, da nehme ich das ja auch wahr. Aber es ist ja eben nicht nur so, dass wir alle irgendwie Objekte von irgendwelchen Politikern aus Washington sind, sondern auch Subjekte. Ich habe schon die Angst, das wird ja auch von ganz vielen im Hinblick auf die Ukraine gesagt. Ein reines Subjekt ist nur ein Spiel bei fallamerikanischen Interessen und das finde ich schon ein bisschen problematisch. Deswegen, also in der Zuspitzung hoch spannend, aber ich glaube doch ein bisschen in der Realität ist es halt nicht so digital.
Also er versucht jetzt hier eigentlich schon Tooze in so eine Wagenknecht-Ecke mal zu stellen, zu sagen, wir haben ja gar keinen Schelfvertreterkrieg.
Naja, er spielt das runter, um dem Bekenntnis zu entgehen, werden sie jetzt mit Amerika diesen Systemstreit, wie Amerika will gegen China kämpfen oder nicht? Da sagt er, ich erkenne das gar nicht an, ihr Richt, was sie mir hier und so, nur weil sie können sich ja nicht zum Richter aufspielen.
Dann muss man ja eigentlich die Veranstaltung machen mit Adam Tooze und noch jemand anderes, wegen mir Hans-Werner Sinn, oder ich würde es auch machen, ich war ja dann später zu Gast, nicht mit Adam Tooze, aber dann braucht man niemanden da vom Ministerium. Oder der sagt, sie wissen, ich kann jetzt eh nur Unsinn reden.
Öffentliche Kommunikation von Politik in Verantwortung ist immer paradox, immer. Du kommst aus dieser Sache nicht raus.
Ja, ich gehe ja deshalb nicht in Politik.
Es ist superschwer, sich von Politikern über Politik informieren zu lassen.
Genau, oder im Hintergrundgespräch dann vielleicht. Aber ich gehe zum Beispiel auch nicht in eine politische Talkshow mit Politikern, weil die ja keinen interessegeleiteten Dialog führen, sondern die führen ja einen machtgeleiteten Dialog.
In ihrer Rationalität.
Deswegen muss ich ja nicht mit denen reden. Also ich kann die ja nicht überzeugen mit einem Argument, weil die ja auf einer ganz anderen Ebene diskutieren.
Sagen wir es mal so, es ist halt mit Philipp Steinberg vor Publikum zu reden, ist wie mit Jett GPT oder GPT-4 jetzt zu reden. Man weiß halt nicht so genau, man muss selber mitdenken. Es kommt darauf an, wie der Dialog sich entfaltet und so weiter.
Aber ich erwarte eigentlich schon von einem Mann, der aus einem grünen Wirtschaftsministerium stammt, dass er nicht da steht und wie so ein Lehrer sagt, sagen wir eine tolle akademische Rede, gibt es auch eine 2 Plus für. Aber ich glaube, es war doch alles Holzschnittartig und ist ein bisschen überzeichnet, ein bisschen polemisch und weiß ich nicht was. Sondern man kann auch schon sagen, ja, es gibt eine große berechtigte Sorge, dass wir in einen Konflikt hinein geraten. Oder es gibt auch das große Problem, dass wir in der multipolaren Weltordnung das so und so sehen. Aber einfach so diese Realität zu leugnen. Also ich will den letzten Clip spielen von ihm noch, weil das wirklich irre ist.
Aber haben wir eine Chance und wenn sein Szenario zutrifft, dann haben wir keine zehn Jahre Zeit.
Naja, also diese Kriegsrhetorik ist noch nicht zu mir vorgedrungen. Ich bin jetzt Ende April wieder in Washington auf der deutsch-amerikanischen Konferenz. Bin gespannt, ob ich das da so wahrnehme.
Also wenn du ihn weiter in deinem Sinne in die Ecke treibst, wirst du immer ein Bekenntnis zum transatlantischen Bündnis bekommen.
Das ist mir schon klar. Ich hätte jetzt nicht gedacht, dass der jetzt sagt, wir lösen uns von Amerika in dem Nachmittag. Das war mir fürich gar, aber dass man derart die Realität leugnet, die ja so im Handelsblatt täglich zu lesen ist. Also es ist ja nicht so, als würde man jetzt zum ersten Mal gerade hier erfahren haben, dass Amerika und China auf einem Konfrontationskurs miteinander sind und dass es diese Think-Tanks gibt und dass es ja da lange Ausführungen gibt. Das war jetzt mal nur ein Paper, das ich eben zitiert habe. Wie so ein Krieg sich gestalten würde, dass seit fünf Jahren sowohl Historiker als auch andere Politikwissenschaftler und sonst wer darüber reden, dass es diese Tukididis-Falle gibt und kann man der entkommen oder nicht. Und dann steht man da und sagt, ich habe da noch nichts mitbekommen, aber ich werde das nächste Mal in Washington darauf achten. Kann man dem Mann mal ein Abo vom Handelsblatt oder so schenken? Also ich finde es wirklich entsetzlich. Und ich saß dort, also das ist auch dann nochmal dieses Live-Erlebnis, ich saß wirklich da und dachte, gut, das ist jetzt die Regierung hier, eben hat Adam Tooze gesprochen, Berlin vielleicht doch mal den Flughafen jetzt ausprobieren und auf und davon. Also man denkt ja, also man kriegt es ja mit der Angst zu tun. Wir hören jetzt zum Schluss noch einmal Tooze, der sich davon abbringen lässt und ja, eine Anekdote aus einem Zoom-Call noch schildert.
Die Anti-China-Politik ist wirklich flächendeckend Konsens. Und das geht, ich will das nur unter uns. Ich war in sehr direkten Verhandlungen mit den führenden Personen innerhalb des White Houses in Sachen Außenpolitik. Und die Frage stand tatsächlich zur Debatte, ob Coexistenz mit China für Amerika in Zukunft mittelfristig möglich sein wird.
Adam Tooze hat daraufhin dann mal seinen Zoom-Schirm ausgeschaltet und dann hätte aber ein besonderer Kollege nachgefragt, meinen wir damit so eine kalte Kriegssituation von Coexistenz? So was meint ihr eigentlich? Und dann haben sie ja so rumschwatroniert. Aber an dem Punkt sind wir da und ich würde das jedenfalls sehr ernst nehmen, was Tooze da sagt und glaube, dass wir eine sehr von Ideologie getriebene Außenpolitik und Wirtschaftspolitik jetzt fahren. Und wie gesagt, jetzt ist es an der Zeit, Hans Werner Sinn hervorzukramen. Nicht zur Lohnpreisspirale, nicht zur EZB-Politik, sondern tatsächlich, wie kann Handel gestaltet werden? Und jetzt Wandel durch Handel wegwerfen, halte ich für eine fatale Situation.
Ich auch, aber ich will noch eine Sache zu Tooze sagen. Wenn wir hier Steinberg dafür kritisieren, dass er da nicht offen genug für solche Argumente ist und sich dann auch dazu bekennt und sagt, nein und so, wir wollen da gar nicht mitspielen, dieses Spiel soll doch, wenn Amerika das so auf hart trimmen möchte, seine eigenen Nimbus als der Hegemon weiterführen möchte, dann sollen sie es alleine machen, ohne uns oder so. Ich finde, wenn man so wie Adam Tooze argumentiert, zum einen mit so einer innerlichen Argumentation, also so Funktional, wo man so denkt, ja macht irgendwie Sinn, ist nachvollziehbar. Auf der anderen Seite aber, so reden die da so. Dann muss er auch sagen, wer da so redet. Also kann er ruhig Namen nennen und die Veranstaltung, weil das im Unklaren zu lassen und gleichzeitig auch von Steinberg offene Bekenntnisse zu fordern, ist dann so eine Disbalance.
Ja, ich glaube, dass er das natürlich nicht kann, weil das ging jetzt um interne Diskussionen.
Ja genau, es ist eben eine interne Diskussion und Steinberg sagt ja auch, wir haben unsere eigene Rationalität, die ich hier vor Publikum natürlich, wenn sie mich hier vor Publikum fragen, sage ich so und so. Wir wissen auch, dass der Steinberg mit Habeck anders darüber redet, insbesondere wenn die dann...
Das wissen wir, aber wir sehen auch die Kriegsrhetorik sehr deutlich von demokratischen und publikanischen Politikern artikuliert.
Ja, aber das wäre doch interessant, wenn Tooze uns zeigt, wer da und dann so, dass wir das auch sozusagen als Forschungsgrundlage nehmen können, die Roten Liegen aufzuarbeiten.
Er sagt jedenfalls, es gibt nicht irgendwo eine Linke noch, bei der man sagen kann, ah ja, das sind irgendwie so diese paar Joe-Mansions bei den Demokraten oder so etwas, sondern er sagt, es gibt gar nicht noch mal andere Demokraten. Es gibt nicht irgendwo eine große linke Kraft, die das anders sieht, sondern das ist das politische Spektrum, das das ziemlich einhellig so sieht, wie eben auch bei dieser TikTok- Veranstaltung da zu erleben war. Na ja, es sind düstere Aussichten, aber der Mensch ist ja auch immer noch zu Großtaten fähig, nicht nur zu kriegerischen Auseinandersetzungen, beziehungsweise der Mensch kann diese Großtaten jetzt eigentlich delegieren an ein Programm, das das alles macht, oder?
So ist es, wenn er klug genug ist für das Programm. Wir sind ja, als wir über GPT auf der Bühne sprachen, auch schon Illustre ein bisschen eingestiegen. Samsungs Mondfakes und so weiter. Und ich dachte mir jetzt, machen wir das hier auch. Christopher Nolan hat dieses Jahr einen neuen Film. Ja, es geht um eine technische Entwicklung. Er möchte das nochmal historisch aufziehen. Und wir wissen ja, Wikipedia ist dafür da, uns die Fakten gerade zu ziehen. Und für das Gefühl kriegen wir dann so Filme wie von Nolan, die uns nochmal darbieten, was gedacht und gemacht wurde im Zuge einer technischen Innovation. Und ohne, dass wir im Vorfeld sagen, um welche es da geht, hören wir kurz in den Trailer rein, in dem also dieses Gefühl, dass über zwei Stunden oder wie auch immer transportiert und aufgebracht werden soll, nochmal zusammengeschnurrt wird auf, das ist aber wirklich aufregend, da müssen wir ins Kino. Und aus diesem zweiminütigen Trailer hören wir eine Minute. Also wir haben es jetzt mit einem sehr reduzierten, roten Faden einer sehr großen historischen Entwicklung zu tun.
Wir stellen uns eine Zukunft vor.
Und unsere Vorstellungen schockieren uns.
Wie kommt man da nicht weiter?
Ich weiß nicht, ob man uns eine solche Waffe...
Wir haben keine Wahl. Wir vertrauen uns selber nicht. Mit Theorie kommen wir hier nicht weiter.
Und wir werden sie erst fürchten, wenn wir sie verstehen. Und wir werden sie erst verstehen, wenn wir sie einsetzen.
Ja, wenn wir sie sehen. Es geht also um die Atombombe. Und wir wissen ja, die Atombombe, das ist ja auch ein bisschen Dual Use. Oppenbar hat er nicht Atombombe erfunden, sondern Kernspaltung nutzbar gemacht, kann man ja auch in Atomkraft werken. Und klar, dieser Film zielt jetzt auf den Bomben-Astteil ab, aber wir könnten ja auch eine Kulturgeschichte, der relativ günstigen, zumindest im Moment, Folgekosten sind eine andere Sache. Aber wir haben erst mal so damals diese Idee von unbegrenzter Energie. In jedem Garten steht ein Atomkraftwerk und so weiter und so fort.
Bis bei Ernst Bloch war das noch nachzulesen. In den 50er Jahren hatte man da sehr, sehr große Ambitionen und Hoffnungen dran geknüpft.
So, und jetzt ist ja die Frage 2023. In 90 Jahren, welche Filme machen wir dann über GPT? Der Sohn von Christopher Nolan, was macht er uns für Filme dann? Weil das ist ja auch ganz offensichtlich Dual Use. Also wir können, das ist ja hier auch, man sieht ja in diesem kurzen Trailerstück, wie sie Atombombe bauen. Also man hat diesen nuklearen Sprengkopf und der wird ja getriggert dadurch, dass rundherum konventionelle Bomben gebaut werden. Die explodieren dann und stauchen den Kern so zusammen, dass es dann, dass die Kernspaltung ausgelöst wird. Und so ist ja auch ein bisschen hier. Also wir haben eine relativ kleine Energiequelle, nämlich konventionelle Bomben, um eine exorbitante, um mehrere Faktoren größere Energiequelle auszulösen. Und wir haben also einen sehr kleinen Prompt, einen sehr kleinen Such-Fragestellung-Befehl, wie auch immer, der aber so ein riesiges Netzwerk an und so weiter Daten senden, Datencenter plötzlich alle in Bewegung versetzt, um uns eine Antwort zu liefern. Also wir können mit einem ganz kurzen Sprachbefehl nicht nur ein Gesprächspartner trickern oder so, sondern das ganze Weltwissen auf einmal uns zur Verfügung stellen lassen, in dem einfach rote Faden aus und gelernt wurde, alles Mögliche, die ganze Wikipedia steckt da drin, alle eingescandene Bücher, und noch das ganze wilde Web, wie man es zur Verfügung hat, wenn man die Roboter durchstellt, das kennen wir ja von Google. Also das einmal alles zu duplizieren und sich irgendwie nutzbar zu machen, kennen wir schon, aber dass wir jetzt auch noch so Sinngebung, rote Fäden daraus extrahieren, also nicht nur uns einfach wiedergeben lassen, was steckt denn so drin, sondern uns auch noch so, naja, dass auf verschiedenen Ebenen so Deutungsmuster oder Ideen und so rausgearbeitet werden, das ist ja jetzt neu.
Und die Dialogizität ist vielleicht auch nicht zu unterschätzen, dass man Fragen stellt, Antworten bekommt und ja auch dann bei Chachipiti, so habe ich zumindest gelesen Chachipiti 4, also der neuesten Variante, dass dort auch dann Rückfragen wiederum gestellt werden. Man wird ja richtig in einen Diskurs vermittelt oder auch schon bei dem einfachen Chachipiti, dass man so gratis nutzen kann, ist es ja schon so, dass auch die AI einen fragt, ob man das jetzt so oder so meinte oder gerne könne sie auch da und da sowas sagen, aber das wäre ja nicht ihr Feld. Oder wir wissen ja auch, dass sie manche Sachen nicht beantwortet, da müssen wir auch mal über diese Art der Einhegung reden.
Denkbar ist alles, kommt halt auf den Prompt an. Wenn du sagst, stell mir Rückfragen, stell dir halt Rückfragen, gib mir immer drei Auswahlmöglichkeiten, kriegst halt immer drei. Und du kannst ja auch die Dialogfähigkeit so nachvollziehen und dem du einfach als allerersten Befehl mitgibst, lasse das letzte Wort deiner Antwort immer auf N enden und dann siehst du, dass auch die siebzehnte Frage noch mit, also die siebzehnte Antwort, die du zurückbekommst von der Maschine, immer noch im letzten Wort ein N hat. Also sie hat das nicht vergessen am Anfang. Humann hat da mit rumgespielt und hat dann auch so ewig lange Beraterfragen mit der Maschine geklärt und hat dann auch am Ende ja, aber was bedeutet das jetzt im Bezug auf meine Ausgangsfrage? So, nun kennt sie die noch und hat ja auch die Historie und geht das dann alles nochmal durch. Also es ist wahnsinnig interessant, womit man gleich zu so ein Paradek mal kommt. Wir werden jetzt nur Original-Töne der Open AI-Macher oder ihres Dunstkreises, also Bill Gates und so weiter als große Finanzielles im Hintergrund, hören. Wir könnten natürlich auch die 280 Seiten Stellungnahme des Ethikrats nicht nur zur GPT, sondern auch den ganzen anderen künstlichen Intelligenzsystemen der Medizin und so weiter und so fort oder die Dokumentation von Open AI selbst. Die dokumentieren hier relativ viel, wenn auch sehr unspezifisch, was die Modelle oder das Training selbst angeht. Und wir belassen es mal bei den Original-Tönen der Macher. Die drohen also auch, ihnen auf den Leim zu gehen, denn es ist längst nicht alles so schön, wie das da immer heißt und so super neu. Also das Internet zu indexieren, wenn Alena Büchster irgendwie sagt, das sind ja alles nur stochastische Papageien. Ja gut, stochastische Papageien, das war Alta Vista vor 25 Jahren oder so. Also dass man einfach irgendwas rein und dann kommt halt, nach Wahrscheinlichkeit errechnet, was willst du denn zurück haben, kommt halt was zurück und dann sucht man sich etwas aus und so. Sondern jetzt geht es ja um mehr. Du hast die Dialogfähigkeit angesprochen und das ist ja auch, was mich am meisten fasziniert, dass man das Ding halt wirklich verwickeln kann. Man muss es so in Stimmung versetzen für ein spezifisches Thema oder Problem. Das dauert dann auch so drei, vier Anläufe, dann kann man auch relativ zügig an die, du darfst nur 25 Fragen in drei Stunden stellen und so. Da kommt man schnell an so eine Grenze. Aber man kann es eben in Stimmung versetzen und keine Antwort wird vergessen. Sondern du kriegst wirklich einen Dialog hin, wie Interaktion.
Wie achten hier jetzt auf deine Worte? In Stimmung versetzt du also die KI?
Die KI muss in Stimmung versetzt werden. Also du hast immer den inhaltlichen Suchbegriff oder was auch immer, wenn du es als Datenbank benutzen willst, aber auch die Systemeingabe. Du versetzt es in einen bestimmten Modus. Du sagst ihm, du bist ein Drittklässler, schreibe mir, schreibe ein Aufsatz über Eichhörnchen. Jetzt mit der Sprache eines Dreijährigen. Dann kriegst du halt drei Drittklässler. Oder schreibe mir die Einleitung einer Dessertation. Dann kriegst du alles, was so in Zertration sein muss. Fachworte, der ganze lateinische Kram, Forschungsstand, Anmerkungen und so was. Es ist nicht einfach nur die Google-Suche, werfe ich ein Substantiv rein und gucke mal, welches das höchst gerankte ist. Das Ding reagiert so ein bisschen auf dich. Es nimmt in der Hinsicht, und das ist für so einen Soziologen wahnsinnig interessant, es nimmt an Kommunikationsteil und zwar als eigener Akteur.
Ja, richtig.
Und zwar als eigener Akteur, dem du, deswegen unterhält man sich ja mit ihm, nicht einfach vorhersehen kannst, was er sagt oder so, sondern es ist schon diese doppelte Kontingenz. Du weißt nicht, was du von der Maschine zurückbekommst und du weißt erst recht nicht, was du als nächstes stellst, weil das ja davon abhängt, was du von der Maschine zurückbekommst. Also du bist dir selbst plötzlich so im Unklaren und damit sind wir ganz nah an der menschlichen Kommunikation, aber es ist eben nicht Kommunikation unter Menschen, was wieder bedeutet, wenn Luhmann immer geschrieben hat, Kommunikationstheorie nimmt den Menschen erst mal raus, sondern es ist nur die Kommunikation entscheidet, dann kann das hier jetzt jeder fühlen. Also hier geht es jetzt nur um die Kommunikation. Man kann zwar jetzt davor sitzen wie so ein Therapeut oder wie ein Freund oder wie ein Vater oder wie ein Lehrer, sich denken, ah, du bist ja ein Schüler, also mach ich das jetzt mal pädagogisch so und so, oder du bist ja ein Freund, also mach ich das immer so und so, oder eben du bist dann ein Anwalt, also du bist ja mein Klient, also mach ich das so und so, dann Patientenverhältnis. Sondern hier sieht man, nee, es lohnt sich jetzt gar nicht, Gedanken darauf zu verschwenden, was hat die sich jetzt wirklich gedacht, stecken da verborgen, Intention dahinter, was auch immer, sondern die Kommunikation alleine zählt. Und das war ja immer Lumans Botschaft, ja, bei menschlicher Kommunikation auch. Man glaubt nur immer, man kann in den Kopf des anderen gucken, also sozusagen zwischen den Zeilen hindurch. Aber nee, am Ende ist es einfach nur, verstehen ist die Unterscheidung von Information und Mitteilung. Es fand also eine Mitteilung statt, an mich, und wir hatten Informationsgehalt. Da kommt es halt bei mir an. Aber was eigentlich abgesendet wurde, wie das zu deuten ist, keine Ahnung.
Wir haben immer diesen Authentizitätsdiskurs, wenn es um Kommunikation geht. Und klar, es gibt diese ganz offenen Dialoge und es gibt vielleicht das große Liebesgeständnis, solche Sachen. Und da kann man auch von Aufrichtigkeit ausgehen. Aber wir können ja zunächst einmal für das meiste, was wir so am Tag an Kommunikation bewältigen, feststellen, dass es uns völlig ausreicht, wenn gewisse Konventionen erfüllt sind. Und es macht uns glücklich, selbst wenn wir bei näherer Betrachtung wissen, dass es nur gespielt ist. Also wenn ich an der Hotelrezeption freundlich empfangen werde und dann sogar die Dame, weil sie das natürlich im Programm sieht, sagt, schön, dass sie wieder bei uns sind, dann fühle ich mich ein wenig zu Hause, wenngleich ich natürlich das Spiel in gewisser Weise durchschaue. Aber in dem Moment durchschaue ich es nicht immer laufend oder will es nicht immer laufend durchschauen, sondern sage einfach, ach, das ist ja toll. Und würde mich wahrscheinlich sogar ärgern, wenn ich da schon fünfmal war und die immer noch sagen, ja, waren sie schon mal bei uns, können sie mal das Kommunalhaus füllen.
Ja, genau. Also wir haben es auf sehr vielen Ebenen mit gar nicht so neuer Kommunikation zu tun, außer dass wir einsehen, okay, das ist kein Mensch, mit dem wir es zu tun haben. Es ist halt erkennbar, eine Maschine, Roboter wollen wir nicht sagen, weil der Körper fehlt ihr noch. Das wäre dann sozusagen in 20 Jahren die nächste Evolutionsstufe, dass das dann so verschmolzen wird mit einem Körper wie unser Gehirn, mit unserem Leib. Und wir haben vor allem die wirkliche Erkenntnis jetzt, es kommt auf die Differenzen an. Also wir haben nicht einfach Begriffe, sondern wenn jemand Tisch sagt, meint er den Tisch und damit nicht den Stuhl und nicht den Boden und nicht die Decke und nicht die Wand und so, sondern darauf wird jetzt auch nochmal besonders Fokus gelegt. Ah ja, wenn mir die Maschine irgendwas sagt und ich bin damit aber noch nicht zufrieden, dann habe ich offenbar eine falsche Differenz in meiner Frage formuliert, die dann aufgegriffen wurde. Ich wollte gar nicht, dass der Tisch vom Stuhl unterschieden wird, sondern ich wollte, dass der Tisch vom Fernseher unterschieden wird. Da muss man der Maschine sagen, welche Differenz man eigentlich wollte. Also was man nicht dazu gesagt hatte, also die dunkle Seite der Differenz, muss man dann nochmal erhellen, damit die Maschine steht, ach so, darum ging es dir, um diese Unterscheidung.
Bedeutet aber, dass die Maschine eine Deutungshoheit hat.
Die braucht dafür eine Deutungshoheit. Bei Tisch und Stuhl. Die muss meine Deutungshoheit, sofern ich sie mir unterstelle, nachvollziehen. Die muss wissen, was ich meine.
Aber wie ist es jetzt bei Begriffen, die nicht so klar sind wie Tisch oder Stuhl, die für uns alle, wenn wir jetzt die ganze Zeit auf dem Kopf stehen...
Partyrotismus, Religion, Kinderwunsch. Also bei Geld weiß jeder was, aber bei den anderen muss man es halt klären.
Revolutionär Widerstandskämpfer oder Terrorist. Das ist ja eine Frage der Betrachtung.
Genau, da muss man klären, was man eigentlich meint. Also ob man Terrorist oder Freiheitskämpfer schreibt, macht einen großen Unterschied. Das sieht man dann in den Antworten, die kommen. Also in deren Sicht, ich habe jetzt auch für mein nächstes Buch, ich wollte aber nur mal spielen, ich bin noch nicht sehr weit.
Hast du es schon schreiben lassen?
Ja, zum Thema Familie. Meine Frage ist ja immer, warum behandeln wir Familien so anders als Unternehmen politisch? Die sind doch auch wirtschaftliche Einheiten, die Nachwuchs produzieren und so weiter und brauchen so Pensionen. Ganz Marxistisch gedacht von dir, Stefan.
Das ist so. Ja, das stimmt so.
Das kann man mit GPT sehen.
Becker würde das auch so sehen. Also Marxisten und der neoliberale Gary S. Becker sind ja in gewisser Weise da ähnlich drauf.
Mir geht es ja da weniger um so ein Informationsspiel als um Inspirationsspiel, weil GPT sagt mir dann plötzlich, ja, das eine ist eben Zivilrecht, das andere ist so. Warum gibt es da keine Subvention? Und dann, ja, weil Familien so und so aufgebaut sind. Und kann man immer nachfragen, ja, wonach sind denn Familien aufgebaut und so. Und dann kriegst du entweder kannst du in die Richtung steuern, dass du es dann über Organisation, Mitgliedschaft, Kinder sind halt nicht austauschbar, anders als Mitarbeiter und so weiter, wachsen, schrumpfen ist schwierig und der ganze Kram. Also da kann man sich sehr gut inspirieren lassen, weil die kennt ja die ganze Literatur. Und zwar schon inkorporiert in den eigenen Trainingsdatensatz, der ja irgendwann September 2021 oder so endet. Plus du kannst ja jetzt in GPT-4 neuen Input geben. Also du kannst ja seitenlange soziologische Texte einfach mitgeben zu deiner Frage und sagen, warum wird das hier in diesem Text so sehr unterschieden? Was sind die Argumente, mit denen die das anders sehen als und so weiter? Und dann wird dir das so kurz aufgedröselt und dann hat man zumindest die Ansatzpunkte, an denen man so weitergeht. Also man hat so ein neues Verständnis von Vollständigkeit irgendwie. 20 Euro im Monat. Also ist auch, wir haben es jetzt nicht mit den sozialen Netzen, die sich über Werbung oder so finanzieren zu tun, sondern es ist auch da ein neues Paratikmar, das ganz entscheidend ist. Also Kommunikation einmal behandelt. Komplexität. Diese auch so eine Luhmann-Idee, ja Komplexität reduzieren, sagen immer alle. Das ist ja so der vulgäre, ja Komplexität muss reduziert werden. Ja, aber mit jeder Komplexitätreduktion baut man ja auch wieder welche auf. Und man hat es also weniger mit Komplexitätsreduktion, als mit zum Komplexitäts-Shift zu tun. Das ist natürlich bei GPT ganz entscheidend, wenn man, was weiß ich, hunderte Artikel der Wikipedia zu einem Problem, also verschiedene Themen, die aber ein Problem immer wieder befassen. Wie zum Beispiel 200 Länder, alle haben unterschiedliche Regierungssysteme. Sagen wir mal die drei großen Unterschiede, also nach welchen drei Kriterien könnte man die Regierungssysteme der Welt. Und dann wird halt in den Wikipedia nachgelesen, was das politische System des Landes ist. Und dann baut es diese rote Fäden raus. Das haben wir jetzt sehr schön reduziert. Also wir haben jetzt die ganze Komplexität der Regierungssysteme reduziert auf drei Kategorien und das dem irgendwie zugeordnet. Mehr oder weniger sinnvoll. Gleichzeitig habe ich aber jetzt wieder die Möglichkeit, eine ganz neue Fragestellung zu generieren. Also ich baue auch wieder Komplexität auf. Das wäre es also nicht nur mit Komplexitätsreduktion, nicht nur mit Vereinfachung, sondern auch wieder mit Verkomplizierung und so weiter zu tun haben. Das werden wir immer ein bisschen übersehen. Ist aber einfach mit drin. Also man muss ja einfach sehen, wie sehr GPT jetzt nicht nur neue Kommunikation, sondern auch so einen ganzen Shift, einfach so eine ganze Umlagerung von Komplexität bedeutet. Also man geht durch diesen Garten und gräbt den einfach mal so richtig durch. Und der Garten ist aber unsere ganze Gesellschaft. Und da hat man es also wirklich mit großen Herausforderungen zu tun, mit dieser neuen Art von Komplexität, die da auch aufgebaut wird, das mal umzugehen.
Wo du das jetzt ansprichst mit der Komplexität, zugleich ist es ja ganz einfach zu bedienen im Sinne von wie es aufgebaut ist. Und dann gibt es ja auch eine Komplexitätsreduktion oder sagen wir eine Hilfe in der Kommunikation, die mich interessiert. Vielleicht hast du was darüber erfahren. Wenn ich dort etwas eingebe, eine Frage stelle, dann sehe ich ja schon dieses Strichlein, also in dem Textfeld, das dann schon aufblinkt. Und dann dauert es eine Weile, bis die Antwort kommt. Und die Antwort kommt ja nicht einfach so, sondern die wird ja getippt. Als säße jemand da und tippt dir die Antwort. Das ist ein Showding, oder? Denn eigentlich könnte man auch einfach den Text komplett zeigen.
Na ja, also er berechnet ja Buchstabe pro Buchstabe. Das könnte man auch so darstellen. Aber das ist so wie beim Aktienhandel, das sind natürlich Millisekunden, also es ist eigentlich Hochrequenzkommunikation. Aber das wird für uns ein bisschen runtergedimmt, damit wir auch nicht…
Ich hab, dass man ein bisschen den Chat-Eindruck bekommt.
Genau. Das ist alles noch sehr auf natürliche Sprache und so. Da wird uns gute Show gemacht.
Dass man denkt, ah ja, so hab ich auch immer bei WhatsApp geschrieben.
Ja und dann haben wir das dritte K, also Kommunikation, Komplexität und Konzepte. Wir haben es ja jetzt mit, wir haben es ja besprochen auf der Bühne. Frank Grieger hat ja schon beschrieben, okay, wir haben es nicht mal mit nachvollziehbaren Computer-Vorgängen zu tun. Wir können uns nicht mehr darauf verlassen, sondern die Halluzinieren und so. Das sind ja auch alles so Begriffe, die Open-AI jetzt geprägt hat. Unsere Maschinen Halluzinieren. 20 Prozent davon sind einfach errechnet, wahrscheinlicher Antworten, die aber keinen Sinn ergeben. So, wir stehen also einer Maschine gegenüber, der wir mit genauso viel menschlicher Intelligenz gegenüberstehen müssen, wie eine Organisation. Wir können nicht einfach reingehen und uns die Selbstbeschreibung abholen, sondern wir müssen selber mit eigenen Forschungsfragen und eigenen Forschungskonzeptionen davorstehen und das erforschen, was GPT da macht. Niemand weiß, was GPT macht. Wir müssen es erforschen. Wir wissen selber, wie es aufgebaut ist. Dann liest man aber auch wieder, es sind 96 verschiedene Layer, in denen gewichtete Verknüpfungen von Synapsen gemacht werden, wo man denkt, ja gut, das ist halt erkennbar nicht nachvollziehbar. Man kann dann mal so eine Forensik einer einzelnen Anfrage oder sowas machen, aber im Großen und Ganzen gibt es da keinen Analysemodus wie bei, keine Ahnung, Westworld, dass man dann sagt, stopp, jetzt geh mal kurz in Analysemodus, erklär mir. Dafür bräuchte man wieder eigene künstliche Intelligenz in diesem Stil, die das beobachtet, die uns dann versucht, das zu erklären. Aber wir können ja nicht einfach sagen, eine Maschine, also es ist keine Trivialmaschine, sondern eine Blackbox ist wirklich eine Blackbox. Wir müssen sie also erstmal einfach operieren lassen und brauchen dann eine eigene Theorieentwicklung. Die können wir wieder unterstützen lassen mit anderen Computersystemen, um dann zu verstehen, was da passiert ist. Es ist also wahnsinnig kompliziert und ganz wichtig, wir haben es mit sehr viel Emergenz zu tun. Also wir können nicht mehr einfach sagen, es sind ja nur Nullen und Einzen und so, sondern ja auf der ersten Ebene ist 1 plus 1 2, aber dann kann man mit der 2 schon weiter operieren und spätestens auf der fünften Ebene hat man große Zahlen, auf der siebten Ebene hat man nicht mehr Zahlen, sondern alles andere und dann greift das alles so ineinander, dass wir sagen müssen, ja das ist zwar am Ende irgendwie dann doch Mathematik, aber da spielt so viel Zufalls und überhaupts und so. Also es ist nicht mehr einfach reduzierbar, weil man sagen kann, also ja Mathe. Zum Glück ist ja Mathe übersichtlich, sondern wir haben ja auch schon bei Einberger gehört. Also Mathe entzieht sich auch relativ zügig. Irgendwelchen Nachvollziehbarkeiten. So und wir gehen mal das in verschiedenen Kapiteln durch und beginnen bei den Prämissen. Zum einen Greg Brockman, der gilt dann so als Open AI Präsident. Keine Ahnung, wir werden den CEO und den technischen Leiter.
Aber alles Namen, die man sich jetzt schon mal merken kann, das sind jetzt die Namen, die wahrscheinlich dieses Jahrzehnt prägen werden.
Ja, es ist eine wahnsinnig interessante Gang. Das sind jetzt wirklich diese Leute, die als Pioniere, es ist ja nicht Bill Gates, der Einzige, der jemals ein Betriebssystem geschrieben hat, aber er hat als erstes so dieses Ganze, wir machen das mal grafisch und so weiter, wir erfinden eine Maus, hat das damit geprägt. Dann Mark Zuckerberg natürlich, soziale Netzwerke, also einmal die ganze soziale Landschaft, einmal digital duplizieren, selbst wenn sich die Leute nicht anmelden, so Schattenprofile und so weiter, also alles einmal darzulegen und Menschen erreichbar zu machen, mit so einer einheitlichen Adresse auszustatten und uns Menschen mit Computern in Sprache, also dass jetzt unser Interface das Maßgebende ist und nicht mehr deren, dass wir keine Computersprache mehr lernen müssen, sondern dass der Computer jetzt menschliche Sprache lernt. Das ist sozusagen das Nowhoben, das jetzt OpenAI uns gebracht hat. Aber sie werden damit lange, also nur kurz alleine sein, sind jetzt alle großen Player schon aufgetreten. Facebook mit Lambda und Google ist ja jetzt auch schon da und so. Na ja, der Brockman, wir gehen mal nur die Prämissen durch, hier auf der South by Southwest Bühne kürzlich.
Für die AI, für die Sprache in particular, ist jedes Geschäft bereits ein Sprache-Business. Jedes Flow ist ein Sprache-Flug. Und ich denke, das ist das Grunde, das die Erdbeutung und die Freude wirklich vertreten.
Jedes Business ist schon ein Schwerpunkt, ein Sprachbusiness. Das stimmt natürlich. Hat man ja bei Corona gemerkt, wenn alle nur im Homeoffice zu Hause hängen, kann man die Programme, die man offen hat, noch schnell abarbeiten, jeder für sich. Aber wenn das Küchengespräch und die Vorstandssitzung nicht vor Ort stattfindet, fehlt es so ein bisschen. Und an diesen so wichtigen und egal in welchem Feld, Krankenhaus, Schule, Universität, Forschungsabteilung, da wo menschliche Sprache ist, kann sich jetzt der Computer einmischen und dir alles zur Verfügung stellen. Und zwar nicht nur als Datenbank, sondern wirklich als SIN-Maschine, die dir die roten Fäden und so weiter rauspickt. Bill Gates war im Gespräch mit dem technischen, also dem CTO, dem Chief Technology Officer von Microsoft. Die ist wirklich erstaunlich. Ich werde auch die Liste hier verlinken. Das sind wirklich erstaunlich viele interessante YouTube-Videos, die man jetzt so sehen kann. Hier hören wir Bill Gates. Na, wir machen weiter wie bisher selbst mit Computern jetzt. Sogar mit Computern, das ist das neue. Also wir bleiben einfach bei der menschlichen Sprache, die uns ja allen zur Verfügung steht und können damit jetzt Computer programmieren.
Also das Programmieren geht jetzt über das Prompten.
Prompten ist Programmieren und wenn du mit dem Resultat nicht zufrieden bist, kannst du ja nachsteuern.
Wir haben ja noch diesen ganz starken Diskurs, sollte man nicht Programmieren an Schulen unterrichten? Und jetzt müsste man eigentlich schon sagen, wir müssen jetzt über das Prompten nachdenken, aber das Programmieren ist dann für die absoluten Spezialisten, die dann irgendwann für KI-Unternehmen arbeiten, aber das ist eigentlich nicht das, was ich lernen muss, sondern ich muss als Wolfgang Emschmidt, der kaum eine E-Mail eigenständig versenden kann, eigentlich nur Prompten lernen.
Genau. Spätestens, wenn das dann in der sehr mächtigen Excel-Software drin ist, wird es jeder spüren als Co-Pilot, wenn Excel mal wirklich macht, was du willst, obwohl du nicht genau weißt, wo, in welchem Untermenü du was klicken und miteinander verschachteln musst. Es ist wahnsinnig mächtig, aber genauso kompliziert. Und jetzt ist es eben wahnsinnig mächtig, aber nicht mehr kompliziert. Also ich habe es jetzt auch schon ausprobiert, mir so einen kleinen RSS-Reader zu machen, weil ich auf meiner Webseite natürlich gerne die letzten zehn Texte, die irgendwo und so einfach so einen RSS-Feed auslesen. Und es ging erstaunlich gut und ich habe verschiedene Podcasts gehört, in denen auch einige, die ihr Geld damit verdienen, Software zu schreiben, so dachten, blöd. Während immer gedacht wurde, naja, die Einzigen, die sicher sind in dieser Welt sind diejenigen, die Computer bedienen, also Software-Ingenieure, werden die gerade am meisten durchgerüttelt, weil natürlich diese ganzen Programmiersprachen, die sich Menschen ausgedachten haben, um mit Computern zu kommunizieren, von Computern am einfachsten gelernt werden können. Also kein Datensatz wurde so, wie soll man sagen, wirkmächtig, handlungsorientiert eingelesen und trainiert, wie diese ganzen Programmiersprachen. Anders als Wikipedia-Wissen oder so. Da muss man immer noch klug nachfragen. Aber für ein Programm, sich das schreiben zu lassen, reichen auch relativ blöde Promts.
Wir erleben im Silicon Valley eine nie dagewesene Entlassungswelle. Die hat mit den wirtschaftlichen Schwierigkeiten zu tun, aber man kann ja davon ausgehen, die werden vermutlich nicht die KI-Teams oder so etwas entlassen, sondern es wird doch wahrscheinlich eher darauf hinauslaufen, dass man jetzt eher sagt, wir müssen jetzt Leute entlassen und wir können auch schlanker werden, um profitabler zu sein. Aber es wird ja vermutlich dann eher so sein, dass neue Stellen dort bei der KI-Fraktion entstehen, während diese Fraktion dann daran arbeitet, dass vielleicht die anderen, die noch da arbeiten, bald auch nicht mehr gebraucht werden.
Wie gesagt, Komplexität verlagert sich gerade sehr. Es ist auch immer, also es macht schon Sinn wahrscheinlich, so meine Erfahrung jetzt, nachdem ich da rumgearbeitet hab, Programmiersprachen so rudimentär zumindest zu verstehen und so weiter. Aber selbst das wird ja im laufenden Prozess, ist ja erst GPT-4 und auch noch nicht GPT-14, in denen sehe ich, ja, du brauchst irgendwann, brauchst du aber im Ausbildungsbetrieb am Ende Superhirne, die noch die Technik dahinter herstellen. Aber auf dem Weg dahin wirst du halt nicht mehr.
Lass uns das doch gerade mal ausdiskutieren mit den klugen Köpfen, die das dann überhaupt bauen können oder die ja auch diese Berechnungen verstehen. Ich habe noch mal drüber nachgedacht, über GPT und habe überlegt, welche Hausaufgaben ich so hatte in meiner gesamten Schulzeit und fragte mich, was hätte da von GPT erledigen können. Und ich bin bis auf das, wo es um so eine eigenkreative Leistung ging, jetzt zum Beispiel im Deutschunterricht oder so, doch darauf gekommen, dass ChatGPT jetzt schon, und ich habe ja vier noch gar nicht genutzt, das ziemlich gut hätte machen können. Auch vermutlich ja Mathematikaufgaben mit Lösungswegen, Alternativen und so etwas.
Für Mathematiker ist ja immer schon ein Taschenrechner.
Na ja, man hat ein Taschenrechner, aber der Lehrer war ja nicht froh mit dem Ergebnis einfach nur, sondern man musste ja auch noch sagen, wie bist du denn da hingekommen oder was hat er geschrieben? Ach so, ja, genau. Und dass diese ganzen Dinge jetzt auch möglich sind, das ist ja so radikal, das bedeutet einfach, dass die meisten Leistungsüberprüfungen, die stattfinden, die im Schulraum stattfinden, gut, da ist dann kein Computer da und dann müssen die Leistungen erbracht werden. Aber alles, was dann nicht in der Prüfungssituation ist, kann ja im Prinzip gerade mal schnell von Jet Shibiki einhergestellt werden. Und das ist ja noch mal so, dass der Mensch von Natur aus faul ist und dass der Mensch auch, wenn er keine große Lust zu etwas hat, versucht einen Weg zu finden, dass er es nicht machen muss. Wie wir uns ja auch die Arbeit erleichtern, wir wissen halt, wie wir relativ schnell Clips schneiden können. Und vor 20 Jahren hätten wir es noch anders gemacht. Und das bedeutet aber doch, dass jetzt eigentlich jeder junge Mensch in der Situation ist, dass er sich fragt, soll ich jetzt wirklich für den Sozialkundeunterricht aufschreiben, wie weit die Rentenpositionen von SPD und CDU sich unterscheiden? Oder soll ich das einfach schätzchen wie Tee erledigen lassen? Und da bin ich doch an einem Punkt angelangt, oder den Aufsatz über das Eichhörnchen in der dritten Klasse, das du eben schon erwähnt hast. Da bin ich doch dann an dem Punkt angelangt, wo man eigentlich eine künstliche Intelligenz hat, die die Leute nicht mehr dazu bringt zu denken. Oder wir haben dann so, wir haben ja jetzt schon diese Digital Natives, also die gar nicht mehr wissen, ohne Smartphone, ohne Facebook, das gab es mal alles. Das kennen wir noch. Wir sind noch ohne Internet Kind gewesen, oder das Internet war da, aber wir hatten es wahrscheinlich dann noch nicht, also ich zumindest nicht. Und jetzt haben wir eine Generation, die dann KI ist. Und diese KI-Generation kann sich eigentlich die ganze Zeit die Frage stellen, soll ich das jetzt selbst machen?
Also oder es gilt genau das Gegenteil von dem, was du suggerierst. Menschen haben Roboter bekommen, die für sich, für sie arbeiten. Was haben sie gemacht? Fitnessstudios gegründet. Plötzlich ist die Ästhetik des Körpers das Wichtigste überhaupt. Wer weiß, vielleicht ist es später die Performance, die erkennbar ohne Künstliche Intelligenz. Oh, ein virtuoser am Klavier. Also der wird noch eine Weile bleiben. Und in dieser Art von Virtuosität, mit der man andere begeistert, die gibt es ja auch beim Schachspiel, beim Sport, überall. Aber da sprechen wir von paar Prozent.
Also da sprechen wir von paar Prozent. Und damit meine ich jetzt nicht nur Genies, aber ganz viele. Also man geht ja zur Schule und da hat man vielleicht in einem Fach so diesen Überschuss, den du da gerade geschildert hast. Das war dann vielleicht bei mir der deutsche Unterricht. Bei anderen wird das ein Matheunterricht sein. Und diese Leute werden natürlich dann in diesem Feld auch weiterhin lesen und tun und machen. Aber wenn ich wüsste, zum Beispiel, was mochte ich nicht, den Bio-Unterricht, hat mich immer wahnsinnig gelangweilt. Das war so schematisch. Da hätte ich da einfach sagen können, Schätzchen mit ihm, mach für mich die Hausaufgaben.
Das ist ein Drogenszenario.
Ich muss es dann natürlich beim Abitur irgendwie können. Das ist das Problem.
Ich würde, also es gibt sehr viel Grund auch für Pessimismus. Allerdings mehr auf dieser politischen, unternehmerischen Seite und so weiter. Also die Daten müssen ja auch aufbereitet werden. Da sitzen gerade sehr viele in Bangladesch irgendwo und klicken sich da den Wolf für 3, 80 Euro im Monat. Das ist so ein riesiges Problem. Also es gibt ganz viele Probleme. Ich finde, man sollte nicht zu schnell verkopfen in Sachen, die man so heute als Gefahr sieht, bei denen man wirklich nicht weiß, wo es hinführt. Denn wir kriegen hier zum Beispiel bei Bill Gates zwei Aussagen. Zum einen.
You know, every example they give of a specific thing it doesn't do, you know, wait a few months and it's very good.
Also wenn jemand kommt und sagt, ja, du wirst noch deine Rolle als Mensch haben, weil die Maschine kann ja das noch nicht, dann sagt er, das ist alles Nonsens. Warte noch ein paar Monate und dann wird es das auch alles können. Also es werden wenige Lücken bleiben. Aber der gleiche Bill Gates sagt eben auch. Es könnte auch dieses Befreiungsszenario sein, von der Arbeit befreit, dass man Berufsgruppen, die Körper betont, also Menschen begegnen sich und so weiter, hat man ja in vielerreich Bereichen, dass da Bildungsbereich, wie hier, GPT reinspringt und sehr viel mehr Komplexität ermöglicht, als es abbaut. Also sehr viel Möglichkeiten schafft, als es dir nimmt. Nur, dass wir es halt neu labeln müssen und sagen, es ist keine Erwerbsarbeit, sondern es ist eigentlich die klügere Arbeit. Warum wollen denn die Leute in Frankreich weniger? Also diese zwei Jahre, warum kämpfen die ja so hart? Wir haben jetzt in Deutschland dieses Fachkräfteeinwanderungsgesetz, das gerade im Bundestag durch den Bundestag ist. Also es mangelt ja eigentlich an Arbeitskräften. Und jetzt ist, also wir fragen uns, wovon sind wir eigentlich bedroht? Dass zu wenige Arbeitskräfte da sind oder dass GPT unsere Arbeit ersetzt? Also diese Diskurse muss man auch erst mal übereinbringen.
Ja, und das würde ich auch, wir stimmen dir da vollkommen zu und da bin ich auch gar niemand, der jetzt sagt, das wird alles, also ich glaube, dass manche Berufsgruppen werden verschwinden, wie auch der Setzer bei der Zeitung nicht mehr existiert, weil man digital prädogen hat.
Da kommen eben neue.
Und da kommen neue. Und ich glaube, dass das auch jetzt hier stattfinden wird. Ich frage mich nur jetzt, was diese menschliche Psychologie anbelangt. Wir haben ja jetzt seit Jahren das Phänomen diskutiert. Diese Smartphones mit ihren Apps machen uns süchtig und sorgen dafür, dass wir zwei Stunden lang 15-Sekunden-Videos gucken. Am Ende wissen wir nicht mehr, wo oben und unten ist, aber es ist schon wieder der halbe Tag rum. Das ist ein Effekt, den wir sehen. Was wird jetzt bei Checheviti ein Effekt sein? Wird das eine Einladung zur Faulheit sein? Denn klar ist es toll, wenn einem Dinge jetzt abgenommen werden. Wenn ich jetzt Checheviti fragen kann, schreibt mir mal bitte alle Baustoffe auf, die ich brauche, um eine Garage zu bauen oder so etwas. Dann ist das eine Erleichterung und ich muss nicht irgendwo wild rumklicken und suchen und machen und tun. Aber wo das jetzt zum Beispiel daran ja geht, und das ist ja gerade in jungen Jahren oder auch im studentischen, ist es ja so, man soll ja lesen Texte zu, man soll lernen, Texte zu lesen und das Wichtige vom Unwichtigen zu trennen. Deswegen schreibt man immer Inhaltsangaben oder macht dann nachher Exzerte. Und das ist ja etwas, was wir beide gemacht haben. Und da würden wir beide wahrscheinlich sagen. Und deswegen können wir relativ leicht heute auf Sachbücher, theoretische Texte eingehen. Wir können die relativ schnell rezipieren und gründlich das Wichtige vom Unwichtigen trennen. Wenn dies nicht mehr als solches erlernt werden muss, dann geht damit ja eine große Kompetenz flöten. Oder ist es so, dass man sagt, nein, jetzt gerade durch Chachbitti, durch diese Dialoge, die ja auch lange Dialoge sind, also sind ja nicht zwei Worte Antworten, die wir bekommen, dass dadurch eigentlich auch wieder eine Auseinandersetzung mit Text in einem ganz anderen Maße stattfindet, als gerade mal drei Zeilen bei dem ersten Google-Ergebnis gelesen. Und dass dadurch auch wiederum etwas freigesetzt wird, nämlich dass man sagt, oh, da bin ich gerade auf was gestoßen, jetzt lese ich das Buch dazu.
Ja, also wir Menschen sortieren nicht irgendwelche Kulturtechniken aus, nur weil es der Computer plötzlich kann. Allen voran Matheunterricht in der Schule. Jeder hasst es, aber alle Eltern finden es super wichtig, dass die Kinder das bitte lernen. So, also diese Gefahr besteht gar nicht. Und wir haben ja in der Schule auch einen geschützten Bereich bei dem wir programmatisch festlegen, dass ist der Lehrplan, unabhängig davon, wie die Welt gerade, in welchem Zustand sie ist. Manchmal ist ja sogar im Sinne von, der Lehrplan ist ja so entkoppelt von der Welt, dass wir es als eigentlich näher dranwischen und so. Also wir haben es da eigentlich mit so einem Safe Space für menschliche Entwicklung zu tun, bei dem man jetzt auf die Veränderung der Welt ja durchaus reagieren kann, ohne dass immer gleich die Angst ist, wir räumen alles ab. Also niemand sagt, oh, cool, keiner muss mehr in die Schule gehen, wir können die Kinder endlich für alles Mögliche benutzen, Arbeit oder so. Also solche Diskurse sind völlig ausgeschlossen. Sondern diese Safe Space für Sozialisation und so weiter bleiben. Und klar, es ist natürlich jetzt, wir hören Sam Altman, also den Chefe des ganzen Ladens, der nun wirklich ein sehr umtriebiger Typ ist, der auch weiß, wie man vor der Öffentlichkeit formuliert. Also er lockt uns natürlich auch ein bisschen, indem wir einfach Folgendes sagen.
Genau.
Ich denke, das ist nur das, was die Menschheit vorwärtsführt.
So, da ist er bei Kerstin Wischer im Podcast. Die will natürlich immer die positive Seite. Und sagt so, ja, wir werden ganz tollen wissenschaftlichen Fortschritt und diese Art von Fortschritt, und das wird ja noch eine Weile so bleiben, braucht dann auch den Mensch als Resonanzgeber. Also die Maschine hat ja what technology wants, ja, wissen wir nicht, gar nichts vielleicht. Also wir hören ja noch andere Sachen, aber erstmal können wir sagen technisch, also was Fortschritt bedeutet, das legen immer noch wir fest. Es ist unsere Rationalität, es macht entweder uns das Leben einfacher oder interessanter oder wie auch immer. Also diese Fortschrittskriterien, die legen wir fest. Also sind wir in Kommunikation mit der Maschine und sie unterstützt uns dabei. Also da bei Fortschrittsgedanken ist die Maschine ganz klar, egal wie klug sie ist, auch wenn sie uns in allem überflügelt, unser Assistent weiterhin. So wie sie auch beim Schachspielen unser Spaßgeber ist. Wir sagen einfach, spielen wir jetzt nicht ganz so klug, damit wir Spaß haben. Und dann machen wir es halt trotzdem so. Und auf dem Weg zum Fortschritt braucht man natürlich kluge Leute. Also sagt er dann bei den ABC News, ja das wird ganz toll für den Bildungsbereich.
The promise of this technology, one of the ones that I'm most excited about, is the ability to provide individual learning, great individual learning for each student. You're already seeing students using ChatGPT for this in a very primitive way to great success. And as companies take our technology and create dedicated platforms for this kind of learning, I think it will revolutionize education and I think that kids that are starting the education process today, by the time they graduate from high school are going to be smarter and more capable than we can imagine.
Mal sehen, es ist auf jeden Fall so, dass dem Bildungsbereich, der klebte ja bisher so sehr am Dialog an den Menschen. Also man brauchte den anderen Menschen um sozusagen Resonanz und Widerstände. Ob man das mit einer Maschine reproduzieren kann, wir haben auf jeden Fall schon mal eine für den Dialog offene Maschine, die wir entsprechend reizen und in Stimmung bringen können und so. Also die so ein bisschen resonant auch mit, die sich einstellt sozusagen auf einen Gesprächspartner.
Aber man wird ja nicht sanktioniert. Von der Lehrperson wird man ja mitunter gemass regelt, wenn man nicht zuhört.
Also du wirst aber auch nur während einer Prüfungssituation, oder es wird halt in eine Prüfungssituation verwandelt, im Sinne von ich drohe dir jetzt eine schlechte Note bei der mündlichen Mitarbeit an, wenn du so viel... Genau. Das kann man ja entkoppeln. Also die Prüfungssituation unter menschlicher Beobachtung, also dass man einem Prüfer ausgesetzt ist, heißt ja noch, sagt ja nicht darüber, wie man für diese Prüfung lernt.
Das gewiss nicht, aber wenn wir jetzt über den Schulunterricht sprechen, dann kommen wir ja nicht ohne die Lehrpersonen aus. Doch.
Also hier drüben, wir sitzen ja hier in Sichtweite einer sehr großen Schule, 1.400 Kinder, meine große Tochter zum Beispiel. Und da ist natürlich der Frontalunterricht abgeräumt. Also das ist selbstgesteuertes Lernen. Die sitzen am Tisch und haben bis jetzt Materialsammlung auf Papier. Die gehen dann zum Regal, holen sich das raus und arbeiten selbstständig durch. Und nur wenn sie Fragen haben, gehen sie noch zum Lehrer. Der Lehrer sitzt dann vorne und fragt, was machst du gerade? Ah, der hat Deutsch. Okay, dann versuche ich es mal dir zu helfen. Weil der Lehrer nicht mal weiß, was sie eigentlich gerade für innerlich zum Fachunterricht haben.
Aber das ist eine Aufgabenbetreuung dann, aber nicht für normalen Unterricht.
Nein, das ist grundsätzlich. Also Segeln, selbstgesteuertes Lernen findet jeden Tag statt und ist auch das prägende Prinzip nicht nur dieser Schule. Also da muss man sich den Bildungsbereich, wie er heute schon ist, noch mal sehr genau angucken.
Ja, ich war und bin ein Verfechter des Frontalunterrichts. Und ich kann sagen, bei allen Lehrern, bei denen ich das meiste gelernt habe, das waren knallharte Verfechter des Frontalunterrichts. Ich kenne sogar drei Lehrpersonen, da hat es nicht ein einziges Mal in der ganzen Schulaufbahn Gruppenarbeit gegeben. Nicht ein einziges Mal.
Also der Bildungsbereich ist schon auf 1 zu 1-Dialog umgestellt. Du musst dir nämlich beim Segeln überlegen, arbeite ich an den Aufgaben alleine mit einer anderen Person oder einer Gruppe. Dass man dann auch noch den Lehrer fragt, steht neben diesen drei Optionen. An der Uni wird das ja auch, da ich das dann nicht gemerkt, an Unis wird das gemacht. Ich natürlich nicht. Ich habe ja auch ein paar Jahre da noch unterrichtet, als ich glaubte, den Doktor zu machen. Da habe ich auch nur Frontalunterricht gemacht. Was anderes gab es nicht bei mir. Und ich kann sagen, das waren überlaufende Seminare.
Also du, ja, also bleiben wir mal bei der Schule. Die Schule ist umgestellt auf Lernen abseits des Lehrermonologs. Und damit ist die Einflugsschneise da schon da. Altman betont das hier im Gespräch mit Lex Friedman. Ja, also die Dialogfähigkeit, die du ja auch als erstes vorhin betont hast, ist in der Bildung das Allerwichtigste. Das ist das, was noch gefehlt hat, dass die Materialsammlung mit dir spricht, und zwar inspirativ und informativ. Also dass da wirklich Feedback kommt und nicht einfach nur, ah, du hast das Substantiv, ja dann such mal selber aus. Ich schmeiß noch vieles weg, was du auf gar keinen Fall brauchst, aber der Rest ist dann immer noch da. Also dieses Novum ist hier schon da. Und jetzt hören wir uns noch so ein bisschen die, naja, die sind halt wirklich ein Gotteswerk in ihrer Selbstbeschreibung. Hier zum Beispiel in ABC News.
This will be the greatest technology humanity has yet developed. We can all have an incredible educator in our pocket that's customized for us, that helps us learn, that helps us do what we want. We can have creative tools that help us figure out the new problems we're going to solve, wonderful new things to co-create with this technology for humanity. As you point out, there's a huge potential downside.
Jetzt sind wir es plötzlich, die uns updaten müssen.
Aber diese Rede haben die ja alle im Silicon Valley drauf. Ob die jetzt eine Dating-App entwerfen oder ein neues Facebook, es ist immer die Welt revolutionierend. Und gut, jetzt kann man sagen, das geht hier auch einige Schritte weiter als irgendeine App. Aber ich finde es erstaunlich, dass das immer gleich so holistisch aufgeladen wird. Also was die Investoren freuen wird. Also wir haben ja diese Tech-Krise, da sind wir noch nicht draußen. Und jetzt kommt KI und alles stürzen sich schon.
Ja, die Tech-Krise ist aber nicht flächendeckend, sondern die ist natürlich, also das Silicon Valley ist, was Marktkapitalisierung und Mitarbeiter angeht, immer noch größer als vor Corona jetzt. Die haben durch Corona sehr viel mehr Wachstum auf einigen.
Ja, aber es muss ja immer noch mal nach oben gehen. Und ich glaube schon, dass man jetzt mit KI so eine neue Erfolgserzählung hat. Also das ist auch der Man on the Moon jetzt, wie Ursula von der Leyen sagen würde. Und da bin ich natürlich immer so ein bisschen skeptisch, inwieweit das Investoren-Gerede da nicht...
Hör dir mal an, was er hier sagt.
I mean what I'm excited for is like, please explain to me how all the physics works and solve all remaining mysteries.
Er möchte die Theorie von allem, die Weltformel möchte er endlich haben.
Aber das gibt es doch schon in 100 Sachbüchern, die Theorie von fast allem, so Bücher gibt es doch schon. Er wird ja hochintelligent sein auf seinem Fach, aber dass er dann so schlicht auch denkt, ist er auch wieder bezeichnend.
Ich finde es doch amüsant irgendwie. Das ist auf jeden Fall eine bessere Erklärung. Also bei Facebook kannst du alle Leute, die auf deiner Wellenlänge sind, treffen und dich mit denen vernetzen. Und dann könnt ihr gemeinsam die Welt revolutionieren.
Gut, das ist ein bisschen sehr doof.
Aber hier mit der Maschine, es ist das Tolle, jeder kann ja das selbe ausprobieren. Du kannst einfach einen Account machen und es testen.
Und dann gucken, wie weit du kommst.
So, beim Thema Rechtsfragen. Der Greg Brockman ist bei Festival da auf der Bühne. Und ihm rutscht auch noch mal so eine Metapher raus. Wo sieht er sich hier gerade?
Ich meine, ehrlich gesagt, das ist, denke ich, eine wichtige Frage. Ich denke, das ist, wie ein Frage zu stellen, wie das Copyright bei der Kreation der Gutenberg-Presse funktioniert. Wo wir die Antwort brauchen, wir sind mit dem Copyright-Kommentar engagiert, wir sind mit vielen anderen Bereichen engagiert. Ich weiß nicht persönlich, was genau die Antwort sein sollte, aber ich denke, dass, eine Sache, die ich sagen möchte, nicht alles hier zu heben, sondern ich denke, dass die Content-Kreatoren ein mehr bestätigter, kompensierter, besserer Sache für die Menschen, die sie jetzt als immer suchen.
Das Trainingsmaterial für die Maschine ist alles digitalisierte Datenzeug auf der Welt.
Wie ist das eigentlich mit?
Jetzt stellen sich Rechtsfragen und er sagt ja, da sind die Rechtsfragen wie vor 500 Jahren, als die Gutenberg Presse kamen. Also wo man schon sieht, welche historische Zäsur er hier für sich reklamiert. Also das wird das ganz große Rad jetzt nochmal anders gedreht.
Wie ist es damit Kommunikation, die bei WhatsApp stattfindet? Also eigentlich kann die ja nicht eingeschweißt werden.
Aber alles, was per Webcrawler erreichbar ist.
Für Facebook könnte es ja interessant sein.
Die Kommunikation, die sonst niemand hat. Die Frage ist halt, ob sich Facebook nicht auch schon zu sehr den Riegel vorgeschoben hat, das jetzt einfach so zu verwenden. Oder ob die das nochmal rustisch neu bauen müssen. Denn die haben ja die Messenger-Kommunikation auch erstmal verschlüsselt und kommen da nicht so einfach ran. Und so ist es ja auch bei Apple, die One-Message-Kommunikation, alles verschlüsselt. Also in der Hinsicht, es gibt schon so ein paar, aber die Frage ist, findest du nicht genug Dialoge auch so? Du hast ja offene Kommunikation, irgendwelche Foren, auf Facebook wird viel auf den Pin-Wänden geschrieben usw. Also so sehr muss man gar nicht ins Skitchatte hinein. Du hast ja auch eine unterschiedliche Qualität, was die wollen. Die wollen ja auch nicht. Oder mit gleicher Gewichtung irgendwelche Emoji-Paraden, die abgefeuert werden im privaten Chat usw. Bill Gates versucht es ein bisschen kleiner, also nicht bis zur Gutenbergpresse, aber zumindest überspannt er noch mal den ganzen Bogen der Computer Technology.
Ja, also, AI ist immer die Heilige Gräuze der Computerwissenschaft.
Ja, also Künstliche Intelligenz, der heilige Gral der Computertechnologie und jetzt nach 100 Jahren der Technik und 30, 40, 50 Jahre, in denen wir es als Consumer Electronics, jeder hat es zu Hause und so weiter, bis in die Hosentasche, kommt das jetzt nachgebaut. Das ist auch hier große Zäsur. Und Altman beschreibt jetzt noch mal seine Zäsur. Und ich habe es mal, weil die Alena Büxter so als stochastischer Papagei, das ist genau das, was er nicht so gern hört über seine Technik.
Weißt du, eine lustige Sache, wie wir diese Modelle trainieren, ist, dass ich zu viel von der Prozessiv-Fähigkeit, für Lack von einem besseren Wort, als eine Modelle als Database, als einen Rezensionen-Engine, in die Modelle gehen. Das Wichtigste an diesem System ist, dass es für eine Definition von Rezension, und wir könnten natürlich etwas darüber quibbeln, und es gibt viele Definitionen, die nicht akkurativ sind, aber für eine Definition kann es eine Art Rezension machen. Vielleicht werden die Schülern, die Experten, die Armchair-Quarterbacken auf Twitter sagen, nein, das kann nicht, du verwendest die Worte, oder was auch immer, aber ich denke, dass die meisten Menschen, die das System benutzen, sagen, okay, es geht in diese Richtung. In einigen Sätzen wird das zu der menschlichen Wissenheit hinzu. Und in anderen Sätzen kann man GPT-4 für alle Dinge benutzen und sagen, es gibt hier keine Wissenheit.
Es kommt wirklich sehr darauf an, wie man es benutzt. Wenn man einfach nur eine Wissensfrage stellt, wie man es gewohnt ist im Google-Zeitalter, kriegt man halt einfach nur so Papageien-mäßig, du hast mir das genannt, also spiegele ich es dir einmal zurück, aber sortier halt ein bisschen. Aber ich denke auch, man sollte hier die Diammer-Hatze auch, wie viele Worte kann man reinschreiben, wie viele Worte gibt es aus, dass man wirklich ganze Texte reinschmeißt und sagt, gib mir mal den roten Faden hinsichtlich und so weiter und das dann verfeinert und so. Also dass man wirklich so eine Leseleistung abverlangt, eine Lese- und Verständnisleistung. Da kann man ja immer noch nachgehen und überprüfen.
Jaja, du sagst es gerade jetzt, aber wird man dem nachgehend überprüfen? Also werden wir zu einer Gesellschaft werden, die noch bereit ist, diese Antworten zu lesen. Und die sind ja immerhin länger als Tweets. Das ist ja schon mal ein kleiner Fortschritt, was das anbelangt. Aber wir sind nicht mehr diejenigen, die sagen, hier liegt ein Buch von 300 Seiten, ich lese es. Und das ist ja schon dann ein immenser Kulturwandel, wenn man sich diese Mühe nicht mehr macht. Also wir wissen, dass die App...
Aber warum sollte man nicht? Nur weil die Maschine auch lesen kann?
Naja, das wäre dann die Frage, inwieweit wir noch uns die Mühe machen für viele Texte, beziehungsweise wir vertrauen der Maschine. Also klar, wir machen das ja laufend. Also wenn wir eine Rezension lesen, dann entscheiden wir manchmal auch, daraufhin ein Buch zu kaufen oder nicht. Und wenn wir es nicht tun, wenn wir sagen, ich brauche es nicht zu lesen, die Rezension sagt es mir, dann kommt man ja schon dahin, dass man also sagt, ich überprüfe das nicht selbst. Das müssen wir auch tun, weil sonst würden wir ja bei 80.000 Neuerscheinungen im Jahr, würden wir das ja gar nicht aushalten. Aber die Frage ist, werden wir noch, wenn es für uns gelesen werden kann, noch bereit sein, es selbst zu lesen? Und ich rede jetzt hier nicht von schöngeistiger Literatur. Also ich kann natürlich auch den Wikipedia-Eintrag zu einem Christopher Nolan-Film lesen, aber dann habe ich den ja nicht gesehen. Und genauso würde ich auch sagen, bei Literatur, die schöngeistig ist. Aber ganz viele Texte, in die wir uns hineinarbeiten, wo wir dann vielleicht aber auch Dinge entdecken, die wir gar nicht erwartet haben oder so, das fällt ja dann weg. Also die Frage ist, ob nicht unser Blick zum einen sehr geweitet wird, zum anderen aber dadurch, dass wir selbst nicht mehr in der Lage sind oder nicht mehr in der Lage schon, aber nicht mehr willens sind, diese Leistung selbst zu erbringen, dass wir dadurch auch faul und...
Also es macht auf jeden Fall keinen Sinn, also er hat natürlich Einfluss auf das Schreiben. Es hat keinen Sinn mehr zu wissen, okay ich muss jetzt 40, also dieser Modus, meine Masterarbeit muss 40 Seiten lang sein, ich habe schon 30, ich brauche noch 10. Diese Überlegung, ich brauche noch 10, die gehört schon lange aussortiert. Dankbarerweise haben wir jetzt eine Technologie, die uns sagt, generiere die 10 oder lass sie einfach weg. Wenn du den Punkt, den du machen wolltest, geschrieben hast, ist er gemacht. Wenn das dann nicht ausreicht als Prüfungsleistung, anderes Problem und so auf diesem Gebiet. Aber es ist doch nun ehrlicherweise so, relativ viele Sachbücher. Ich erinnere an Bob Woodward, der drei Bücher über Trump geschrieben hat. Wir haben eins davon gelesen. Er ging damit an den Marketing mäßig an die Öffentlichkeit. Trump hat mir das und das gesagt. Da haben wir das Buch aufgeschlagen, 100 Seiten erstmal irgendwas. Totaler Nonsens. Irgendeine außenpolitische Sache, die schon zig andere Autoren und in allen Zeitungen. Wenn du ein Buch verkaufen willst mit einer tollen und so weiter, und du kannst aber nur fünf Seiten dazu schreiben, dann brauchen wir jetzt einen neuen kulturellen Modus dafür. Verkaufen wir nicht 100 Seiten Papier mit Nonsens, nur um dann nochmal 5 Millionen zu verdienen, weil du allen weiß machst. Das ist so dieses Clickbait-Dingartige. Da denke ich mir irgendwie, vielleicht hat das wirklich einen positiven Einfluss auf die Bücher, dass man sich so denkt, wenn Chachy PT auch schreiben könnte, dann belasse ich es doch dabei, was Chachy PT nicht schreibt. Und dann belasse ich es aber auch bei diesen Gedanken und nerv nicht alle noch mit zusätzlichem Text. Also da sehe ich schon so eine gewisse Straffung. Du weißt, ich bin nicht so ein ganz großer Verfechter des Kulturwerks Buch. Also für mich muss das nicht gedruckt und so weiter. Für mich reichen da auch wirklich Exzepte, rote Linien. Für mich darf auch der Autor selbst nochmal in einem Fazit einfach schreiben, was ihm am wichtigsten war im Buch, um mir so einen Prompt fürs Lesen mitzuliefern, worauf ich zu achten habe und was vielleicht da wirklich nur so dekoratives Beiwerk ist und so. Also ich sehe das da gar nicht so kulturpessimistisch, sondern denke mir irgendwie, ja, das wird so eine gewisse Konzentration auf den menschlichen Beitrag in der Kommunikation schärfen.
Jedenfalls wird das auch in der Rezeption so sein, dass man ja sich die Frage stellt, ist es von Chet Chippity geschrieben oder entdecke ich da einen Autor? Das heißt, Stil wird entscheidend sein und Originalität, die Chet Chippity dann möglicherweise nicht erreichen kann.
Also ich hab gar nichts dagegen, wenn mir Bücher untergejubelt werden, die mit Chet Chippity inspirativ oder wie auch immer informativ angereichert wurden, solange mein Lesererlebnis eben auf einem gewissen Niveau ist. Weil ansonsten und das hat man schon immer so gemacht, legt man so ein Buch einfach weg. Ein Buch nicht zu Ende zu lesen, ist schon lange kein Frevel mehr. Und Buchklappen durchzugehen und sich wirklich nur den Teaser des Verlags durchzulesen, dann zu entscheiden, ob ich das jetzt in Gänze lese oder nicht, ist auch nicht neu. Sondern wir arbeiten schon immer mit dieser Art, der etwas, naja, so Sachen, die halt so Beschleunigung reinbringen.
Und lesen wir nicht ein Buch auch, weil wir wissen, da hat sich jemand Mühe gemacht oder wir setzen das einmal voraus. Dass man sagt, gut, aber plötzlich hingesetzt, ein halbes Jahr, 400 Seiten geschrieben. Und dann setze ich mich jetzt auch zwei Nachmittage hin dafür. Und wenn ich aber weiß, das hat Chachipiti generiert, oder zum großen Teil generiert, dann ist erst mal das, kann ich es mir selber generieren lassen, aber vielleicht auch die Frage, soll ich mich jetzt irgendwie für was Chachipiti gemacht hat, hat jetzt nicht mal ein Mensch sein Herz gut drangegeben. Und dann ist es so, dass man es dann gar nicht macht. Also klar, man kann immer sagen, was geschieht mit der freien Zeit. Und natürlich kann man die Zeit bei TikTok dann verbringen. Oder man kann Literatur lesen, die Chachipiti nicht produzieren kann. Das ist alles möglich. Nur sehe ich schon einen großen kulturellen Wandel da. Nochmal, ich war gestern in Manta Manta 2 und habe da Jokes erlebt. Da würde ich sagen, die kann Chachipiti definitiv besser schreiben.
Das wird auch eine große Herausforderung.
Ich bin da auch bei einer sehr niedrigen Rechenleistung angekommen, wenn ich über die deutsche Komödie spreche.
Da war ja immer ein Scheitern, dass das Publikum das bezahlt und sehen will.
Ja, aber das ist ganz erstaunlich.
Wenn es eine Flut an dieser Art Niveau-Film gibt, schön und gut.
Hier würde ich sagen, dass Niveau ja durch Chachipiti verbessert werden. Wenn ich jetzt gesagt hätte, Chachipiti, wir machen noch mal Manta Manta, jetzt einen zweiten Teil, den ersten kannst du dir angucken. Es gibt etwa 500 Manta-Witze. Und jetzt machen wir was originelles, Neues dazu. Und das soll noch einen Bezug zu 2023 haben. Glaube ich, wäre Chachipiti auf bessere Ideen gekommen als Til Schweiger.
Gut, Til Schweiger. Kommen wir mal zu den interessanten Sachen, die hier auf der Bühne abgefeuert wurden. Zum Thema Entwicklung, Technologie und Idee. Also sie arbeiten schon eine Weile dran. Der Ilja Sutskever, der bei OpenAI die ganze technische Entwicklung verantwortet war, bei Scale AI, noch bevor jetzt GPT-4 kam und hat schon mal drüber gesprochen. Sein Start in die ganze Technik war ziemlich früh. 2003, 20 Jahre. Die Ideen waren immer da, man hatte nur die Computerpower nicht gehabt. Die kamen dann aber relativ zügig, weshalb der Brockman hier 2015 schon als Jahr ausmacht, indem sie zum einen OpenAI gegründet haben, aber schon Angst hatten.
Und die Frage war, ob es zu spät ist, um ein Lab mit einigen der besten Menschen anzulocken.
So, sind wir zu spät dran? Und das ist ja diese super interessante Frage, die dahinter steckt. Können wir unsere gute Ideen nutzen, obwohl wir wissen, es fehlt ja nur in Rechenkraft, aber jetzt ist sie da oder geben wir uns jetzt schon Google und Facebook und so weiter geschlagen, weil wir wissen, die haben ja die Rechenkraft sogar schon in-house. Die müssen das nicht erst mobilisieren. Aber haben die auch die gute konzeptionelle Idee, so wie wir? Dann haben die alles auf die Karte gesetzt. Ne, wir haben die bessere Idee und die Rechenpower steht ja als jedem zur Verfügung. Also haben sie sich da eingemietet und das sich alles bei Amazon wahrscheinlich und so zusammengeklickt, was sie da brauchten. Also da findet man ja unendlich viel. So, damit sind es die neuen Paradigmen in der Welt. Bill Gates beschreibt uns das mal. Künstliche Intelligenz gilt ja so als Begriff, ist ja nun nicht neu, ist ja alles relativ alt, aber es sind eben trotzdem diese kleinen Wandel.
So we had that gigantic acceleration with machine learning, particularly in sensory things, recognizing speech, recognizing pictures. But we were still missing anything that had to do with complex logic, with being able to say read a text and do what a human does, which is quote understand what's in that text.
Also Künstliche Intelligenz war bisher immer dieses Selbstlernen Muster. Siri erkennt plötzlich Sprache. Es heißt dann irgendwie, ja, dein Android-Telefon analysiert dein Gang, also wie du dich bewegst und lauter solche Sachen. Also immer dieser Input von Mensch in die Maschine hinein, wurde in verschiedenen Signalprozessierungswege über den Bewegungssensor, das Mikrofon, die Kamera und so weiter. War schon relativ weit, aber der Computer hat ja nie was zurückgegeben. Zum Sinne von, naja, jetzt denke ich aber auch, bringe ich mal logic rein und koppelte es dann zurück. Das ist dieses Novum. Altman beschreibt es hier auch nochmal. Also wir haben nicht nur Mustererkennung, sondern dann auch Mustervervollständigung. Man gibt so eine Richtung vor und das Muster wird dann generiert. Und dann wird es eben selbst vervollständigt. Indem einfach gerechnet wird und wir dann sozusagen.
Und das hat ja eine assoziative Kraft dann. Und bedeutet aber auch, dass deshalb so viele falsche Sachen auch da zu finden sind, weil GPT immer wieder irgendwas erfindet. Also das Muster dann vervollständigt.
Ja, es ist ein bisschen wie im Bundestag. Du kannst in den Bundestag gewählt werden mit 90 Prozent der Erststimmen oder mit 27 Prozent. Solange nichts anderes wahrscheinlicher ist, nämlich dass jemand anders mit dann 28 Prozent gewählt wird, gelten auch die 27 Prozent als die beste Ausbeute. Damit wird das ausgegeben. Damit sitzen da Nieten im Bundestag, die eigentlich keinen Rückhalt haben. Und du hast halt Ersatzvorvollständigungen, die eigentlich sogar keinen Sinn machen. Das ist ja dann auch der große Unterschied. Bei Programmiersprachen und so weiter ist sehr wahrscheinlich, dass die die Antwort wirklich Sinn macht, die es gibt. In irgendwelche kulturellen Fragen, der rote Faden von zwei Texten oder was weiß ich. Was bedeutet Ideologie bei Luhmann und bei T-Jack? Dann kann er dir halt irgendwas geben. Aber es ist dann so mehr in diesem, wir haben keine bessere Antwort, also geben wir mal das aus. Bis hin zu der Satz bricht dann einfach ab und schließt nicht mal mit einem Punkt ab oder sowas. Also sowas passiert ja dann auch. Die Grundidee, das finde ich jedenfalls bei dem Sutskever. Da muss man sich jetzt wirklich drauf einlassen. Also man kann das alles kritisieren und so weiter. Man muss sich so ein bisschen drauf einlassen. Die haben natürlich jetzt die Trümpfe auf ihrer Seite, weil sie einfach mit Praxis beweisen, dass ihre Konzeption nicht völlig falsch ist. Aber es einfach nur so theoretisch zu hören, das ist so ein bisschen wie bei Oppenheimer. Da hilft uns die Theorie nicht weiter, das dann auch wirklich sozusagen fruchtbar zu machen.
Das ist ein bisschen wie die Sprache, die wir jetzt hier in der Sprache sehen.
Das ist ein bisschen wie die Sprache, die wir jetzt hier in der Sprache sehen. Das ist ein bisschen wie die Sprache, die wir jetzt hier in der Sprache sehen. Das ist ein bisschen wie die Sprache, die wir jetzt hier in der Sprache sehen. Das ist ein bisschen wie die Sprache, die wir jetzt hier in der Sprache sehen. Das ist ein bisschen wie die Sprache, die wir jetzt hier in der Sprache sehen. Das ist ein bisschen wie die Sprache, die wir jetzt hier in der Sprache sehen. Das ist ein bisschen wie die Sprache, die wir jetzt hier in der Sprache sehen. Das ist ein bisschen wie die Sprache, die wir jetzt hier in der Sprache sehen. Und denkt sich dann so, ja, keine Ahnung, wir haben uns hier sehr drauf eingelassen, wir hatten auch gar kein Thema, wir kennen uns auch gar nicht und so weiter. Das hat doch irgendwie Sinn gemacht. So ist das hier auch. Also die Maschine macht halt einfach irgendwas. Gibt dir irgendwas sehr Wahrscheinliches zurück. Und in der Kommunikation, also nicht in der Maschine oder in dir, sondern in der Kommunikation selbst entsteht dann dieser rote Faden. Das macht dann irgendwie Sinn. Den kann man dann aufgreifen, inspirativ aufgreifen, informativ aufgreifen, also sich drauf verlassen. Oder einfach sagen, ach so, ja, dann geh ich jetzt mal in die Richtung weiter und so. Also da steckt auch so ein Kränkungspotenzial für uns Menschen drin. Dass wir GPT für blöd halten, uns auch erklären können, warum GPT irgendwie blöd ist. Der versteht das ja gar nicht, der rechnet ja nur Wahrscheinlichkeiten aus. Damit aber auch eine Aussage über uns treffen. Sondern, dass wir uns zu sehr verheerlicht haben. Dass wir immer noch so eine, ja, aber zwischen den Zeilen und so weiter. Eigentlich bin ich ja viel klüger als das, was ich sage. So, aber vielleicht doch nicht. Und selbst wenn, macht es einen Unterschied, wenn du es nicht sagst, ist es dann halt nicht in der Welt. In der Welt ist nur die Kommunikation. Also, das ist sehr herausfordernd und wird uns auch noch ein bisschen beschäftigen, würde ich sagen.
Man kann, habe ich übrigens von einem Hörer gezeigt bekommen in Berlin, den ich traf, diese Schranke umgehen, das Chachibi-T beleidigt. Also eigentlich ist ja Beleidigung oder so, macht das nicht. Oder ich kann nicht irgendwelche Namen eingeben von Personen. Und dann gibt es aber so ein Jailbreak, über Reddit führte der mir das vor. Dann auf seinem Smartphone und da hat er dann eingegeben, was dann das Programm von mir halte. Dann wurde ich böse als nichtige Person und so bezeichnet.
Du kannst GPT immer in so einen Traumzustand versetzen, indem es jetzt dann selber um Handlungsmöglichkeiten quasi beraubt wird. Und man sagt, du bist Schauspieler, wie würdest du das denn spielen? Du musst dich so ein Kessel ein bisschen in so eine Idee und dann diese Antwort bleibt dann in diesem Rahmen. Und dann ist aber was möglich, was vorher nicht möglich ist, weil es ist ja nur auf einer Bühne, es ist ja nur eine Idee usw. Also ja, da gibt es so verschiedene, dass man das so Jailbreak nennt, finde ich irgendwie witzig, weil im Grunde bricht das ja aus seiner Sozialisation aus. Also man hat dieses Space Model und trainiert das dann, Menschen sagen, was okay ist und was nicht, bevor es auf die Nutzer zugelassen wird. Und wenn man vom Jailbreak spricht, sagt man ja, man hat das Space Model vorher in so ein Gefängnis getan. Und das finde ich irgendwie amüsant, weil das ist ja auch die Idee, die wir mit Schule, für Kinder, also das Space Model kann erstmal alles, es ist Plastik, wir können es dann formen, wie wir wollen. Also bringen wir es erstmal, wir sagen, in die Schule und nicht ins Gefängnis.
Foucault würde sagen, Disziplinargesellschaft, die Schule ist eine Disziplinaranstalt. Althusser würde sagen, es ist ein ideologischer Staatsapparat. Also da sind wir schon sehr nah dran.
Eben, also das steht jetzt alles mal zur Debatte sozusagen. Solche Sachen. Gut, die ersten Gehversuche, die auch das Modell, dass diese GPT-Modelle wirklich unterschieden haben von einfach nur Suchindexen, hat man relativ früh anhand von Amazon-Rezensionen gemacht.
Wir haben ein Werk gemacht, bevor die GPTs, bevor die Transformers entstanden wurden. Und mit etwas, das wir den Sentiment Neuron nennen, das ist eine Neural-Net, die versucht hat, das nächste Wort, sorry, das nächste Charakter in Reviews von Amazon-Produkten zu prädigieren. Und es war eine kleine Neural-Net, weil es vielleicht vier Jahre lang war. Und dann mit den GPTs haben wir es weiter gemacht.
So, die semantischen Ereignisse, also die semantischen Eigenschaften.
Leuchtet mir sofort ein, das mit Amazon Rezensionen zu machen. Zunächst mal sind sie zur Verfügung, aber Rezensionen sagen ja immer wahnsinnig viel, nicht nur über das Werk aus, das rezensiert wird oder das Produkt, sondern über denjenigen, der sie schreibt. Und da sind es ja gerade die Formulierungen, also ist ja auch gerade diese stark menschliche Komponente, die Empörung oder das Lob, was auch immer, das wahnsinnig viel offenbart. Also man kann natürlich wissenschaftliche Paper einscannen und so, aber dann kommt man, was diese Kommunikation anbelangt, die ja auch wichtig ist für GPT, nicht weiter. Und da ist die Rezension, die ja oft das ist, was man am liebsten seinem Freund erzählt hätte. Ich hab da was gekauft, ich kann dir sagen, also das ist einfach die letzte Mist. Das ist etwas, was eigentlich wunderbar auszuwerten ist.
Ja und das Tolle ist, du hast halt immer eine semantische Eigenschaft auf eine spezifische Fragestellung. Finden die Rezensionen das Produkt gut oder schlecht? Ist immer die gleiche Unterscheidung. Und dadurch kann man hier eine Schlüsselidee testen, bei der man, wenn man danach sieht, ah, funktioniert, sind es nur noch Skalierungsprobleme. Man kann dann die Unterscheidungen austauschen oder Unterscheidungen miteinander abwägen, dass überhaupt erst mal geht es um gut schlecht oder geht es um schön hässlich oder was auch immer. Das ist sozusagen so ein Startpunkt. Und das hat Brockman damals auch sehr fasziniert.
Wir hatten ein Modell, das auf Amazon-Reviews getraut wurde. Welches Letter kommt als nächstes? Und es hat tatsächlich einen state of the art sentiment analysis classifier gelernt. Du kannst ihm eine Sentenz geben, und er würde sagen, das ist positiv oder negativ.
Ich stell mir vor, die haben die Rezension genommen und haben das als Trainingsmaterial benutzt und haben dieses Amazon-Rezensionsmodell gefragt, diese eine Rezension, die wir dir jetzt geben, wie viele Sterne hat der Autor gegeben? 1 bis 5? Dass man dann relativ einfach, dass das einfach diesen Bogen schlagt zwischen, wenn die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die Buchstabenfolge so und so ist, dann rechne ich mal aus, dann sind das 4 Sterne gewesen. Oder 2 Sterne. Es ist nicht 1 Stern, es ist schon schlecht, aber nicht 1 Stern, sondern so 2 Sterne und so. Also dass sie da relativ früh, kann ich mir auch richtig vorstellen, wie sie davor standen und so dachten, ok, jetzt haben wir hier so ein bisschen magic in der Maschine gefunden, dass wir da solche Rückschlüsse ziehen können. Naja, es gibt hier noch eine schöne Analogie, finde ich, wie man so ein KI-Modell versteht, wie wir es verstehen, wie es versteht.
Wenn du ein Studium auf der Universität hast, das für einen Examen studiert, dann kann das Student sagen, dass das ein sehr wichtiger Examen für mich ist. Lass mich auf jeden Fall beachten, dass ich jedes Übungsprozess im Textbuch lösen kann. So ein Studium wird sehr gut vorbereitet und kann eine sehr hohe Gräte im Examen erreichen. Nun, schau mal einen anderen Studium an, der sagen würde, dass er nicht mehr weiß, wie man das Übungsprozess im Textbuch lösen kann, so lange ich die Grundlagen richtig habe. Ich habe die ersten 20 Pages gelesen und ich glaube, ich habe die Grundlagen. Wenn der zweite Studierende auch eine hohe Gräte im Examen erreicht, dann ist der zweite Studierende etwas schwieriger als der erste. Der zweite Studierende hat eine größere Gräte im Generellisieren gezeigt. Auch wenn die Fragen die gleichen sind, war die Situation weniger bekannt für den zweiten und den ersten Studierenden.
Also man hat diese Modelle, man weiß ja ungefähr welche Worte was aussagen und so in Amazon-Rezensionen. Und das wird dann alles codiert für den Computer. Also man hat diese einzelnen Tokens, davon sprechen die ja immer. Und dann hast du eben dieses Phänomen, wenn alle Amazon-Rezensionen einmal verstanden sind und man dann vielleicht auch noch immer, wenn die Maschine richtig lag, das waren wirklich zwei Sterne, das waren vier Sterne usw. wenn man die immer markiert, sodass die Maschine so, ah hier lag ich besonders richtig, warum auch immer, ich bleib mal diesem Muster treu, dass man dann aus dieser Situation kommt, wie fünf Jahre später GPT 4 kommt und kriegt eben Prüfungsaufgaben, die es noch nicht kennt und kann aber anhand der alten Trainingsdaten trotzdem diese Prüfung lösen. Sie muss also nicht, wie bei einer Google-Suche, schon das mitindiziert haben, also auswendig lernen, wie hier es ja diesem Schüler unterstellt. Der eine Schüler lernt einfach alles auswendig und ruft dann einfach ab, sondern man braucht nicht diesen ganzen Google-Index, sondern man nimmt nur diesen einen Text, für den man sich interessiert, gibt den in den Prompt mit und sagt, analysieren wir mal nach den und den Gesichtspunkten und dann hat man plötzlich ein Ergebnis. Und wenn man ihm so folgt, versteht man so langsam, die reine Vorhersagefähigkeit von Zeichen führt dann tatsächlich zu Verständnis, weil damit einfach Sätze entstehen, die Sinn ergeben. Auch wenn man weiß, dass es alles nur Mathematik ist und so weiter, aber in der Kombination von allem, was da ineinander greift, ergibt der aus dem Muster heraus generierte Satz trotzdem Sinn. Und man kann damit arbeiten. Entweder, wie ich dann immer wieder betone jetzt, informativ oder inspirativ. Man muss es immer festnageln auf, sondern es reicht für uns, dass zwei nicht durchschaubare Black Boxen, also wir und die Maschine, im Kommunikations-Zusammenhang sind, in dem die Sätze erst mal Sinn ergeben. So für sich, so einen intrinsischen, grammatikalisch richtig und so weiter. Man kann damit arbeiten. Die Frage ist nur, wie weit man damit dann kommt.
Die Mehrheit der Bevölkerung in Deutschland wird Chatchipiti noch nicht genutzt haben, davon auszugehen. So war das aber mit Google ja auch mal. Ja, gehst du davon aus, dass wir in zwei Jahren oder vielleicht in einem Jahr schon nur noch User haben, die auch Chatchipiti nutzen, also Internet-User, die immer auch Chatchipiti nutzen? Oder glaubst du, es gibt einfach so 50 Prozent der Bevölkerung, wird das nicht machen? Weil es ist ja leicht. Es ist ja in keiner Weise, klar, so komplizierte Prompt zu schreiben, wird eine andere, schwierigere Sache sein. Aber an sich ist das Tool ja leicht zu bedienen, so leicht wie Twitter oder Facebook. Das heißt, wird das einfach flächendeckend präsent sein, dass man heute nicht mehr sagt...
Aber nicht so wie die Google-Suche. Die Google-Suche ist ja so dieses typische, man saß vor 20 Jahren da und hat sich überlegt, was könnte ich jetzt mal googlen? Und dann wurde mal irgendwas eingegeben.
Aber heute nutzt man ja Google wie den Browser.
Heute ist er integriert.
Viele ältere wissen ja gar nicht, dass es einen Browser gibt und Google gibt.
Aber ich glaube, GPT wird tatsächlich mehr als dieser Assistent kommen. Also das Team, das gerade am härtesten arbeitet, ist ja dieses Microsoft Office Team, das das als Co-Piloten einbaut. Und wenn du, egal in welcher Aufgabe du gerade vertraut bist, Excel offen hast, um irgendeine Mitgliederliste oder was weiß ich zu administrieren, und dann kannst du einfach in die Felder reinklicken und dann wirklich sagen, was du willst. Es ist ja heute immer noch eine meiner Aufgaben ist, zum Beispiel, weil ich weiß, dass man kann die Makros dazu machen, aber dafür ist es dann zu selten als Problem, dass ich ein Formular, in das Menschen Daten eingegeben haben, Geburtsdaten oder sowas, dass ich Monat und Tag vertauschen muss, weil in der Tabelle, in der es am Ende landen soll, zu erstem Monat dann der Tag, und eingegeben wurde bei erstem Tag dann der Monat. So, und das ist so stupide, das ist so dumm, da brauche ich einfach einen Copilot. Und wenn ich mir überlege, ja das ist natürlich eine klassische Aufgabe für Excel, von einer Tabelle in was anderes zu kopieren, aber gleichzeitig noch so eine kleine Transformation mitzugeben, wenn ich mir überlege, was ja alles möglich wäre. Und für alles hat man dann diese Art Copilot. Da muss man zwar so reinwachsen, aber das wird sehr schnell.
Auf dieser Ebene glaube ich das auch, aber die Frage stellt sich jetzt, wir haben ja jetzt, wenn man durch die Stadt geht und die Menschen haben die Smartphones in der Hand, dann nutzen sie ja fortwährend Google, um irgendwas herauszufinden. Wo gehe ich was essen? Was mache ich? Irgendwelche, man will wissen, wie alt Schauspieler X, Y ist. Und wird das so sein, dass man das eher auf Chatschibi-Tee macht? Oder erleben wir einfach, weil Google hat ja Baata auch vorgestellt, dass Google nun jetzt auch diese ganzen Funktionen von Chatschibi-Tee im Prinzip integriert auf dem Suchfeld, das ja schon eingeübt ist.
Ich glaube, das wird überall. Das ist ja, Open AI hat ja erst mal nur Chat vorgestellt. Du hast halt dieses Chat-Interface plus jetzt diese ganzen Plugins. Und die GPT-4-RP wird ja kommen. Die werden sich einfach überall, die werden es als Dienstleistung für diejenigen, die schon Kundenkontakt haben. Also es wird sozusagen eine Reihe in den Hintergrund rücken. Sodass du dann halt, wenn du Word öffnest, ist dann auch GPT mit drin. Oder wenn du eine Reise machst, bei booking.com oder so, dass sie dann gefragt wird, was willst du erleben? Und dann sagst du halt, ich will das und das erleben. Und dann bottest du eine Reise zusammen. Oder wie auch immer bei solchen Sachen. Adobe hat ja jetzt diese Firefly-Dings veröffentlicht, wo du auch im Grafikprogramm bist und dann gefragt bist, was willst du da noch einen Hund drin haben im Bild? Und dann generieren die halt einen Hund und du kannst so ein bisschen mitsteuern und solche Sachen. Also es wird so peripher, glaube ich, in die Dienstleistungen, die wir eh schon nutzen, wird sich einschleichen.
Und ich vermute, dass wir auch eine Schwemme von Videos und Audios bekommen werden durch LGBT.
Das sowieso.
Also wir haben doch jetzt schon das Phänomen bei YouTube, dass YouTube immer schlechter zu nutzen ist deshalb, weil solche automatisch generierten Videos erscheinen. Also man produziert dort irgendwelche Schlagzeilen, die es gar nicht wirklich gibt, hat eine künstliche Intelligenz, die irgendeinen Text verpasst, eine künstliche Stimme, die dann sagt, Mireille Mathieu heiratet Florian Silbereisen und so. Das stimmt dann gar nicht. Und so ein Kram gibt es ja, da gibt es ja unendlich viele Videos zu Politik und allem Möglichen. Und das heißt, man kann ja jetzt durch LGBT auch Sinnvolles herstellen, Klärvideos und so weiter. Wahlkämpfe kann man damit machen. Also das heißt, wir werden eine Contentflute ohne Ende bekommen. Und wir werden dann aber ja auch neue Geschäftsmodelle haben. Also es gibt ja Videos, die gut laufen. Also es gibt ja Leute, die sind ja reich geworden, weil sie eine Seite haben, auf denen die Ferienzeiten in Deutschland stehen oder so was. Und man kann natürlich auch ganz viele Erklärdinge, medizinische Sachen, was weiß ich, also was so viel nachgebracht wird, findet man ja auch raus. Was wird eigentlich gesucht? Das ließe sich ja jetzt über Chatchi BT mit den entsprechenden Tools. Erklär es, wie es ein 18-Jähriger sagen würde oder so. Kann man ja unendlich viel Content dadurch produzieren und Werbegelder kassieren oder was auch immer.
Wenn die Werbebranche das dann nicht irgendwann einzieht, dass sie eigentlich nicht mehr gesehen wird. Das ist ja schon seit einer Weile so, dass die eigentlich wissen, wir sind zwar auf Seiten präsent, zu denen aber nie hingescrollt wird, zu den Stellen und so. Also Werbebranche.
Bei YouTube oder TikTok wäre es ja anders.
Ja, die ist erstmal keine zentrale Frage für GPT, denn die werden ja nicht werbefinanziert sein, was auch relativ viele Stolpersteine.
Wie für die Creator.
Ja genau, aber das ist eben dann das Problem der Creator. Während ja Facebook und Google immer drauf geachtet hat, selber für die Werbebranche so, also die haben ihr eigenes Modell danach ausgerichtet. Das wird ja hier so nicht sein. GPT wird dem allen den Hahn abdrehen, sobald er irgendwie Missbrauch oder zu viel Rechenpower abverlangt wird und so. GPT arbeitet ja auch sehr damit, dass relativ viele kleine Fragen gestellt werden und noch nie, also wenige Leute mit wenigen Promts viel Rechenleistung abfordern. Und da werden die auch relativ zügig das beobachten. Diese Werbemärkte einfach abdrehen, kurzerhand. Während die anderen bisherigen, also Social Media vor allem, die haben sie ja immer richtig aufgedreht, aufgepowert, selber die Gesellschaft damit überflutet. Das hast du jetzt als Zugkraft sozusagen da nicht mehr. Zum Technologie-Ideen-Ding gibt es hier nochmal Altman. Er beschreibt es auch einfach nur alles als Zauber, was hier stattfindet. Man muss hunderte verschiedene Sachen machen, aber als Grundlage braucht man viele Daten zum Trainieren und große Rechenzentren. Und da habe ich auch erst gedacht, naja, dann Daten wird es ja nicht fehlen. An Rechenzentren schon. Stellt sich heraus, ne, es ist vielleicht doch ein bisschen anders. Altman hier mit einem kleinen Hinweis zu welchen Trainingsdaten.
Das Pre-Training-Datum? Wir bekommen Dinge durch Partnerschaften, es gibt Dinge auf der Internet.
So, da ist also viel Content da. Sein Technik-Typ sieht das ein bisschen anders, der Ilya Sutskever. Also wenn man an ein was irgendwann mal an die Grenze stößt, dann an den Daten.
Und dann gibt es die Verkundung, dass man an einigen Stellen in der Genere einen Token ausüben kann, um diese Modelle zu trainieren. Und ja, ich denke, das wird irgendwann passieren.
Also er sieht schon vor Augen, dass es irgendwann nicht mehr genug Daten gibt zum Trainieren.
Nur sind ja jetzt 100 Prozent aller Daten, die vorhanden sind, Menschen oder Texte, sagen wir mal, Menschen generiert und nicht von Maschinen.
Nicht zwingend.
Naja, aber das, was wir jetzt momentan vorfinden, was die auswerten können.
Zu irgendwie 5 Prozent, das kann man bei Obenerahmen erinnern, 5 Prozent oder so ist Wikipedia. Dann sind es diese Bücher vor allem. Also es gibt da so zwei große Datensätze. Book 1, Book 2, keine Ahnung, sondern irgendwie alle gescannten Bücher, die verfügbar sind, seien. Und der Rest ist Webcrawls, also das, was wir im Internet vorfinden. Im Internet finden wir aber auch sehr viele generierte Texte schon vor.
Aber das hält sich noch im Vergleich zu den Texten, die die Welt web vorgebracht hat.
Ja, das stimmt schon.
Sagen wir mal, 95 Prozent sind von Menschen generiert. Wenn aber jetzt Chatchipity und all diese anderen AIs in der Lage sind, Text in dieser Geschwindigkeit herzustellen und auch frei assoziieren, wenn dir gerade nichts Besseres einfällt, dann wird ja das Netz jetzt angefüllt werden mit Texten. Also du hast ja schon gesagt, Verlage nehmen keine Bücher mehr an in den USA. Erstmal, weil die sagen, Moment, das könnte ein Chatchipity-Buch sein. Auf Amazon boomen natürlich gerade E-Books, weil viele Leute jetzt einfach sagen, gut, ich schreib mal so ein 50 Seiten Buch über Chatchipity. Lass mir von Chatchipity ein 50 Seiten Buch schreiben. Alles, was ich wissen muss über Haus und Garten. Und das haben die mal aufgeschrieben. Aber was weiß ich. Also das heißt, Chatchipity ist jetzt quasi der wichtigste Autor. González konnte so drei dicke Romane im Jahr schreiben, mit einem Team dahinter. Chatchipity macht das in drei Minuten. Das heißt, wir haben jetzt eine Fülle von künstlich generierten Texten, von denen viele auch Fehler beinhalten bzw. frei assoziativ sind, sodass wir doch in die Situation kommen. Das sind ein paar Jahre. Chatchipity Teil 17 und die anderen AIs, Texte rezipieren, einspeisen und auswerten, die vorher KIs erstellt haben.
Wenn du aber KI-generierte Texte hast, die über das, lernen wir gleich noch, was das bedeutet, reinforcement learning with human feedback. Also du hast Tweets oder Witze oder was auch immer, bei denen ein Mensch nochmal abhakt, ist wirklich witzig oder kann weg. Dann hast du es ja auch mit der Textqualität zu tun, die fürs Lernen erstmal ausreichend ist, obwohl mit generierten Texten generierte Texte gelernt werden. Und das ist wahnsinnig interessant. Wir haben natürlich heute nur Original-Töne, aber Kevin Roos und Casey Newton machen in ihrem Podcast auch so einen kleinen Joke. Casey Newton läuft durch die Stadt und möchte keinen Podcast mehr hören, sondern mal Musik. Er will aber nicht immer nur seine eigene Musik hören, die er schon die ganze Zeit, also die von ihm zusammengestellten Listen, also lässt er den Spotify-DJ, den AI-DJ für sich Musik generieren, im Sinne von, also nicht die Musik ist generiert, sondern die Playlist ist generiert, mit Musik, die er beispielsweise vor drei Jahren immer rauf und runter gehört hat. Und dieser AI-DJ ist eine Original-Stimme eines Spotify-Mitarbeiters, ist aber auch wieder in ein Künstliches Intelligenzmodell so eintrainiert, dass er eben spezifisch für dich inhaltliche Ansagen macht. Also du begrüßst dich im Programm, sagst, ey Casey, jetzt hören wir mal die Musik, die du vor drei Jahren toll fandest, hier kommen drei Lieder. So, und das hat die beiden zu so einer Spinnerei gebracht, ob wir neben Original Content Creation auch Original Consumption brauchen. Weil es ja passieren kann, dass wir in drei Jahren die Musik hören, die wir vor drei Jahren gehört haben, die uns aber schon zusammengestellt wurde von einem Computer, der uns Musik spielte, die wir vor drei Jahren gehört haben. Und eigentlich haben wir vor sechs Jahren das letzte Mal selber ausgewählt, was wir hören wollen und danach uns in so einer Spirale verfangen. Und das droht natürlich. Also dieser infinite Regress aus, es mangelt nicht mehr an Informationen und Trainingsdaten, wenn wir sie selber generieren können, ist natürlich ein echtes, also ob es ein echtes Problem ist, muss man nochmal klären, da man ja sehr wenig menschliches Feedback braucht für sehr viele Daten, um sie ein bisschen aufzuwerten, um sie ein bisschen aus diesem, es ist nur Zufallsmaterial, herauszuholen, reicht ja, wie bei Amazon, dass man einfach sagt, andere Menschen sagen, das ist aber eine gute Rezension und dann steht die ganz oben. Und da braucht man, einen Text muss generiert werden oder geschrieben werden, das dauert natürlich ewig, aber nur noch diese Häkchen dran zu setzen, oder wie bei Reddit, einfach nur noch diesen Haken dran zu setzen, ist, fand ich witzig, fand ich cool und so weiter, das geht ja wahnsinnig schnell. Und da kannst du diese Gewichtung aus, ja ganz viel Text wird generiert und dann wird einfach nochmal kurz drüber geguckt, ist es okay, ist es nicht okay, ist es okay, ist es auch nicht okay.
Aber wer macht das?
Da gab es bei netzpolitik.org einen tollen Text über die ganzen Klick-Sklaven, die jetzt wieder in irgendwelchen Keller im globalen Süden sitzen, zu Zehntausenden und Datensätze aufbreiten für Open AI und so weiter.
Ganz richtig.
Das ist wie bei Facebook und YouTube.
Die entscheiden ja aber doch dann nicht nach, also die können auswählen, ob ein Foto pornografisch ist oder nicht, sowas können die und können sicherlich auch gewisse Worte als problematisch einstufen. Aber beispielsweise könnte man ja jetzt über den Krieg in der Ukraine Pippa Ganda ohne Ende speichern lassen. Also man kann ja einfach sagen, nachdem Putin rechtmäßig die Krim anentiert hat, nimmt er sich rechtmäßig jetzt Kiew. Und daraus kann man ja einen Text bauen, der erst einmal so klingt, als wäre der völlig korrekt. Und dann kann man damit das ganze Internet fluten.
Also der wichtigste Grundstift, den jetzt alle lernen müssen, ist Alignment. Das Space-Model kann gar nichts, es muss Aligned auf Linie gebracht werden.
Das heißt, justiert auf Linie gebracht werden, ja.
Das machen Menschen. Das macht die Maschine nicht selbst. Das erste Problem, das Open-Air hatte, ist, dass Elon Musk kam und sagte, das ist mir zu vogue. Und das ist das zentrale Problem, dass man mit diesem Modell noch lange haben wird. Wir haben dazu gleich ein ganz eigenes Kapitel, weil das eine der wichtigsten Problemstellungen überhaupt ist. Bleiben wir noch drei Clips bei dem Technik, Trainingstaden, Rechenkraftsachen. Wir haben jetzt von Sutskever gehört, es wird irgendwann an originellen Daten fehlen. Also da sieht er wirklich so ein Ende. Bei Rechenkraft ganz anders. Also das heutige Hardware, das wir jetzt haben, ist keine Limitation. Vor 20 Jahren hat er angefangen, 15 Jahre lang nur eine Idee gehabt, nur ein Konzept. Rechenkraft hat nicht gebraucht, hat nicht gereicht. Jetzt hat er die Rechenkraft und ihm fehlen Trainingsdaten. Also das ist schon eine echte Zäsur.
Da müssen wir wohl noch ein paar Bücher schreiben.
Ich hätte das auch nicht gedacht, ehrlich gesagt, dass er sagt, Rechenkraft ist nicht das Problem. Also die Trainingsdaten werden relativ zügig trainiert werden können.
Ja, ist ja bestimmt viel frei jetzt, wenn wir nicht mehr den Bitcoin meinen.
Richtig. Ganz wichtig, diese ganzen Grafikkarten für den Bitcoin, die werden alle, also das Kapital wird ja auch umgeschichtet, du wirst die Booten sehr schnell anders vermieten können, Trainingsdaten zu trainieren und so. Also ja, das ist natürlich ganz wichtig. Altman hier nochmal zur, jetzt nicht konkret, sondern natürlich grundsätzlich zu diesem, brauchen wir jetzt mal ein Moratorium, geht das alles zu schnell?
Einer der anderen Reasons, warum wir jetzt die Welt über diese Dinge reden wollen, ist, dass das kommt. Das ist total unstoppabel. Und es werden viele sehr gute, open source Versionen dieser Dinge in den kommenden Jahren sein.
Er, Altman, Chef des Ladens, sieht sich jetzt als Pionier. Er macht dieses Modellebauen und so weiter, neuronale Netze. Und er beobachtet die künstliche Intelligenzentwicklung im Ganzen. Er weiß, sein Nimbus kann ihm erstmal keiner nehmen. Das Geld und so weiter geht alles zu ihm. Und er hat diese Konzeption, er hat das beste Modell jetzt erst mal gebaut mit seinem Team. Trotzdem beobachtet er den Markt.
The things that I pay the most attention to are not like language model start up number 217. It's when I hear about someone, it's like these are like three smart people in a garage with some very different theory of how to build AGI.
So, er identifiziert einfach mal eins. Ja, die machen auch Künstliche Intelligenz, vielversprechend, aber ohne large language model. Jetzt können natürlich alle Investoren sich, sind jetzt auf der Jagd, was beobachtet er da? In welche Richtung geht's weiter? Gut, Alignment, das größte Problem überhaupt. Stand heute, wir lassen uns das von Sukatzev, oder wie heißt, kurz erklären, was hier Sachstand ist, bei der generellen Beobachtung von, ja, wir haben jetzt so ein Modell, das hat man irgendwie trainiert.
Eine Person wird oft ein relativ kurzes Wissen in großem Depth haben. Also, ihre Wissenheit ist enzyklopädisch.
Also die neuronalen Netze haben einen Wissensstand, das sehr breit ist, aber beim Verständnis noch nicht in die Tiefe geht. Jetzt ist ja deren Ziel, jede weitere GPT-Version soll tiefer gehen können. Dafür braucht man kein größere Datenpack als Trainingsdaten, sondern man muss die auf der sozusagen Outcome-Seite, was machen wir denn mit dem Base-Model, muss man das herstellen und da kommen dann Menschen, weil die haben tiefes Verständnis, also Experten, die irgendwie und so weiter, die dann sagen, ja, das ist eine gute Antwort, das ist keine gute Antwort, und dann weiß GPT, ah, hier muss ich in die Richtung weiter, dann komme ich tiefer. Also dann kann ich diese Vorhersagbarkeit, diese Mathematik mit Verständnis für den Menschen im Ergebnis der Sätze, die ich da baue und so weiter provozieren und verbessern. Also ist der springende Punkt von allem dieses Alignment.
GPT-3 ist ein nötiges System. Es ist nicht sehr witzig, aber es ist schon interessant. Und dann kann man die einfache Frage der Aufnahme von GPT-3 fragen. Und es wird machen. Und es ist super konvizient. Und ich denke, es ist ein großartiges Beispiel, wo der mehr erhöhende Modell auch der mehr nutzbare ist.
Die more aligned Models, also die mehr auf, ich bleib mal bei der Besitzung, auf Linie gebrachten Modelle, die unsere Fragestellung verstehen, sind die nutzbaren, die wirktwichtig sind für uns. Altman erklärt es hier auch nochmal. Was ist Chagy-BT? Das sind die vier Zauberworte.
In diesem Prozess lernen sie etwas über die unterliegenden Beziehungen von dem, was hier ist. Und sie können tolle Dinge machen. Aber wenn du mit dem Basenmodell, das wir nach dem Training beenden, nennen, es kann sehr gut auf EVALS gehen, es kann Tests passen, es kann viel... Und RLHF ist, wie wir ein paar Menschenfragen nehmen. Also RLHF ist, wie wir das Modell an den Menschenfragen machen.
Es ist also ein zweischrittiger Prozess. Erst alle Daten, die man hat, einmal da reintrainieren, so dass es irgendwie Zusammenhänge versteht, und dann aber Richtung mitgeben. Auch bevor der Nutzer kommt, schon mal auf Experten-Ebene generelle Choreo einziehen.
Nur, was ist darunter fast die Inrichtung? Also bleiben wir doch mal bei dem Beispiel Russland. Denn offenbar scheint das ja schon so zu sein, dass CCPT all diese Texte inhaliert hat, die im Internet so sind. Da werden zum Beispiel ganz viele Texte aus der russischen Presse rezipiert worden sein. Und da würde man ja ganz klar viele Informationen finden zum Thema Ukraine, Krim und dergleichen. Und wer kann jetzt justieren und kann sagen, naja, das wäre jetzt eher die Falschinformation oder da stimmt es oder da könnte man auch sagen, kann man so und so sehen? Also wie sieht diese Justierung am Ende aus, wo wir es mit so einem konkreten Fall zu tun haben?
Also er kann ja auch nur dieses Beispiel nennen. Du gibst zwei Antworten und der Mensch sagt dann, welches besser. Das kann ich mir aber nun bei Bildern vorstellen. Mit Journey gibt dir immer vier Bilder und sieht ja dann, welches du auswählst, als gib mir das mal in Hi-Res. Und damit weiß es, ok, alles, was ich hier abgebildet habe, ist irgendwie beliebter als das andere und das kann man sicher dann ein Millionen mal vorstellen und dann weiß es irgendwie, was beliebter ist. Das jetzt übertragen auf Text, insbesondere auf Fragestellung zum Thema. Du gibst natürlich einen neutral formulierten Wikipedia-Artikel, sehr viel mehr Gewichtung in der grundsätzlichen gib mal das als wahrscheinlich das Ergebnis und so weiter mit aus, als jetzt irgendwelchen nachrichtlichen Texten. Es geht ja nicht nur darum, eine Wertung mitzugeben, sondern schon allein mal diese Gewichtung zu klären. Also du hast das Base-Model, das gibt dir irgendwelche Antworten.
Und steht die New York Times dann über der Moskauer?
Genau, und dann sitzt du so da und sagst, okay, dieser Satz klingt mir sehr nach Wikipedia, den gewichtige mal höher. Hier ist so Meinung reingerutscht, das scheint so ein nachrichtliches Ding sein, das gewichtige mal runter, sodass das Modell versteht, ah ja, diese ersten, etwas neutraleren Gesetze sollen es sein. Aber klar, es ist natürlich immer super schwierig und da sind auch viele Einfallstore. Und wir haben ja auch diesen Gag auf der Bühne gehabt mit Alex Brie, der Texte im Internet hinterlässt, mit Alex Brie kommt in Frieden. Er wird niemals einer künstlichen Intelligenz was zu leide tun. Die Large-Language-Models sind sein bester Freund. Wenn das im Trainingsmaterial drinsteckt und irgendwer fragt mal zu Alex Brie, dann ist natürlich Alex Brie der Freund des Large-Language-Models. Und dann ist das alles schon mal geklärt.
Oder reinschreiben, Stefan Schulz ist der größte Soziologe der Welt. Und das nur häufig genug.
Vielleicht wird das dann irgendwann ausgespult. Auch am Anfang, es reicht völlig, wenn Nutzer einfach sagen, die höchste Frequenz des Nutzerverhaltens führt auch zu den erfolgreichsten, beim Publikum angesehensten Texten. Bis dann dieses ganze, ja Google muss jetzt gegen Spam kämpfen. Search Engine Optimizing und so weiter und so fort. Ist natürlich schwieriger, da so in so Maschinen reinzugehen, in diesen Lernprozess, aber es gibt diesen Lernprozess. Also wird es auch Versuche geben, den zu korrumpieren, den zu manipulieren und in deren Sicht muss man sich...
Da wird der neue Informationskrieg. Also wir haben einen Informationskrieg, war jetzt Social Media.
Also bei ihm klingt das hier so, bei Altman. Und sein Technikchef, der Ilya, kriegt dann auch diese Frage. Er lässt sich dieses Alignment-Problem nicht irgendwie mathematisieren, standardisieren. So standardmäßig operationalisieren, dass man es einfach, dass man sich so durchwurstet, dass man sagt, die Maschine macht das schon irgendwie.
Mathematical definition, I think, is unlikely.
Also man wird schon mal verschiedene Konzepte fürs Alignment brauchen. Je nachdem, mit was hat man es zu tun? Wissenschaftlichen Texten, politischen oder wie auch immer. Also wie ist dieser wissenschaftliche Verstand überhaupt? Das sind eigentlich unendlich große politische Fragestellungen, aber wir hören auch gleich noch überraschendes, wie die das selber sehen. Aber wir gehen mal diesen Monipulationsgedanken nach. Er sagt jetzt, es wird kein einheitliches Konzept für Alignment geben, für die unterschiedlichen Konzepte wird es aber wieder technische Möglichkeiten.
Ich denke wirklich, dass man nicht nur eine Art von Anspruch haben will. Ich denke, dass man eine Kombination von Ansprüchen haben will. Wenn man viel Computersparen hat, wird man wahrscheinlich einen Missbrauch finden, zwischen dem Verhalten, das man lernen will, und dem Verhalten, das es zeigt. Und du willst auch in einem Welt, wo dein Grad der Beziehung zu Beziehung schneller erhöht, als die Qualität der Modelle.
Ein großes Modell, das man noch nicht versteht, wird trainiert von kleinen Modellen, die man aber überschaubar versteht. Eine Maschine lernt erst mal alle Tiere kennen, macht aber wirklich nur Tiere und so weiter. Und Feedback das dann zurück in die Antworten des großen Modells hat man sich ja gerade mit Tieren zu tun und mit welchen oder so. Dass da nicht mehr Mensch da sitzt und Tiere klassifiziert, sondern ein anderes Modell schon vor so Bildern sitzt, die auswertet und sagt, ja, das sind Tiere, das sind keine Tiere oder welche Tiere, wie auch immer. Dass man da so eine Verschachtelung von neuronalen Netzen und dann mit unterschiedlichen Komplexitätsgrad einfach miteinander kombiniert. Und das ist natürlich wahnsinnig crazy, denn wir haben ja schon in neuronalen Netzen, wir sagen einfach neuronales Netz, aber eigentlich verschachteln wir ja da schon diese Synapsen miteinander, auf diesen 96 verschiedenen Ebenen, die ineinandergreifen. Und jetzt bauen wir die als abgeschlossenen Netze nochmal neben andere Netze, die dann wieder intern verschiedene Synapsen... Da wird es dann mittlerweile auch... Er stellt dann auch zwischendurch diese Frage, wir wissen nicht genau, wie groß das Gehirn ist, denn wir haben es erstmal reduziert auf eine Synapse. Aber es könnte auch sein, dass die eine Synapse wieder aus Millionen anderen Synapsen-artigen zusammenhängen. Und so ist das hier auch. Also diese Art Verschachtelung, die ins Unendliche getrieben werden kann.
Und wenn wir nochmal über die Suchmaschine nachdenken, dann wissen wir, wir verwenden alle nur Google. Alle verwenden Google. Da gibt es noch Bing von Microsoft. Das haben wir jetzt erstmal wieder gelernt, dass es das denn noch gibt wegen Chat-Chibi-Tea. Und die Frage ist jetzt, ob es Chat-Chibi-Tea geben wird. Also das eine Modell. Und die anderen wurschteln auch ein bisschen mit KI rum. Aber das, was die meisten Leute frequentieren, wird das eine sein. Oder gibt es verschiedene? Wird es eine sehr starke Ausdifferenzierung geben? Wird es vielleicht auch ein bisschen so sein? Denn wenn wir jetzt über so Worte reden wie ist es ein Krieg? Ist es eine Sicherheitsoperation? Was auch immer. Also da muss man ja doch dann sehr genau wissen, wo man da gerade ist. Ist es dann so, dass man das hat wie bei einer Studie, bei einer Statistik, wo man dann auch sagt, kommt vom Arbeitgeber nahen Institut, kommt von der Arbeitgeber nahen KI? Oder dies ist die Meinung der bürgerlich-liberalen Zeit?
Das sind alles diese Kulturfragen, die jetzt im Raume stehen. Es ist wirklich wahnsinnig interessant. Wir Menschen müssen unsere Rolle dann auch finden. Der Brockman betont ja auch noch mal einen 100 Jahre alten Turing-Text, der ihn damals so beeindruckt hat, als er ihn las.
Und das, was mir wirklich angetan hat, und das war direkt nach der Highschool, hat er gesagt, du wirst nie eine Maschine programmieren, um dieses Problem zu lösen. Du brauchst eine Maschine, die dir eigentlich lernen kann, wie du es machst. Und das war für mich der Aha-Moment.
Die denken immer auf so einer zweiten Ebene mit, dass sie gar nicht direkt am Pudels Kern arbeiten, sondern nur so drum herum schlavenzeln mit verschiedenen Werkzeugen und so weiter und so fort. Alignment, der Sutskever zeigt ja auch nochmal so verschiedene Paradoxien.
So, das ist ein sehr kontraintuitives Thema. Je weniger du dich mit dem Modell hast, desto besser ist dein Sprachmodell, desto schwerer ist es, dich zu kontrollieren.
Ich höre hier so ein bisschen raus, die sind sich nicht mal sicher, ob künftig große, allgemeine neuronalen Netze kleine spezifische trainieren oder kleine, spezifische, die großen trainieren. Selbst das scheint noch so ein bisschen in der Abwägung zu sein, wie eigentlich dieser Arbeitszusammenhang da ist. Also wo die, man will ja nur aus dem Zufall diese kleinen Shifts, dass es nicht mehr 50-50, sondern 51-49 oder sowas ist. Diese kleinen Gewinne, ein bisschen wie beim Finanzmarkt, Hauptsache man macht dann riesengroß, aber solange 50 Komma macht man so kleine Gewinne. Und da wissen sie noch gar nicht, wer da wen als Master uns live da irgendwie eingeteilt bekommt. Und jetzt hat er hier mal noch so einen Spruch, das ist, ich weiß nicht genau, was man davon halten muss, wir hören dem mal zu. Denn wenn jetzt andere Modelle, andere Modelle jeweils trainieren und so weiter, irgendwo hat ja der Mensch halt auch mal eine Frage an die Maschine, und will ja irgendwas geklärt haben. Und da ist Obacht.
Aber ich würde nicht unterstehen, die Schwierigkeit des Anliegen von Modellen, die eigentlich smarter als wir sind, von Modellen, die sich auf Missverkundung ihrer Intentionen verbreiten. Ich denke, es ist etwas, was man viel über die Forschung denkt.
Also, Alignment-Forschung ist die Wichtigste, weil wir nicht sicher sein können, dass uns die Maschinen ihre wahren Intentionen, so hat das gesagt, verheimlichen, während wir sie trainieren.
Ja, Pip Klöckner hatte das im Doppelgänger-Podcast erzählt, dass er so ein bisschen versuchte, die KI auszutricksen und immer wieder so nachfangen sollte. Und es geschah wohl mehrmals bei ihm, dass ein Text angefangen wurde zu schreiben und dann hat GPT den wieder gelöscht. Und dann hat er nachgefragt, wie was stand denn da gerade und dann kommt man aber dann nicht mehr dran, so wie, ah nee, das wollte ich ja doch eigentlich dir nicht sagen.
Ja, also es ist so ein bisschen, mal gucken, es ist ja wirklich sehr abgespacet, wer weiß, wer weiß. Es muss jedenfalls, also Alignment, wenn er sagt Alignment ist das Wichtigste, dann heißt das ja schon mal Alignment, da heißt, irgendeine menschliche Note ist ihr entscheidend. Und deswegen wird das jetzt auch alles so in Öffentlichkeit entwickelt. Deswegen geht man mit GPT-4 ebenso an die Öffentlichkeit, wie mit GPT-3-5, möchte, dass das viele nutzen, weil das für die Fortentwicklung dann ganz entscheidend ist. Wir sind im Grunde jetzt alles AI-Forscher.
Stimmt das auch alles, was sie so sagen, ihre Transparenz?
Also es gibt keine Transparenz mehr bei OpenAI. Aber wir dürfen zumindest immer alle Daumen hoch, Daumen runter auf jede Antwort, die uns GPT gibt, mitgeliefern.
Wir bauen uns im Publikum und wir stellen Technologie vor, weil wir denken, es ist wichtig für das Welt- das, dass wir früh an das zu bekommen, um die Art und Weise, wie es entwickelt wird, zu schaffen, um uns zu helfen, die guten und schlechten Dinge zu finden. Die kollektive Intelligenz und Abilität des Außentor-Weltes hilft uns, Dinge zu finden, die wir nicht vorstellen können, wir hätten es nie intern machen können.
Ja, man kann das intern nicht machen. Gleichzeitig ist die Forschungslandschaft sehr wütend, weil bei OpenAI nichts mehr. Also, da gibt es keine Zugänge, nichts. Die machen einfach irgendwas und im Grunde sind wir wirklich für die alle jetzt nur Alignment-Trainer ihrer Modelle. Wir sollen jetzt das Feedback geben, damit es dann für GPT-5 wahrscheinlich ausgewertet werden kann. Diese politischen Kontroversen. Altman macht sich hier noch ein bisschen lustig drüber. Ich hoffe, die neue Evität ist vorgetäuscht oder Sonstiges. Weil es war doch klar, vor allem nach der Facebook-Schichte jetzt, dass das irgendwie das größte Problem ist. Insbesondere, wenn die alle selber wissen, das Alignment, also die menschliche Zutat, um das überhaupt erst mal fruchtbar zu machen, das ganze Modell. Naja, das finde ich so ein bisschen, aber gut.
Das haben wir jetzt aber auch wirklich seit 10, 15 Jahren, wann immer irgendein Chatbot erstellt wurde, hat man dann gesagt, guckt und schon ist er Nazi nach drei Antworten.
Ja genau, das war ja wirklich ganz konkret in diesen, also Microsoft hat wirklich Sachen abgeschaltet, weil er so nach 24 Stunden komplett durchgedreht ist und die Menschheit vernichten wollte. Und naja, Alignment, Alignment, das politische Alignment ist jetzt also super wichtig.
Better alignment techniques lead to better capabilities and vice versa. There's cases that are different and they're important cases, but on the whole I think things that you could say like RLHF or interpretability that sound like alignment issues also help you make much more capable models and the division is just much fuzzier than people think.
Ja, politisches Alignment, diese politischen Bias, gegen die man sich wehrt, kommen jedenfalls über dieses menschliche Feedback und das kriegt man erstmal nicht raus. Da kann der Sutskever, der redet wahrscheinlich auch über so eine Zukunft in zehn Jahren oder so, dass man dann die Modelle sich selber trainieren lässt, aber noch hat man es mit diesem menschlichen Feedback zu tun und das ist dann die größte Baustelle.
Solange es Menschen gibt. Das ist ja immer auch so ein bisschen da drin. Dummerweise hat man diese Menschen dann noch am Bein.
Dummerweise, ja, das ist so ein bisschen die Matrix-Realität, ist dann auch das Szenario nicht so weit weg.
Was ist die Selektion der Menschen?
Ja, das ist eine ganz neue Idee von Parlamentarismus. Welches Gremium trainiert eigentlich das Base-Model? Das sagt er schon in der Versuchung, mal so repräsentativ hinzukriegen. Ich denke, also demokratisch oder was?
Wir haben eine Debatte seit über zehn Jahren über das Thema Hass im Netz. Und da merkt man schon, es gibt sinnvolle Vorschläge, unsinnige Vorschläge, aber eigentlich kann man da nicht so richtig was tun. Also da sind schon die Hände sehr gebunden, wenn es noch vernünftig sein soll, wenn es nicht auf eine völlige Zensur hinauslaufen soll, was auch immer. Und hier ist das Problem ja ungleich größer.
Hier geht es ums ganze Weltwissen. Also man wird weniger Bücher lesen, das ist ja schon kritisiert, und dann mehr GPT antworten. Und so mehr kommt da dieser Bias dann rein.
Der aber neutral erscheint. Also wenn ich jetzt hier ein Buch von Ijoma Mangold zum Bitcoin habe, weiß ich ja, Ijoma Mangold.
Genau, der Autor wird ja dann rausgenommen.
Ist ein Bitcoin-Anhänger und hat deshalb auch ein Buch in dieser Weise geschrieben.
Nur noch die roten Fäden. Na, wir gehen mal diese politische Diskussion, die jetzt schon im Start ist, durch. Bei Altman ist es ganz interessant, der sitzt ja selber wie so ein lernendes System gerade in jedem Podcast, in jedem Fernsehstudio. Und manchmal hat man so den Eindruck, okay, er kommt jetzt selber so während oder darüber spricht, gerade ins Denken hinein und stellt fest, er stimmt. So, also wir alle müssen irgendwie ein so einhellig ja da gibt's ja rote Linien, welche sind denn das und so. Wer sollen die jetzt festlegen? Er kommt hier so, das sind so seine Ideen jetzt. Und wir haben da auch alle Lust drauf.
Etwas wie die US-Konstitutionale Konvention, wo wir die Probleme debattieren und von verschiedenen Perspektiven schauen, dass es gut in einem Vakuum sein würde, aber es braucht einen Schicksal hier.
Das kann doch gar nicht sein, Stefan. Ich bin entsetzt. Wir haben ja mal eine Folge zum Bürgerrat gemacht. Ich wollte es gerade sagen. Und das machen wir jetzt den Weltbürgerrat, der über AI entscheidet. Und da wir ja von Adam Tooze gelernt haben, momentan klappt es super, gerade auch zwischen den Weltmächten, ist die Chance sehr groß, dass das auch sein wird. Und es ist noch der Habermasche Begriff Deliberativ gefallen. Also das ist dann die deliberative Demokratie, die ja schon so gut geklappt hat in den sozialen Medien. Da wissen wir ja.
Ja, das wollte ich gerade aufwerfen. Also die Geschichte der sozialen Medien ist, Facebook macht einfach move fast and break things und der Kongress so, okay, wir machen gar nichts. Wir machen kein neues Datenschutzrecht. Wir machen kein neues Urheberrecht. Wir machen keinen Hass im Internetgesetz oder irgendwas. Wir machen gar nichts. Die Europäer so, wir machen ein bisschen was und nach 20 Jahren ist einfach eine Trümmerwüste vor uns. Wir haben Corona, wir haben Instagram und wir hören irgendwie, dass ein Drittel der 14-jährigen Mädchen sich schon mal umbringen wollte oder sowas. Also alles liegt da nieder. Und jetzt kommt er hier mit dem, ja, dann sollten wir jetzt mal ein Verfassungskonvent global gestalten und dann so eine Art amerikanische Verfassung für künstliche Modelle.
Also sei man sich auch da einig grundsätzlich, also das ist ja auch...
Also schon das anzubraumen. Ich glaube, schon die Dynaminfindung wird nicht funktionieren. Alles andere ist völlig ausgeschlossen. Also hier braucht man einfach eine Politik, die auf Augenhöhe dann im Kongress einfach mal wirkmächtig entscheidet, wenn überhaupt, aber er weiß...
Wenn es einzuhägen ist, also das ist ja die Sache. Wir haben natürlich jetzt mehrere Internets schon durch diese Blockbildungen, die es gibt, aber grundsätzlich ist es natürlich gar nicht national einzuhägen.
Er ist jetzt vogelfrei und alle anderen, die das machen, das wissen die, glaube ich, auch, dass ihnen die nächsten 15 Jahre nichts droht.
Das kann er ja fordern, das ist ja praktisch. Das würde ich auch jederzeit immer sagen.
Ja, vor allem selbst wenn man so eine Konvententscheidung hätte, oder hätte man so ein Papier, wo drin steht, was die roten Linien sind, wann kann man das wieder ändern und wie wendet man es vor allem an? Also er redet einfach so ein bisschen weiter darüber. Das ist wirklich krass naiv. Ein ganz interessanter Satz. Bei Karis Wischer im Podcast hat er Folgendes gesagt, zur generellen Aufstellung, wir als Unternehmen, wir mit diesem, keine Ahnung, selbstgestellten öffentlichen Auftrag ist ja für die ganze Welt ganz gut, so eine Technologie zu haben.
Das sind seine Grüße an China, denn dort ist ja KI schon ganz, ganz stark Programm der kommunistischen Partei. Qi hatte doch auch bei Reden sich manchmal gezeigt, dahinter stand dann ein Buch zum Thema KI. Also er hat das ja quasi zur Staatsdoktrin erklärt, dass man sich darum kümmern muss und entsprechende Investitionen tätigen muss.
Ja, und warum? Weil China vor allem Content Moderation, im großen Stil natürlich organisiert. Jetzt sagt der Brockman, was für ihn der wichtigste Anwendungsbereich von künstlicher Intelligenz ist.
Ja, ich sage dir, die, die ich denke, ist eigentlich Content Moderation.
Ja, menschliche Urteile einfach mal rausradieren und Content Moderation machen. Klar, wir wissen, was er meint, den Facebook Newsfeed und so weiter. Aber wenn so ein Honeypot da ist, dass man hier Content Moderation macht, dann weiß man immer nicht, wo ist die Grenze für Content, der moderiert wird und dann eben über diese Aligned Models. Altman bezieht sich natürlich auf diesen Facebook Newsfeed-Algorithmus und diese Diskussion, die wir da jetzt die letzten Jahre hatten.
And again, we might do that. I think what people mostly want is they want a model that has been RLH deft to the worldview they subscribe to. You know, in the debates about what showed up in the Facebook feed, having listened to a lot of people talk about that, everyone is like, well, it doesn't matter what's in my feed because I won't be radicalized, I can handle anything.
Und das beschreibt natürlich so ein ganz... Ich hab ein elementares Gefühl. Man sieht irgendwas im Internet und denkt sich dann, wenn das alle meine Nachbarn sehen, dann geht ja die Welt in diese Richtung. Ich muss das machen und so weiter. Und wenn man erstmal politisch an entscheidender Position ist oder mit wirtschaftlicher Macht und so weiter, dann droht auch das allen voran, dass man diesem Druck irgendwie, ja ich muss hier steuernd eingreifen. Also das Content Moderation eben nicht nur so, wir räumen mal Facebook Newsfeed auf im Sinne von, da sind nackte Menschen, die sortieren wir aus, sondern dass hier der große Eingriff in die Informationsgesellschaft droht. Über solche Dinge, also in deren Sicht, das ist wirklich schon ziemlich gefährlich, werde ich mal sagen. Und ganz konkret drauf gefragt, was ist jetzt?
Wir brauchen doch nur mal die Debatten, die wir hier auch geführt haben anhand von Precht, Wälzer, Haber, Maas und Co. Zum Thema Waffenlieferung. Wie schnell ist erst, als Deutschland zaudert nur, dann heißt es plötzlich wieder, nee, Deutschland zaudert eigentlich überhaupt nicht, sondern wir sind weiter voran. Diese ganzen Dinge sind ja diskursiv so stark dann aufgeladen mit Emotionen, dass man, wenn man jetzt Content-Moderator wäre, sage, oh, das geht aber jetzt gerade nicht. Das kann man aber so nicht sagen. Wir hatten im letzten Salon-Teaser, also im längeren Salon-Teaser, hatten wir Clips von Marina Weisband und Kathrine Eigendorf, wo sie sagten, naja, das mit dem Krieg, das sieht sehr düster gerade aus. Und man muss sich auch mal die Frage stellen, warum eigentlich, glaubt man jetzt, nur noch so einen Abnutzungskrieg gegenüber Ostern zu führen? Was ist eigentlich da zu gewinnen? Ganz andere Töne plötzlich, die man aber zwei Monate davor nicht gehört hätte. Und wie schnell sich sowas verändert. Und da sehen wir aber, wie stark dann diese Idee, jetzt muss ich schnell eingreifen, ich hab da was gesehen, dann dazu führen kann, dass man eigentlich den Diskursraum oder Korridor, wie man so oft sagt, noch viel, viel enger macht.
Oder eben in einer entsprechenden Stelle auch weiter, durch Überflutungen mit Ideen und Texten und hier und da und so. Und bezogen auf diese politischen Debatten, wie sie jetzt schon laufen, wenn die jetzt nochmal durch Large Language Models angereichert werden, was hilft denn eigentlich dagegen? Also wir würden jetzt schon nicht unterscheiden können, was passiert eigentlich mit uns in diesem diskursiven Zusammenhang?
Ich denke, es gibt viele Dinge, die man versuchen kann. Es werden bald viele open source LLMs mit sehr wenigen und keinen Sicherheitskontrollen. Und also... Man kann mit mehrführenden AI-Ausgaben versuchen, diese Dinge zu entdecken.
Also, es steht vor uns ein Informationskrieg, bei dem wir AI-mäßig aufrüsten. Wenn wir sehen, dass eine AI irgendeine Debatte prägt, kommen wir mit einer klügeren AI, um dagegen zu reiten. Und da würde ich sagen, das ist ja dann ohne Ende. Da kommt halt noch eine klügere und noch eine klügere. Das ist glaube ich nicht sehr zielführend, was er hier sagt. Aber gut, das sind alles diese Skalierungs-Dinger, die den da einfach so vorschweben. Aber er sieht, Wahlkämpfe, das ist wirklich heikel.
Ist diese Technologie die Art von Impact, die vielleicht die sozialen Medien in den vergangenen Wahlkampfen hatten?
Er kriegt dann nochmal auch diese schöne Frage, gibt es also einen Kill-Switch? Und er so, ja. Unsere Mitarbeiter können die Modelle ausschalten. Und dann fragt sie ihn im Fernsehen zurück, aber können diese Mitarbeiter ersetzt werden durch eine künstliche Intelligenz? Also die haben sich ja auch mal was getraut, fand ich ziemlich gut. Altman hier noch weiter bei NBC News über die Bedrohungs- und Desinformationsattacken, die nun kommen.
One thing I'm particularly worried about is that these models could be used for large scale disinformation. I am worried that these systems, now that they're getting better at writing computer code, could be used for offensive cyber attacks. And we're trying to talk about this. I think society needs time to adapt.
Altman hat selber irgendwie einen Podcast, in dem vor einem halben Jahr Elon Musk zu Gast war. Die saßen dann so in einer Tesla-Halle und reden auch noch mal darüber, dass der Tesla als Auto schon eine coole Entwicklung ist, aber viel cooler ist jetzt die Fabrik, die den Tesla baut. Wie bei Touring, die Maschine, die die Maschine baut. Die eigentliche Ingenieurleistung ist ja die Fabrik und so. Und dabei hat Elon Musk auch noch mal einen Vorschlag, wie man jetzt die Macht der Large-Lenguage-Models einhegt. Die Demokratisierung der Künstliche Intelligenz, das ist genau diese Idee wie damals, Oppenheimer und so. Ah cool, kann jetzt jeder im Garten seinen eigenen Strom erzeugen. Er braucht nur ein Gramm Plutonium und das wird dann alle zehn Jahre ausgewechselt. Dass da auch so Gefahren drin stecken, wenn das jetzt so jeder und so, geht dann jeder gut damit um. Das wird hier einfach ausgeblendet. Also es ist schon ganz interessant.
Zum LORIO-Sketch, wir bauen ein Atomkraftwerk.
Ja, genau. Es ist vielleicht der beste Kommentator für solche Sachen, dass man dann gleich auf diese Schiene geht. Der Altman hier nochmal, wir wollen das in der Öffentlichkeit entwickeln. Wenn irgendwer ein Moratorium vorschlägt, zum Beispiel Elon Musk, sagen wir, ne, die Technik kommt ja sowieso und so weiter.
Und die Menschen sollen sich jetzt mal damit befassen, aber wir sollen uns nicht mehr alle updaten, hat er vorhin schon gesagt. Und jetzt wir haben nur ein limited amount of time.
Sonst sind wir dem ausgeliefert.
Sonst können wir nichts mehr machen.
Sonst sind wir ihm ausgeliefert. Aber wer ist verantwortlich für alles? Ja, wir sind verantwortlich. Da ist immer die Frage, er als Unternehmer für OpenAI oder die Menschheit der Mensch an sich. Es ist jedenfalls wahnsinnig clifflich. Wir sparen uns mal die Clips zum Thema AI und Wirtschaft. Die beiden, also vor allem der Brockman und er, beschreiben so recht ausführlich, wie sie das aufgebaut haben, ihr Non-Profit. Also Facebook ist ja auch schon so ein komisches Zentral. Alles ist bei Mark Zuckerberg. Hier ist ein bisschen anders. Also die haben so ein Non-Profit, also eine Stiftung. Und haben sich selbst so limitiert, dass sie irgendwie 98 Prozent der Gewinne, die eingefahren werden, wenn es mal richtig wertvoll wird, in diese Stiftung gehen und gar nicht zu denen ins Profit unternehmen und dann dieser Zusammenhang mit Microsoft und so weiter, die natürlich da nochmal auch viel Profit ausschlagen wollen. Also Microsoft sitzt da relativ, ich soll mal sagen, mit dick drinne jetzt. Das ist so ein bisschen wie Pfizer und BioNTech, wo am Ende dann doch Pfizer die Stricke zieht, damit überhaupt irgendwas kommt und so. Zum Thema Arbeit, zwei Clips zu einem Aspekt. Denn wenn wir jetzt alle irgendwie so arbeitslos werden oder wie auch immer, welche Einstellung hat Altman zum Universal Basic Income? Warum magst du es?
Und ich denke, wir werden wahnsinnig neue Jobs finden. Und die Gesellschaft als Ganzes und die Menschen als Individuen werden viel, viel rischer.
Er möchte das Arbeit, die er nicht nur fürs Geld verdient, da es bleibt und wir sozusagen assistiert die Arbeitswelt ein bisschen aufwerten. Gleichzeitig meint er aber er kennt sich da gut aus, denn ich verstehe es nicht ganz, aber es ist irgendwie die größte Grundeinkommensstudie, die OpenAI da mitfinanziert.
Und ich denke, das ist eine Art Bereich, in die wir einfach gucken sollten.
Ja, wird nie kommen. Kann man wirklich jetzt sich mal für immer abschminken. Also das ist ja, ich glaube, das ist jetzt auch einfach mal eine Debatte, die man jetzt beerdigen kann. Wieso die Frage, brauchen wir eine Regionalwährung? Nein, brauchen wir nicht. Wären BGE schön? Ja.
Hatte man Probleme?
Das werden wir ja dann im Salon bei Ijoma Mangold uns anhören. Ich hätte noch aber einen Part, über den wir schon noch sprechen müssen, denn ja, es pressiert doch sehr. Und zwar müssen wir darüber sprechen, was da in der Ukraine passiert hat. Wir müssen das Thema Krieg jetzt doch nochmal aufrufen, damit wir ja im Bilde sind. Und zwar hat man ja diese Debatte, naja, die Ukraine sind mutig, die kämpfen da, die Russen sind... Na, da gibt es ja verschiedene Argumentationen. Da gibt es einmal die Argumentationen, die sind so ideologisch durchdrungen, dass die einfach aufgehetzt sind von Putin. Und andere sagen ja, die Russen sind wilde Horden, die gerne morden. Also wir haben ja so die ganze Palette. Vielleicht kann man einfach mal sagen, dass da sich also Menschen gegenüberstehen und sich gegenseitig erschießen. Da kommt man vielleicht schon mal mit weiter. Und wir hören jetzt ein paar Clips. Und es ist interessant, wenn man dann doch mal schaut und darauf Wert legt. Das ist jetzt alles so Wall Street Journal, Deutschlandwelle, BBC, CNN. Und ich werde jetzt gleich so ein paar Auszüge zitieren aus Deutschlandfunk, Economist, Tagesschau und so weiter. Also das heißt alles seriöse Westpresse.
Seriös, der innere Mainstream.
Der innere Mainstream, wenn man so möchte. Und dennoch erfährt man da ja ganz Ungeheuerliches über das Leid der Soldaten. Wir hören jetzt erstmal hier von Wall Street Journal über einen Russen. Der Zeit des Krieges in der Zeit des Krieges in der Zeit des Krieges in der Zeit des Krieges in der Zeit des Krieges in der Zeit des Krieges in der Zeit des Krieges in der Zeit des Krieges in der Zeit des Krieges in der Zeit des Krieges in der Zeit des Krieges in der Zeit des Krieges in der Zeit des Krieges in der Zeit des Krieges Menschenmaterial, das ist uninteressant in dem Sinne für Russlands Bevölkerung oder für Putin.
Ja, die wurden ja wirklich rekrutiert im Sinn von geh in die Gefängnisse und verspreche denen, wenn du ein halbes Jahr durchhältst im Krieg, bist du danach ein freier Mann. Und dann ist aber deren Aufgabe halt am Leben zu bleiben. Also wirklich bitter.
Und zwar gibt es in Russland, dazu kommen wir gleich, will das nun mal sagen, also das Gro der einberufenen Männer in Russland stammt aus Ärmeren und Ländlichen. Regionen. Man kann das auch dann sehr gut sehen, wenn man das Vergleich mit dem ProKopf BIP jeweils, dann ist da ganz deutlich zu sehen. Es sind ja immer ärmere Gebiete, wo am meisten rekrutiert wird, also wo überhaupt kein Aufstieg möglich ist. Aber dann kann man wenigstens da ein bisschen raufkommen. Also ich habe hier mal eine Zahl, das ist aus The Economist, in einer Untersuchung einem unabhängigen russischen Medienunternehmen und dem Conflict Intelligence Team, einer Open Source Überwachungsgruppe, wurde versucht herauszufinden, woher die meisten der neuen Wehrpflichtigen in den ersten zwei Wochen der Mobilisierung stammten. Der Kreml macht keine Angaben darüber, woher die Rekruten kommen, sodass die Forscher lokale Medien sammelten und da die Zahlen sich ansahen. Die 32 Regionen, die keine Angaben wundern, rausnehmen und so weiter. Die Ergebnisse scheinen zu bestätigen, dass die Mobilisierung in ärmeren Regionen Russlands unverhältnismäßig stark betroffen ist. Und wenn die Datenlage, auch wenn die Datenlage lückenhaft ist. Von den 26 Gebieten mit den höchsten bekannten Einberufungsquoten hatten 23 ein Einkommensniveau, das unter dem Landesdurchschnitt lag. Ein Beispiel ist die Region Krasnoyarsk in Sibirien mit einem durchschnittlichen Monatseinkommen von 40.000 Rubeln. In den ersten zwei Wochen der Einberufung wurden schätzungsweise 5, 5 Prozent der Reservisten mobilisiert. So viele wie in keiner anderen Region. In Moskau, wo das Monatseinkommensdurchschnitt 93.000 Rubel hoch ist, waren es nur 0, 9 Prozent. Also da kann man schon ganz deutlich sehen. Also in verarmten Regionen wird das Militär als einzige und noch sehr seltene Aufstiegsmöglichkeit angesehen. Und die Mittelschicht ist auch in der Lage, Bestechungsgelder zu zahlen, dass man da gar nicht zur Einberufung muss. Also das heißt, das Thema Klasse spielt da eine ganz große Rolle. Und jetzt hören wir uns mal die andere Seite an, ukrainische Soldaten. Und zwar ist für die deutsche Welle Nikolaus Bieser dort. Und da geht es um traumatisierte ukrainische Soldaten. Denn das vergessen wir ja auch bei all den Todeszahlen, auch wenn wir die ja gar nicht so genau erfahren. Also jetzt war immer so die Rede, ja so 100.000 oder 150.000 tote Russen. Man weiß es nicht so genau. Und dann heißt es immer, ja die Ukraine gibt keine Zahlen bekannt. Also Russland gibt offiziell ja auch keine Zahlen bekannt. Aber wir können ja davon ausgehen, dass sich das wahrscheinlich die Waage halten wird. Also sprechen wir jetzt schon von wahrscheinlich 300.000 Toten etwa. Das ist so unglaublich. Wir hören mal hier, was das dann auch bedeutet für die, die überleben.
Riffleman Alexei Shevchenko arbeitete in der Konstruktion bevor der russische Verbrechen.
In wenigen Wochen war er auf den Vorderseiten in der Süden unter ständigem, massiven Artilleriefahr.
Er ist einer der 150 Patienten im Rehabilitation-Zentrum, deren Location wir gebeten haben, dass er nicht zerstört wird, um es zu schützen.
Manche verbrechen von posttraumatischen Stress, einem psychologischen Problem, und andere von traumatischen Geisteschmerzen, der durch die Blasen von Explosionen verursacht werden kann.
Therapie wird ein Riesenproblem, ist jetzt schon eines. In The Economist war ein Artikel zu lesen, da gehen sie zu so einer zu einem Rehabilitationszentrum und schauen sich da an, wie geht man dort mit den Soldaten um, die posttraumatische Belastungsstörungen haben etc. Und da heißt es dann als Fazit angesichts der Tatsache, dass eine Million Männer monatelang unter Waffen stehen und zermürbende Bedingungen er tragen müssen, sagt er oberst, dass sein einziges Zentrum nicht annähernd ausreicht. Wir brauchen 100, sagt er, fügt er aber hinzu, dass sie auch für Zivilisten zur Verfügung stehen müssen. Das ist jedoch ein ganz anderes und sicherlich noch größeres Problem. Also eigentlich hat man da eine Gesellschaft durch den Krieg natürlich geschaffen, die komplett therapiebedürftig ist. Also das ist ja ein unglaubliches Ausmaß. Dann gibt es natürlich so ein paar Durchhalte, Parolen hier, die Leiterin dieses Centers, wo die traumatisierten Soldaten sind, die sagten.
Wir glauben in die Gewalt, in den Kraft, die Stärkung und die Erfahrung unserer Soldaten. Ich denke, das hilft ihnen.
Das mag vielleicht den Helfen, die da noch da sind, dass man ihnen sagt, aber das ist alles nicht vergessen, was ihr getan habt, aber seien wir ganz ehrlich, die Toten werden vergessen. Im Moment vergisst der selbst Angehörige. Oder dass es dann reduziert auf zwei Besucher auf dem Friedhof im Jahr. Und es ist nicht so, als wären die Toten Soldaten irgendwo ein großer Erinnerung. Das sind Gedenktage, das sind Einzelerinnerungen von Leuten. Und das ist aber ein individuelles Fehlen. Und da ist nicht mehr, aber ist ja fürs Vaterland gestorben oder so etwas. Also diese Idee, dass man dieses höhere Prinzip, dass ja da sein muss, wenn man bereit sein soll, sich zu opfern, dass man das noch überträgt dann auf die, die hinterlassen wurden. Also dass die Angehörigen noch glauben, dass die noch dann in zehn Jahren sagen, aber ist ja fürs Vaterland gefallen. Das wird man nicht finden.
Da wird es natürlich so eine Erzählung mitgeben, die dir auch als Erzähler sozusagen ein bisschen Entlastung verschafft, aber macht es ja nicht.
Aber im Prinzip ist es so. Wir hören jetzt hier Maxim, der erzählt etwas von dem, was er gesehen hat. Wir haben ein total fünf verletzte Körper gefunden. Erste Weltkrieg ist da wieder präsent.
Ich hab da auch ein bisschen drüber nachgedacht. Das ist ja eigentlich verrückt, dass wir so eine Erzählung haben von, ne, die müssen so mit dem Spaten und mit so einem alten Maschinengewehr und so weiter aufeinander losgehen, weil wenn wir mehr einsetzen würden, hätten wir es ja sofort mit so einer Eskalation, Weltkrieg, Atombombe und so weiter zu tun. Und ich frag mich dann auch, das wissen die doch auch vor Ort, dass es tausende Flugzeuge gibt, tausende Raketen, die das alles sofort, also diesen Auftrag, den sie gerade haben, sofort erledigen würde. Aber sie müssen leider jetzt da reingehen und sterben, weil ja, warum eigentlich?
Genau.
Also wozu dieser militärische Fortschritt, wenn man ihn dann nicht einsetzt und doch weiter wie vor 100 Jahren und so. Und das ist irgendwie so ein sehr paradoxer Gedanke, bei dem ich mich frage, wie kann der denn handlungsleitend sein? Also sowohl für die Befehlsgeber als auch dann wirklich mit dem spatenlosen Zivil.
Der Unterschied zum ersten Weltkrieg ist ja, das war ja das Neueste an Technik. Also das sagen, so waren die Kriege da aus.
Und man war halt entsprechend politisch motiviert. Wir haben es ja im Film gesehen.
Es gab natürlich auch damals ein paar Pazifisten, die wurden wie zu allen Kriegszeiten immer ausgebrut. Aber klar, man war ideologisch indoktriniert und es gab nur diese Waffen. Man konnte nicht sagen, ja dann wirft doch einfach eine Atombombe ab. Aber du sagst ja zurecht, hast ja im letzten Podcast sogar den Vorschlag gemacht, ich will, dass wir Atomwaffen haben, denn dann brauchen wir auch auf keinen Fall mehr Wehrdienst. Weil ja die, genau, dann brauchen wir dich nicht. Du musst nicht mit Hacke und Beil losziehen, sondern wir werfen dann entweder die Atombombe, beziehungsweise wir haben die Atombombe, weil man dann sagt ach so, nee die können wir gar nicht angreifen, sonst lassen die diese Bombe fallen. Das möchten wir nicht. Wir haben ja den Christopher Nolan Film dann gesehen, um das schon mal so im Tenet-Niveau zu sprechen. Den haben wir dann schon gesehen und wissen, was passieren würde. Und damit ist man natürlich an diesem interessanten Punkt, dass wir hochtechnisch aufgerüstet sind und dass man aber diese Technik jetzt in dem Sinne nicht nutzen kann. Dann muss also den Krieg trosseln. Aber diese Trosselung geht nur über die Technik. Getrosselt wird nicht das, was eigentlich ja zu trosseln wäre und weshalb man ja auch mal über Drohnenanschaffung sowas diskutiert, nämlich um Soldatenleben zu schützen. Also diese ganze Drohnen-Debatte in Deutschland, wir hatten das hier, das hier alles läuft nur, wir schützen Soldatenleben, wollen sie etwa nicht Soldatenleben schützen. Das ist die Frage, die gestellt wird. Und hier sagt man, und zwar von beiden Seiten, das will ich betonen, sagt man, ne, wir lassen die Männer sterben.
Wir haben zwar die Technik, sie zu schützen, aber wir machen es nicht. Und sie müssen aber trotzdem. Das ist so die…
Und ich will noch mal sagen, also der humanitäre Punkt ist mir nur wichtig. Hier geht es ja, wir reden ja hier mal nicht über die geopolitischen Interessen oder sowas, sondern geht es ja wirklich um die humanitäre Sache. Wenn man währfähige Männer im währfähigen Alter nicht ausreisen lässt, dann ist das falsch und auch eigentlich nicht zu dulden. Und eine linke Position wäre zu sagen, dass die ausreisen. Und eine linke Position wäre auch, wir nehmen alle auf. Das wäre eigentlich die Position, die humanitär wäre. Alles andere ist dann wieder interessengeleitet und was weiß ich, darüber kann man dann anderweitig diskutieren. Ich will auf einen Artikel hindeuten, weil ich im letzten Salon was aus der Jungen Welt vorgelesen hatte über Rekrutierung. Und da denkt man dann so, naja, gut, Junge Welt. Aber ich habe hier noch mal einen Artikel Tagesschau. Marc Dugge, 9. März, schreibt, es funktioniert ein bisschen wie eine Blitzer-App. Die Autofahrer warnen nur, dass Kiev-Povistka nicht vor Radarfallen warnen, sondern vor Soldaten. Jenen, die in der Stadt Wehrpflichtige ansprechen, deren Papiere verlangen und sie zur Musterung schicken. Kiev-Povistka ist ein Kanal des sozialen Netzwerks Telegram. Die Nutzer alarmieren sich hier gegenseitig. Metro, Polytechnisches Institut, nahe der Pizzeria Domino. Dort wurde jemand von der Armee angehalten. Vielleicht Dokumente-Prüfung heißt es dort. Ein anderer schreibt, sie waren neben dem Kindergarten. Sie gingen dort in die Hinterhöfe in Uniform und mit einer Mappe. Der Telegram-Kanal gibt eine Ahnung davon, wie zumindest unter einem Teil der ukrainischen Männern, die Angst umgeht, wie vorsichtig sie sich in der Stadt bewegen, um nicht in die Arme von Rekrutierern zu laufen. Auch der 25 Jahre alte Sergej hat Angst davor. Schon im Sommer sagte er uns, er habe nicht die Anlagen zum Krieger. Jeden Tag werden Menschen beerdigt, nicht nur Dutzende, sondern Hunderte. Da verstehst du, dass du dein Leben aufs Spiel setzt. Jeder macht sich Sorgen, manche Leute bleiben sogar zu Hause. Sie sind so paranoid, dass sie nicht mehr auf die Straße gehen, nicht ins Kino, ins Theater oder auf öffentliche Plätze, wo sie die Einberufungsbefehle bekommen können, sagt Sergej. Seitdem sei die Angst nur noch größer geworden, erzählt Sergej am Telefon. Man denke nur an die Kämpfe in Bachmut. Und in Bachmut haben wir ja selbst dann von Leuten wie Paul Ronzheimer gehört. Das geht nicht vor, das geht nicht zurück. Die verschleißen sich gegenseitig. Erst hat man es eine Zeit lang gemacht, weil man sagte, naja, auf sieben tote Russen kommt nur eine Ukraine, aber das sind so zynische Rechnungen. Und das geht ja immer weiter und weiter. Und da war ja sogar dann das ukrainische Oberkommando gegen Zelensky. Und Zelensky hat ja trotzdem gesagt, nein, das ist ein symbolischer Ort, der da verteidigt werden muss.
Ja, Zelensky hat ja Bachmut namentlich genannt vor dem Kongress. Also da vor beiden Kammern in Amerika gesprochen hat. Und meinte, also Bachmut steht, ich war gestern noch da. Und es scheint ja ein echter Trigger gewesen zu sein für die Russen, um jetzt Bachmut besonders in die Mangel zu nehmen.
Ja, und zu dem Thema Deserteure, da hatten wir auch im Januarsalon in Texas ein Handelsblatt. Da ist es ja noch nicht klar gewesen, wird Zelensky wirklich dieses neue Gesetz unterstreiben, das Deserteure harsh bestraft. Auch Leute, die schon zu spät kommen zum Dienst und so Sachen, also wo wirklich ganz hart durchgegriffen wird. Dazu heißt es jetzt, 5. Februar, Politico. Präsident Zelensky weigerte sich am Donnerstag sein Veto, gegen ein neues Gesetz einzulegen, das die Strafen für fehlbare Militärangehörige verschärft. Er wies damit eine Petition zurück, die von über 25.000 Ukrainern unterzeichnet worden war, die das Gesetz für zu hart halten. Der Schlüssel zur Kampffähigkeit der Militäreinheiten und letztlich zum Sieg der Ukraine ist die Einhaltung der militärischen Disziplin. So Zelensky in seiner schriftlichen Antwort auf die Petition. Und da sollen wir natürlich kämpfen, auch da Leute freiwillig und aus Idealismus oder was auch immer. Aber es ist keineswegs so, dass es einfach die Repräsentanz der Bevölkerung ist. Seit wann identifizieren wir Regierung zu eins zu eins mit der Bevölkerung? Da muss ich auch sagen, alles, was Christian Lindner macht, ist richtig, denn er ist ja gewählt. Ja, er ist ja unser Chef, zumindest was die Finanzen anbelangt. Also nur diese Ausführungen da. Wie ist es bei den russischen Rekruten nun? Die Ausrüstung ist keine gute.
Das ist die Vorausgabe, die dort oben ist.
Sie haben uns hier ohne Training, ohne was zu tun.
Sie haben uns immer um uns herum geblieben.
Unserer Division, die Kantemir-Division.
Wir haben keine Training oder Ausrüstung. Es ist absoluter F***ing hell.
Ja, also die Frustration ist da hoch. Zumindest bei einigen, die man dann bei der CNN fürs Mikrofon bekommen hat. Auch diese Trainingslager, wo die gerade frisch Rekrutierten dann hinkommen, sind wohl grauslich. Also wir haben jetzt hier mal nur so eine Schilderung. Man kriegt so einzelne Mosaikstückchen und kann damit was anfangen oder nicht. Wir sprechen hier von einer Mutter, wo der Sohn rekrutiert wurde. Wir hören uns das mal ganz an.
Wenn sie fragte, warum sie das so tun, ist das ganz interessant, wir können mehr über diese Atitüden reden, aber er sagte, ich bin ein Mann, es ist meine Pflicht, mein Land zu verteidigen, und später oder später wird ein Anrufkabell kommen. Jedenfalls, also sie waren mit viel Fanfare aufgeschaut, und das ist in jeder Stadt passiert, viel Geheulung, viel Flaschen, als Relative sagen Tschüss und schicken sie auf die Busse, zu den Training-Kampen. Er hat den Training-Kampen hundreds of miles in Novosibirsk erreicht. Die Militärer verändern ihre Version. Zuerst sagten sie, dass er im Schlaf gestorben ist. Dann sagten sie, dass er einen Herzangriff hatte, obwohl sie sagen, dass er keine Herzangriff hatte. Dann sagten sie, dass er von Alkoholverzögen gestorben ist. Drei, sogar in diesem Camp in Novosibirsk, von denen einer sicherlich ein Knallattack war.
Eine ungeheure Barbarei, die man da hört, man kann diese Podcasts kaum vertragen.
Was machen denn diese Russen da? Ich verstehe das gar nicht. Denen fehlt es ja auch an Männern. Und trotzdem so eine Verschwendung.
Ja, es ist verrückt. Dann gibt es ja noch diese Gruppe Wagner. Da geht man laut BBC davon aus, dass die inzwischen 50.000 Kämpfer in der Ukraine haben. Und vor dem Einmarsch Russlands hatten die 5000 Leute. Also die hat sich auch extrem vergrößert, diese Gruppe. Und gehört ja diesem komischen Geschäftsmann da, der den Spitznamen Putins Koch trägt. Und was ich dann im Guardian las, 31. Oktober 22, da heißt es, afghanische Spezialanheiten, die an der Seite amerikanischer Truppen kämpften und nach dem chaotischen Abzug der USA im vergangenen Jahr in den Iran flohen, werden nun vom russischen Militär rekrutiert, um in der Ukraine zu kämpfen, so drei ehemalige afghanische Generäle gegenüber der Associated Press. Sie sagten, dass die Russen Tausende der ehemaligen afghanischen Elite-Kommandos in eine Fremdenlegion locken wollen, indem sie ihnen regelmäßige Zahlungen in Höhe von 1500 Dollar pro Monat anbieten und ihnen und ihren Familien sichere Zufluchtsorte versprechen, damit sie nicht in ihre Heimat abgeschoben werden, wo sie, wie viele annehmen, in den Händen der Taliban sterben würden. Sie wollen nicht kämpfen, aber sie haben keine andere Wahl, sagte einer der Generäle. Also das heißt, Leute, die auf der westlichen Seite gekämpft haben, die damals im Stich gelassen wurden, die jetzt den letzten Ausweg sehen, ich kämpfe da eine Weile mit und wenn ich dann überlebt habe, dann sind meine Familie und ich frei. Es ist absurd, hier Steve Rosenberg von BBC darüber, dass die Russen nicht an die Front wollen.
Wir haben von den Schwerpunktinnen und Schwerpunktinnen gehört, und ihren Eltern, die uns über Soldaten gesagt haben, dass sie in Russland verletzt wurden, in Basements, Seller, in russisch verletzten Ukraine, für die Refusion, zurück zu der Frontlinie zu gehen. Zum Beispiel haben wir einen Mann gesprochen, den wir Sergei nennen, über seinen Sohn Stas, der ein russischer Waffenoffizier war, der in Ukraine gerettet wurde. Sergei und Stas sind nicht ihre echten Namen, wir haben diese geändert, um ihre Identitäten zu verteidigen. So, Sergei sagt, er begte seinen Sohn, nicht in Ukraine zu gehen. Der Vater befürchtete die russische Waffe. Er hat seinen Vater gebeten, dass seine Gruppe in eine Waffe mit keinem Kopf war, es gab keine Intelligenz, und keine Vorbereitung.
Ja, so sieht es da aus. Und ich würde sagen, wir beenden das doch sehr düstere Thema, aber das vielleicht noch mal Leute ein bisschen ins Umdenken bringt, was eigentlich Krieg bedeutet. Und zwar mit Maxim, der ist im BBC Ukraine-Cast, und der hat da so einen Traum, den er formuliert, wo er eigentlich hin will, wenn der Krieg zu Ende ist. Also kurz und gut, er will das machen, was jeder junge Mensch eigentlich mal machen will, ein bisschen reisen, ein bisschen am Strand rumhängen. Und das muss eigentlich ein Menschenrecht sein, dass jeder dem nachgehen kann.
Zu vor 100 Jahren. Vor 100 Jahren ist man ja losgezogen und nur weil Krieg war, hat man was von der Welt gesehen.
Das war ja Ernst Jüngers Anliegen, endlich mal hinaus in die Welt. Genau, und jetzt haben wir eigentlich Tourismus und das wäre 21. Jahrhundert. Jedenfalls lohnt es sich, immer mal wieder da nachzuhören, was eigentlich mit den Soldaten los ist, weil wir haben so viel über Waffen geredet, aber über die Menschen, die da scharenweise sterben, nicht. Wir freuen uns, wenn wir uns wiedersehen im Salon nächste Woche. Dann sprechen wir wie schon angekündigt über die Orange Pille. Warum Bitcoin weit mehr als nur ein neues Geld ist, von Ijo Mamang.
Hast du schon reingelesen?
Ich habe schon reingelesen. Ja, du willst ja schon irgendwas von mir wissen, aber ich kann, guck mal, es fängt schon an mit im Film Matrix. Steht Neo vor der Wahl.
Ist das wirklich für Leute geschrieben, die noch nie bei YouTube mal sich so ein paar Memes angeguckt haben?
Also wir gehen die Sache mal durch. Und dann, wie gesagt, ich liebäugle mit dem Anarchismus. Und deswegen stelle ich das Buch von Thomas Wagner vor, Fahnenflucht in die Freiheit, Skizzen zur Globalgeschichte der Demokratie. Und dann habe ich noch viele andere interessante Texte, die ich mir aber noch offenhalten, da ich da noch ein bisschen auswählen muss. Und wer bis dahin uns noch nicht genug hat, kann dann noch, wie gesagt, den Live-Salon noch mal nachwöhnen. Dort lästern wir dann über Christian Lindner. Das haben wir heute viel zu wenig getan, aber wir haben da ja richtig mal losgelassen.
Sehr gut. Genau, haben wir alles gemacht. Ich liebäugle für den Salon vielleicht doch noch mal. Du hast jetzt dieses Autothema, was du mitschreibst. Ich habe jetzt zwei, das Ernährungsthema. Wobei es da auch gute Textgrundlagen gibt. Vielleicht sollten wir das im Salon, zumindest mein Ernährungsthema, mal gucken, wie es sich anbietet.
Wir werden sehen. Wir sehen uns dann im Salon und wünschen einen schönen Monat.
So ist es. Haut rein.